Hey,
hey, hey.
Deep down. [music]
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey.
Hey. Hey. [music]
>> [music]
>> Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
[music]
Hey,
hey, hey.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
[music]
>> [music]
>> down.
Hey
Heat. Heat.
Heat up
here.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat. Heat.
All
>> [music]
>> right.
Yeah.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey.
[music]
Hey. Hey. [music]
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
>> Hey, [music]
[music]
hey.
Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey,
hey, hey.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
[music]
hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
[music]
>> [music]
>> down.
Hey
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
>> Black got down.
[music]
Heat. Heat. [music]
>> [music]
>> Pizza.
Pizza.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Yeah.
[music]
Yeah.
>> [music]
[music]
>> me.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Unleashed has been unleashed here in
Europe. New mechanics, new legends, new
chaos. Will Diana bathe utre in
moonlight or will we be dazzled by elder
dragons or will or will Rengar ambush
the competition in the jungle? I'm Shay
Burton, delighted and excited to be your
tour guide through this regional
qualifier here in Utre. And I'm joined
by the one, the only Leo. How are we
feeling this morning? Oh, fantastic.
Been waiting so long for the next
regional qualifier. new meta in
Unleashed. We've already watched a few
tournaments over there in America and in
China of course, but this is some Europe
action and we have some of the best rift
bounders in the world. So, I can't wait
to see how things will unfold.
>> Neither can I. Now, you mentioned that
we've had some events, you know, here in
Europe and across the world as well.
Let's take a look at our road map. Leo,
talk to us about this one.
>> We started off with Leo. Of course, we
had the big Azia win there. Then
followed by Atlanta and if I'm not
mistaken, then unleashed reveal. We've
had Sydney and Vancouver. We had an
Aelia win and we also had the first
Diana win with Alan ZQ just recently.
And now we are hitting it. Let's see how
that goes next week. We also have over
Nene Hartford regional qualifier. That's
going to be a interesting one to see how
the meta game develops in this short
week. But it's not all over there. Of
course, we have two new sets, Vendetta
and Radiance. And then sprinkled in
amongst them, Barcelona, Singapore, and
Los Angeles. And at some point, we get
some news about that regional and how
that's all going to pan. That's going to
be on there somewhere. But that is our
2026 road map. What we're looking
forward to here. But of course, for this
weekend, it's all about UTRE unleashed
here in Europe. And we have seen so many
decks develop over time. I cannot wait
how things are changing. decks like
Mastery, which was always a late game
ramp deck, which with with units like
White Flame Protector, or then Vilemore
when it came out, people are running the
arena's greatest. Now, what madness will
we see this weekend? What kind of crazy
developments have people cooked up?
Well, if you like crazy developments
like me and Leo do, you know, one thing,
one place you got to start Rift Bounders
is get involved at your locals. I love a
locals. That's where you can get out
your fun cards from your binder. try
them out. If you're anything bit like
me, the decks can get a little bit
quirky, but that's where you're going to
have fun.
>> Yeah, and the quirky decks can also give
you a high chance of a best of legend in
one of those regional qualifiers. Also,
the friends in along the way are not to
be underestimated yesterday at the preq
tournament. I've seen one of my locals
sitting at table two in round three or
four. So, I was pretty proud of him.
It's always cool to see how the players
around you develop and how they are
overcoming themselves.
>> There we go. So, I have a question for
you. You mentioned best of a little bit
there. If we have some players who are
in this hall, we can see over there and
the viewers at home. If they want to
compete for a best of, they have a
tournament to get through here in Utre.
Talk to us about the sort of schedule
and how that works.
>> Yeah, of course, you are playing the
Swiss rounds first. On Saturday, it's
eight rounds of Swiss and then there is
a cutoff. Not everyone gets to play on
Sunday, I suppose. And then on Sunday,
five more rounds of Swiss. So, we have
13 rounds in total where you're going to
be paired up against people with similar
scores of yours and then the almighty
top eight. Top eight is going to be
where you want to be because then those
eight players play a single elimination
tournament to see who is going to be the
regional qualifier champion and of
course who gets the best prizes.
>> Wa wa you mentioned prizes there Leo.
Our rift bounders are competing for some
very fun fantastic prizes. How about
everybody? $6,000 US going to our
champion along with though that playmat
there and the champion card as well. Top
eight will get 1,000 to 3,000 and that
cash prizing will cascade down all the
way to top 32. Let's keep an eye on
those future RQ competitive passes
though. Nothing to sniff at prize wall
tickets. Leo, there's a lot of prizes
over there. I'm looking at them. Got
your fancy runes now and packs. We love
that. And then, you know, if you get a
top 128, you're going to get the Vex
playmat as well. All to play for.
>> Yeah. And that's the Vex overnumbered
playmat. This one is incredibly cool.
You know, with a with a big arms and
shadow keeping up Vex there. Vex looking
bored as always. I just love these
artworks. Honestly, the unleashed
artworks for overnumbered might be some
of the best so far.
>> No, I I love that. I can see where
you're coming from. Vex always looking
so apathetic when it's in the active,
you know, relaxed causing carnage. We'll
get a little bit more about that later
on. But Leo, as we look over our
competitor hall over there, we have some
absolutely star studded rift bounders
here in this event. Why don't we take a
look at who's here and who's been doing
the best this season. Oh yeah,
absolutely. We have so many talented
rift boners players we've talked to
already like Alan ZQ and Rocklo and
Prismaticism. They are all competing and
they are the best of the best for a
reason. Look at those performances
there. Sam D. Sherman, of course, also
on number four, has just played out an
incredible final versus Alan ZQ. Got
second in that one with the Renga deck.
Nobody thought that was going to happen.
And then yesterday in the preq
tournament, Renga was all of a sudden
top five most played decks. And then we
have of course CTCG, Deiden with the
Leblanc deck. We have a bunch of bunch
of Annie in there, Aurelia here and
there. And then of course Pedro on the
number eight with the Azir deck.
>> Yeah, that Azir deck. Absolutely love
seeing that one arise on the sand
soldiers coming.
>> There we go. We love that sovereign. But
yeah, keep an eye on this. Some of our
players will be there. Allan's EQ
already a twotime winner. Can he do it?
Can he win another one and do it back to
back? There's only one way to find out,
folks, and that's by watching this
stream all the way through Sunday, which
I think is a very good idea for you to
do. Now, Leo, before we sort of come to
this event, we got asked, you know, what
we think is going to do well, for sure.
And I think, I'm not going to lie, I
think you guys played it a little bit
safe. I did push the boat out a little
bit. So, let's have a look at our caster
predictions and what we picked and why.
I'll get us started. I did go with Pike.
I think Pike is one of the most
versatile decks in the game. If you want
to ramp, you can play Pike. If you want
to hand rip your opponent with that
bewitching spirit, you can do that with
Pike. If you want to remove, you have
Star Cost and Falling Star, you can do
that with Pike. And if you want, you
know, drop one of the biggest baddest
units in the game with Baron Nasher, you
can do that with Pike.
>> You know, that's very nice to have a all
flexible deck that does a lot of
different things. I'm a little bit more
straightforward. You know, Rexi, Void,
Borrower, one of the most aggressive
decks we have here. Constantly relying
or hoping for good top decks, finding
some extra nice things with Undertitan
here and there. has performed incredibly
out of nowhere at the Tanzhin regional.
So that was already a plus and I think
that people might have underestimated it
before. I think in in Europe it was also
a little bit underestimated. Could have
a breakout performance here as well. I'm
very curious to see that. No, it is that
deck can really get out of hand
ridiculously fast. But Rift Founders,
that's been mine and Leo's prediction
and that's been our show opening. I
think it's time to hear from Bandit and
from James about their Carter
predictions and we can get some gameplay
started. So, let's kick it over to them.
Thank you very much, guys, for taking us
through our introduction for our Q
Utract. James joined by Bandit as I'm
stepping in for Medic who unfortunately
not feeling well this afternoon or this
weekend I should say. So, please feel
better soon, Medic. We uh look forward
to having you joining us again. But
Bandit, we're going right into round
one. Uh, there can be no doubt about it.
And have you played it too safe with
Diana? I think it's a fair statement to
make because up to this point, I don't
believe we've seen a back-to back legend
win a an event yet. So, is there just a
0% chance that you're you're right on
this one?
>> 0% chance. Uh, I'll be honest, when when
Allen's EQ is in the room on a deck, I'm
like, there's no 0% option for that. Uh,
I will say I kind of took the easy the
easy route route out on predictions
where I was like uh kind of always bank
on Allen at that point. There was some
spicy things around the edge. I cast an
event last week that like a Kha'Zix one,
but I'm like I don't think that that's
happening this weekend. I I would love
to be wrong though.
>> Uh you will be you will be [laughter]
>> here here's the thing. I think Diana has
all that versatility you're looking for.
>> Can put it down a tempo. can keep up
with some aggro lists, but none none can
compare to the boss himself set. That's
why that's why they're going to
overtake. I I've said it at the start of
set two. Body will overtake Chaos. We
have Ruin Runner dominating out there
being a menace. Very tough to deal with
for pretty much every deck out there.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Except Diana, I guess.
>> Still still not great for the be. We got
room right now.
>> First over it.
>> There is the sav. I feel the flexibility
in a a body deck, no pun intended.
>> Sure.
>> Is will what pull a multi client.
>> Sure. I I get that. I get that for sure.
Um and especially like when we end up
seeing the meta share. I'm expecting to
see quite a lot of decks that do lean
into body like Mi be our day one high
prominence decks and probably into the
Swiss of day two as well. I think we
were talking about this a little bit
before we went live. Um, one of the
things for me though is when you reach
towards the last rounds of Swiss, the
top eight, that's when you end up
needing that high skill cap, high skill
um, you know, expression with what you
can do within the game. Uh, and we're
actually going into a master round one,
which I think is uh, you know, something
that makes a whole lot of sense as uh,
I'm going to assume
it's not mastery meditative.
I I'm going to assume it is round
>> the traditional master the one that came
in the recent set the forecast. We'll
see when we actually get into game. It
is round one as you said, but uh that
would be quite a big surprise going up
against a Teemo. Um Teemo, a deck that
we saw a lot in Origins. Uh haven't seen
as much recently, but I know there's a
lot more hidden cards to to throw around
and people have been trying to make it
work a little bit more. So the
development that we've been seeing at
least in Teemo decks that tend to have a
little bit of a higher win rate
throughout is teams that really focus on
the aggressive side of things. Yeah. Try
and get onto the battlefield with the
sprite fountains on turn one before your
opponent can which is very effective
against Y.
>> However, getting onto a battlefield
which is already taken quite difficult
goes for both of these decks. So, I
don't think it'll be a very middle of
the road type match. It's who can get on
there first and who can make who who can
stick around the longest.
>> And I would say that that's one thing
that that MSI does extremely well if
you're able to post up. Uh it costs very
few resources to be able to hold a
battlefield because of that legend
ability allows you to kind of just,
you know, make a stronghold on each
battlefield with with minimal units and
have a couple pump spells on top of it.
Whereas I've always found like Teemo,
when you're ahead, it can feel great cuz
you're like, I'm going to hide some
cards. I'm going to shuffle some cards
around, like bounce things. Yeah, you
don't know what I'm playing. Um but when
you're behind, Teemo's like, well, I
can't play any hidden cards. Uh there's
nothing really I can do in this setup.
Um and we'll we'll see how it actually
goes as we get through this. So, yeah,
it is going to be uh I'm pretty sure
it's the Masi tempered the uh the
forecast one that comes through. I did
see it a little bit on our side uh as we
came into the game. So, no major
surprises there. Likewise, I think it is
the uh the other Teimo that we typically
see uh at least the uh the the alt that
we're getting from our Teemo player.
>> You'll be you'll be jumping through and
that is this is kind of the nightmare
situation for Teamos to be in. There are
a handful of options to be dealing with
incredibly powerful units. You have to
usually uh access to the switcheroo to
handle single big threat targets. You
have singularity sometimes flown around
in there getting your your turn one two
or turn one unit out there to at least
get stuck on a single battle before the
Ye can unless they are shenanigans and
themselves out of there.
>> Yeah,
>> is going to be absolutely key. The bad
side to this is the fact that Yei will
have to point lead and it's up to Teemo
to push him up cuz if they're just going
to stay like this, Ye will take it.
>> Yeah. And of course going into game one
where you're not sure about the point
lead. Uh I giving a ye a hold
battlefield is start to peak. I'm like
ah that's not what I want to do. But at
the same time you're a whole deck
yourself in some regards. So like Teemo
is like I want that rune. I would like
that that rune too. So maybe I'm going
to just hedge my bets, try and hope I
win the dice roll and and get ahead on
things. But we do see one of the reasons
why the Masti so good in this setup. And
here's some of the tech that people
started bringing in. um the Wininger to
just bounce things back. It's Gust on a
stick.
>> Gust on a stick. You can have a body for
a single extra energy attached to it.
You can hide it away. It will trigger on
strategist as well. The versatility is
there. Furthermore, you deny ye the
hole. You deny ye the extra rune that he
would have gotten in two turns he could
use. And the only thing that fuel on the
other side is you do
>> have the star which allows the ye to get
back out there in the next few turns
just that little bit quicker. Mount that
counterattack just that little bit
quicker. Keep the pressure running on
Teemo.
>> And one of the ways that you beat Yi is
by avoiding combats on Yi's terms at at
all costs. You're basically saying,
"Well, I'm never going to allow you to
be the defender if possible." and and
things uh like the Winds are just like
no I will take the battlefield you're at
but I'm going to do it the way uh of
bouncing it back to hand and turning
this in my favor for the Teemo. So
>> there we have it. One of those pivotal
cards we mentioned before Ruin Runner
spot it. Now if you have the opportunity
it's so hard for a team to deal with
because
>> yep strategist targets you can't target
the Ruin Runner. So your best bet is
that you're maybe going to hit a
Noctturn if they got those laying around
in there from the reveal triggers
>> and the commitment to just develop for a
turn. Take it a little slower. There is
no push of the clock just yet.
>> Take your time. Meditate a bit.
>> And then the other half of that is a lot
of the the chaos removal or bounce
packages. Uh like rebuke's not doesn't
work. Um starcross doesn't work. Can't
target on that room. So so much of that
uh ability for blue and purple to deal
with units just is not effective uh
against this. So from this point we have
to
track what does Teemo do against a
mastery that's already on battlefield on
that Starring. So you're you're now
looking at okay can I can I augment my
units in any way? mentioned um
you you mentioned when it came to like
revealing more if there is for instance
a knockturn in there is there a way to
to like dig for for better answers
through the deck cuz things like I guess
there's a wages of pain in hand by the
looks of it as well
>> this is painful just
>> I will say as a I I play the team myself
I adore this deck playing the team of
strategist days that hurts my feelings
[laughter]
>> just just that little bit but you you
really have to cuz you have that threat
of the rune runner where you know all
right will I have the trickery to stick
around for that the strategist is not
going to pull it off we know for a fact
that the switcheroo cannot pull it off
>> so what options do you have left in this
regard and it's just the the the fact
all right
>> I'm not really properly geared up toward
this match it's all in that sideboard
>> yeah I I think that's rough as well
because I think people
>> had to expect a lot of mi coming in I
think that's one Probably one of the
tricky things here is you're like, "Ah,
okay. I really needed to try and get out
a little bit quicker." I will say
though, you know, that first tricky play
with the Win Singer at least allowed um
Teemo player to to take a little bit of
an advantage in the beginning of the
game. But everything that is coming now
from Ye is like the stuff that feels
like a problem. However, we're going
into our first real showdown of RQ.
>> Utracted buffed up. Ruin runner is
already quite difficult to deal with.
goes through.
>> Yeah, that that is trouble for you. Um
and you could see the little tip there.
Yeah. Yeah. I believe that was a hidden
switcheroo if I can.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> So that is painful already to cuz that
painful is one of the most painful.
Switcheroo is one of the most important
cards in a team deck because it allows
you to hold those battlefields with
let's say only a few bodies which is
usually low on our might scale. Trade
very efficiently. Dodge yourself that
double power cost. Keep your economy
running. And now that you are beaten off
of both of the battlefields, this is the
point where you start to really sweat as
a team up because what is your way back
in?
>> You're going to have to be looking for
either a singularity uh unchecked power
if if you're if you're running that in
your list.
>> And those options are quite dramatic.
Yeah. One thing that's not important for
this match up, but I think it's worth
mentioning because we saw it in hand,
the Axan the main deck gear hate. Uh
let's focus back in on this exact turn
though as we get guerilla warfare coming
through
>> and you're getting back the switcheroo
that is you're going to have to pay for
it if you want to push through and take
into account this master he he's not
left powerless
>> attempt to come here
>> he still has a fair amount of resources
back to go and I think we know for a
fact
>> that that punch first is ready to go can
be responded with
>> in the uh tricky situation of having to
switch roofers you always know that
[laughter]
because his action speed, you you kind
of have to go, well, I'm going to do it
now and then just hope that you don't
have anything on the back end. Like,
please don't have any pump spells that
have resolved once my switcheroo goes
through.
>> There's really two trains of thought
>> where you can be at uh in the game, and
it's either play around the worst
outcomes every single time.
>> We see a lot of calculated players do
this. Oh, I need to play on every single
threat. Just imagine they always have
it. the other side of the spectrum will
lean a more aggressive way of make them
have it. If they don't have it, the the
rewards for me I'll be in such well in
this case at least be in a playable
state again.
>> Alas,
so the switcheroo has resolved. Now it's
uh onto our next passive priority. See
where this goes is uh
it is six to three. So the thing is if
you punch first there's things like uh
hard bargain for instance that would
just say nope not going to allow you to
do that from this situation. So you do
have to be careful of of of getting
blown out too too much
and you have to keep in mind the
pressure is still on the team in this
regard because the yei is still ahead in
in pacing. If you're looking at this is
only the start now you have to get rid
of a ruin runner as well. I'd like to
see you switcheroo that one
>> or not.
>> Spoiler alert you can't. [laughter]
>> No. Exactly. is couple Teemos will go
over to the Starring in order to bolster
up that Wind Singer. That would have
been a little bit of a precarious
position leaving just a one might unit
on that battlefield alone. But at this
point, when we pass the turn back over,
we have to okay, how do you re you like
approach the Starring with what is in
hand for Patrick? We'll uh take another
look in a moment, but it is definitely
going to take some resources here
because in order to play out a unit, go
aggressive onto that battlefield. Make
sure that you uh are able to go through
all three units.
>> And and here it comes really into play
that the ye plays up to this point
haven't been that power hungry.
>> So, he does have a lot of resources to
work with. The cards that he got to put
down were rather efficient. So, he gets
to have a lot of options to be playing
around with.
>> Okay. Okay, so it's just double action
in the sense of like I'm not playing
this for any of the gear hate any of
that. It's literally just a a four might
body for four. Uh, I'll develop this
turn and next turn is when I'm going to
be able to go over the top of you with
just bigger units. And trying to
overwhelm uh a double strategist hiding
out on there
>> doesn't make any difference, but
>> it's a little nerve-wracking, I will
say, cuz that will be 10 cards for you
>> if they both are allowed to trigger and
they're not being charmed away.
Even coming through as the the extra
fuel up here gets defied.
>> The fact that you are looking to take
down which is end of the day only five
might on a battlefield rather simple but
the threat
>> and we haven't had confirmation just yet
but the threat of an extra Noctturn
popping popping up out of there
>> is the stuff of nightmare
>> is first right. Yeah, that that is
actually a really good point. And I
think for people that maybe don't um
often see Teemo so much, I think it's a
deck that has a lot of love and a lot of
hate. Uh yeah, I see what I did there
accidentally with the hiddens. That
Teemo strategist is important that you
mentioned. Um it's going to be that when
it defends, you reveal the top five
cards your main deck and you deal one to
an enemy for each card here with hidden
and then recycle them.
>> So the the the thing I feel so on reveal
we do we we're not doing that anymore.
>> Okay. Sorry. It's only on It's only on
defense and we have to target a unit.
>> So, um, as the showdown is about to
start through on this one, we have seen
and
the
>> little nerve-wracking for our team, the
natural enemy of the team.
>> Sure.
[laughter]
>> Yeah, very much so. So, uh, I I believe
our players are just ordering
>> Can
the targeting goes.
>> So, none. Let's see what they have to
say about that. Now, we're just going to
go through the reveals. And you're
really just looking for as much hidden
through here. And we are [laughter]
>> Oh, wow.
>> Now, I'm not one to say that Teemo is a
lottery deck, but that that [laughter]
is pretty close to to the stars
aligning. And
>> he just
>> in hindsight, you're kind
auction [laughter]
playing it safe. Despite all this, we
need to get through the second auction
because if we do not,
>> that is still going to take out.
>> Show it to me.
>> What a blowout.
>> Oh, and then it gets hit by a
discipline, but still, I mean, that's
going to help trade.
>> Uh, I mean, it's going to it's going to
still take out the entire battle.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it will still be enough. And
we've already used the one gorilla
warfare, so the resources to get back in
this are slimming by the second. So
despite we get nine hidden cards or uh
or or eight hidden cards out of the 10
which is a remarkable result the outcome
the bottom line is still not all that
team favored.
>> Uh just to double check something I I
think our players are going through it
as well. Uh the discipline actually has
to be targeted on the other action right
because as soon as you start revealing
cards the the trigger has already gone.
So therefore like you can't see how much
damage and then react to it. So uh
discipline will come through anyway. our
players will allow us just to move over
to the other action.
>> I'll I'll do wages of pain on that one.
>> Going to be at least we'll be trading,
but it's a it's a dire trade still for
the team.
>> But you have to hold on.
>> Not trading anymore. That's two wages of
pain.
>> Another discipline.
>> Another discipline. I get another gold
token then in that case if it goes
through.
>> Plus four.
>> Double discipline though.
This is a high resource showdown for for
this point in the game.
>> It's a it's a showcase in in
consumerism, right? On the one hand in
inflation and the other side discipline.
Can [laughter] you can you refrain from
uh sorry for
>> spending all that money
>> and at the end of it all the
>> other one? Yeah, I forgot to pay for
>> the other battlefield is just a rune
runner, right? Like the other
battlefield you're still trying to
figure out how you do it. I think
overall
um if I if I really had to to look at
this, our Yei player is on six with a
rune runner on one battlefield and a
lonely power on the other with more
units available. I still think as much
as that looked cool for Teemo. As much
as this looked like you're able to hold,
I think the ability to recontrol these
battlefields is perhaps a little bit
beyond this game state.
>> Yeah. You know how they say, "Oh, you
may have won the battle, but you will
lose the war." So Temo didn't win the
battle, but he will also lose the war.
>> Yes. Exactly. Although I think in style
won the battle with fireworks for sure.
>> Wasn't expecting the the reveal off the
top so much for round one of [laughter]
the day. Warming up on things here.
I do love our early rounds. So we get
some spicy stuff, some some different
decks. I mean, here's the thing. A a
comparable
little more aggressive version that we
saw in Sydney played by by Ashen.
>> Um do really well, make a top eight,
catching people off guard. Now that
we've seen the introduction like just in
our meta share with more Rexas being
played more aggra heavy list to contest
to contest the Diana push him at an
early pace make sure they can't get
comfortable the the the teams are under
a little bit more pressure without that
element of surprise however this game
number two will flip the tables once
again like we said this is not a middle
of the road type match and we do see a
main decked unchecked power which
against the Yi is a dream. Yeah, I was
going to say actually that would have
been what you were looking to to find
that of course is going to going to deal
with everything. There's a Baron Nashe
in the main deck as well. Some there the
Noctturns that you're talking about.
>> So here is that there there is some
conflict in the in the Teemo sphere
about main decking the Baron Nasher.
>> Sure.
>> Um because Teemo burns through runes
like no one else. Even though you can
pay the energy to hide the cards because
you need them out there very quickly.
You are often like if you go on turn
one, you will play the sprite fountain
which will cost you one of your runes.
>> You are more than happy to sacrifice
your last rune to tuck something away in
there. Keep those stacks for hold in
going. Um why is the Baron Nasher in
conflict for for a lot of players?
>> You're not going to reach 10 energy.
>> Yeah.
>> However, closing out the game for Teemo
can be really hard.
>> So having just a Baron to be like, "All
right, you now I have one turn to deal
with my Baron cuz I'm at seven points.
Good luck." can be quite the challenge
even for Yecks, even for Diana decks.
>> Meanwhile, on the other side of the
table, uh looking through this list, it
looks relatively stock for what we've
seen from Master's um the Rengars in
there, of course, like as I said a
little bit in in the first game, the
Axons currently are being mainboarded
because you expect a lot of Aurora in
the room. Um I'm excited to see our our
meta breakdown of see how much Aurora is
in there. It also helps you a little bit
with like the Aurelia match up and a few
other things. But generally, it's not a
surprise to see a couple of actions
right there at this point in the
tournament.
>> What I think is a very tough decision to
make for you right now is which
battlefield to select
>> because both the arena's uh greatest
there loves playing arena's greatest.
Yeah, let's play a shorter game.
>> Yeah, get me through.
>> On the other side, when you look at the
Emperor's Deis,
>> yeah,
>> Teemo loves playing that. I'll take it
with a sprite. pay one, get a permanent
token instead.
>> Yep. Get my Teimo back in hand if that's
the one.
>> If uh if they're stuck, um which I mean
you could already do with your legend.
But now I now I get a free sand soldier
for it.
>> Exactly. You leave something behind. You
uh you're able to to kind of make that
conversion. So there's plenty of of
differences that that those battlefields
make. I mean, I said in game one that uh
you know, giving your opponent the the
hold and channel was something perhaps
you don't want against E. Maybe these
two battlefields you don't want against
Teemo. As you said, it
>> it's it it's it's two decks that really
want similar game plans to unfold in
front of them. The pacing set out will
be very different. And now that Teemo
gets to go first,
>> he has to capitalize on it. Right.
>> Right.
>> At this point then you look over at the
Y, there are so many good early game
options. Like I still think Scuttle Crab
is absolutely one of the best cards
right now in the game. any card that
will replace itself. And by replacing
itself, I mean when you play it, you
draw a card. So, you're already neutral.
And then you get a body that can score a
point. And then you get the ye legend
ability, which is going to make it
harder to break. And then you get
information.
>> What? No.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Believe it or not, you get
to see your opponent's hand. Like, and
all of these things, I think people look
at them in a vacuum and say, none of
them on their own are quite that good.
But you put them all on one card with
one legend, you're like, this is insane.
>> And if that's still not good enough for
you, those hidden cards. Yeah, I will
have a look at those as well. Oh, you
want to play more hidden cards after?
I'll be having a look at those as well
since you you can look at hidden cards
for the entirety of the turn.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, of course,
>> scuttle crab
>> like you said before, even though
usually a herbivore natural predator
option
>> the first time. Yeah, but I didn't mark
it in.
>> So, how I'm looking at this like how
important do we think is going to be
>> to get That's a handful of not units. I
guess this is Sprite fountain in there,
but is that your like that's good enough
for me in the early game in this
situation?
>> Um, so what you're looking for is
usually
>> a sprite fountain and then a unit to
hide so that you can in fact hold.
>> Yeah, cuz that's what I'm I'm thinking
is like the bait with Teemo is like,
well, I guess I'll take that to hand,
shuffle it in, and hope I have a
different sleeve on [laughter] so that I
you you don't know that I only have that
as my unit. That's what I was a little
bit alluding to on on the rest of
things, but in this situation, I don't
think will be possible. Perhaps on the
next turn. Um, we'll see where where our
Te-Mo player goes.
>> In this regard, I feel like you're
you're not able to pay for the for
Emperor's Day.
>> Do you really want to negate that from
the Ye
>> because I mean, you have some scuttle
options there. You have some lonely por
options there.
>> Do I pay
>> to get your value throughout?
But just being able to play the scuttle
crabs and
>> it's going to be our team found
>> that's kind of the big question. If not,
I mean we we saw that it was a consult
the pass ready to go.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh yeah, you'll miss out on the on the
on the hold point. So be it. We will
live.
>> Yeah. And because it's reaction speed,
you just do it on the the temporary
trigger. Correct. So at the beginning
instead of the whole reveal.
>> Oh, it it is a Teemo instead. Uh so
>> they took it away from their legends in
our zoom in. Uh the big old switcheroo
now.
>> Yeah, we we got switcheroo [laughter]
>> channel.
>> So we'll be able to get the hold and
then as you said react in that moment.
So ends up playing
>> here
>> onto both battlefields. This is the pace
you were talking about in game one that
you you would hope if you're the Teemo
player
>> and the the the power that this deck has
to just continuously do this. And I am,
I will say, a little bit surprised to
see Teemo bring out
the arena's greatest cuz we saw that
there was a uh bandal tree in there as
well, which
>> I'll put one here.
>> Believe it or not, Teemo players are
very conflicted about.
>> Okay. So, what I'm hearing is Teemo
players can't agree on a lot.
>> Yeah, it's uh they're Jordles. They have
a lot of time to be the discussing
things.
>> Okay. But the the the reason why if you
play Bandal tree, you kind of usually
want it to play when you're going first.
If your opponent takes it, you're not
getting back on there.
>> It's kind of a wasted band tree.
Meanwhile, arena's greatest is great
when you're going second cuz it kind of
even from a from a a second perspective,
you still get to push forward. And in my
opinion, hiding two cards away on a on a
hidden tree, it's a bit overkill. It's a
bit win more.
>> Okay. Okay. Something I I think we've
seen a little bit now after seeing
Patrick's hand uh that might very well
come to fruition at one point. Uh we
actually see a sideboard card of an
Alpha Strike moved in. So what that's
going to be able to do is pick off a lot
of these small might units uh that that
Teemo wants to play. Other than the
Baron, Teemo's list is very low to the
ground on the actual amount of strength
that a battlefield that it is is holding
with. So there's a a potential point on
a further turn where you go okay well I
only have like you know room runner you
can say okay five I'll just dish that
out among all of your units and oh
suddenly everything dies. It's uh it's a
bit of a nightmare to to be against.
Like that is the point where the Yi
matchup can be so destructive
where the the answers that Yi has are so
efficient and because you are very much
fishing in the same pond like we talked
before. We both really want to hold on
to this battlefield and not let go get
ourselves entrenched.
>> That is
>> You can't hear us when I announce here.
>> Oh, you can hear. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Good.
>> Let me see what the players are talking
about.
>> Uh let's see.
>> Oh, don't be shy, guys. I think they
were talking about what they could hear
from each other. Uh at that point
in uh in this situation though, holding
to four um will look to reestablish
control potentially
>> at this point. Do you do you even try
and spread your resources over both
battlefields if you're Teemo? Are you
trying to sneak quickly to that that uh
a point and say, "Well, uh I'm going to
lose the fights, but I'll just take lots
of small ones."
>> There is no tomorrow for tomorrow. you
are uh imagine you're preparing for
winter and you want to hibernate and it
it's already autumn. There's no more
leaves on the [laughter] trees. We need
to hurry it along. The faster you get
this game over, the better it is.
Something interesting.
>> Okay. Even though there is an arena's
greatest on the battlefield, Patrick is
at zero points.
>> Okay. Okay. We'll we'll find out from uh
our team and as this goes whether that
is uh something that Patrick missed or
whether it's something that that we
>> I'll do the trigger then.
>> Yeah.
>> Need to update.
>> All right.
>> Here we go again. Spin the wheel of
mythicality.
>> I mean I I it's a good situation. And
again, no pump spell has been used
prior.
>> No, another turn.
>> Oh,
two nocturns hit in
>> and one damage. I mean, here here's the
thing. Yeah, there's only one damage and
we will be losing our team up for it.
>> But it's very unfortunate.
>> Is that power two units of eight might
on the board
>> is a acceptable consolation price.
>> Well, you just get to decide to you can
decide where to put them and you can
just put them here and then you won't
actually end up losing the battlefield
as it stands now. Now, of course, we can
only assume that Patrick is going to
have uh combat tricks on the other side
of it, [laughter] but this Teemo is has
been everything
that I has needed.
>> It there is a point to be made to be be
spreading out your risk like this by
keeping one Noctturn in base and keeping
uh putting one on the battlefield.
>> Yeah.
>> However,
>> I feel like you're also lowering the bar
for success for a Y.
>> Yeah. Do you at this point looking at it
like there's a couple options out here?
We see a dis Oh, okay. There's some some
important things in hand as well on my
cursor side. Um, do you have to
discipline alpha strike? Do you have to
say I I can't lose this ye I'm too far
behind in the in the point game and do
you just say I have to I have to pump
this and then I have to hit this and
this and just be able to survive through
>> if I play off strike.
>> Oh, it's Yeah. So
>> let's let's have a look at what they're
saying cuz
>> the targeting but before can I play
discipline on top of that.
>> So I believe it is like you said or we
are going over the
>> Sorry I hear you.
So you don't Yeah,
>> I believe they're waiting for a a judge
to uh to to clarify something for them.
It looked like we were talking about the
targeting.
>> No.
So, I think the uh players are just
speaking to the judges on a uh
interaction there as we we came through
the reveals of Teemo. So, we'll we'll
get an update for you on uh on stream as
soon as we can.
>> Elder Strike is a tricky card.
>> Yeah, because with the the the target
selection of both the unit and the the
target that you're picking and how the
damage gets divided, uh there's a
there's a lot of rules that got to be
clarified. It's good when you're in
doubt, get that judge involved. make
sure it's all clarified. Now, one way or
the other,
>> I'm very worried for Teemo here
[laughter]
>> because he is um like like we said
before, by by spreading out the
nocturns, I feel like you you have to
assume that Y has at least a single buff
spell to push his Y to let's say at
least seven or eight might. If it's a
punch first, it's going to be a lot
worse.
>> Yeah. Um,
>> I feel like you're giving me just such a
favorable trade right now that the the
benefit from getting those two Noctturns
is diminished quite a bit.
>> I'll switch.
>> So, we had the alpha strike
>> get damage twice.
>> Use. Now, we're going to have a a
switcheroo.
>> So, I got
>> which I believe was hidden at that
battlefield, right? So, it can be used
our reaction speed
>> minus three. No, you can turn him
around.
>> Oh, we're going down the rabbit hole.
>> No, because this is damage.
>> Exactly.
>> Oh, this is might and this is damage.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> My bad. My bad. Yeah. So I damage one
and then
>> got a minus two.
>> Yep.
>> So then I get minus two. So I get two
damages on my guys.
>> No, wait. I still
>> of alpha. No,
>> no, wait. I still have I have a
reaction. So
>> okay,
>> so discipline on top is going to
invalidate some of what just happened
with the uh the switcheroo as well. And
that's one of the other things is
switcheroo is a difficult card because
you have to decide your timing on doing
it because you obviously can't pass
priority and just say no, I'm not going
to do it, but you can always get blown
out on the other side. It's like you
switch and then oh, you had a discipline
on top. Okay, that's really frustrating.
>> Wouldn't it be hilarious if we we have
like another very spectacular showdown
only for Teimo to scoop it right
afterwards anyway [laughter]
in game one. Either way, N like I think
has uh has has won over some fans, I'm
sure in this game on on how it's played
>> go away and then this goes away. No, cuz
then he's at four.
>> No, but you you're not no response for
this then.
>> No, cuz this one was reaction to alpha
strike.
>> Yeah. Then unless the switch resolved.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Ah, you play separate. Okay.
>> I play after after you resolved and I
can play this because it's still on the
chain.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> Yes. That is something that is really
important. the switcheroo has to resolve
first. Otherwise, if the discipline
resolves first,
>> uh it's the team player that gets the
benefit of the discipline. You you have
to have that go. And that's something I
think catches out players sometimes is
the chain does not have to fully res.
>> You can resolve step by step and say,
"No, your switcher will go. My alpha
strike has not resolved yet." And then
I'll discipline to my I'll react to my
own ability that is on the chain.
>> Like like a hop on, hop off tour bus.
>> Exactly. Exactly. [laughter] Exactly.
You're not stuck on the bus. They're not
like, "No, you joined this for 2 hours.
You you got to stay now."
>> No, you you if you want to enjoy the
view here a little longer, take
[clears throat and laughter] in those
alpha strikes.
>> I'll do.
>> And trust me, Teemo is not too happy
about taking on those strikes.
>> Then it's going to be a wis damage go
away.
>> Yeah. Then
>> on top of that,
>> so combat is done.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> all right guys, we made it. Well done,
everyone.
>> But the end result is I think the way
that the damage ended up being coming
from that alpha strike, it wasn't enough
to eat through the the Noctturn and the
Teemo. So that wages a pain clears out
the mi and despite having the longest
chain ever what started with a master
going into a showdown against a single
Teemo surprise two noctturns uh and
about five spells later and we're
finally at a situation where Teemo
survived the hold
>> if you were to tie an anchor around that
chain you could hold down a very large
container ship
>> uh channel two
>> end of the line
>> we are still in a mirror situation from
what we had
to the point where now it is the team
that is sitting on a point lead. He can
relatively rest on his laurels, wait for
the toy
turn, right? You you are losing your Y.
You have a I think it was like three or
four separate cards invested that risks
havoc upon your hand and except for a
ruin runner, all of the the threats that
a ye can throw out there
>> can be answered by the team um with the
with the existential thread.
>> Yeah. Yeah. as we'll see the Noctturns
head across end up conquering the second
>> battlefield of the 10 puts Nikos in a
really strong position. Now, one thing
we actually saw from the revealed
information come through that we didn't
see in the main board at this thousand
tail watchers now in the Teemo deck
which that is a card that will help
significantly against the Masti. It also
goes through that rune runner problem of
like hey it doesn't target it so you get
the minus three you're able to put out a
big unit. It does kind of go towards the
side of you saying you kind of don't
have the runes. You're gonna have to
spend a lot to it, but it's gonna win
you the game when you do it.
>> And this is the nice part about Teemo.
Did you
>> because you can get yourself so far
ahead as we do have the concede coming
through when Teemo was sitting on both
of the battlefields looking to hold that
with all the energy up hitting card
through
>> game three is going to be a nailbiter.
But to to get back to to to the initial
point,
>> if Teemo is allowed to get ahead, like
even if you do get on the battlefield,
you usually have two full turns
>> to dick for answers. So get yourself in
a position where you can look to
equalize the board unchecked power. The
only thing that causes me worry.
>> Ye is not a deck that overloads
battlefields. They want to stick around
with a single body
>> and uncheck fire is just it's a very
costly investment because it also
exhausts all your units.
>> Yeah, that's very true. You know, I I
kept trying to play it in so many decks
and I'm like, I just can't get this card
to work because I feel when I play it.
>> I do when it works the the time that it
works and kills everything. You're like,
yes, this is everything that I need. But
I was like trying to play in Ahri at one
point back in Spirit forge and I'm like,
I can't make this card work. It does. I
need something that deals more damage,
but this is the wrong archetype to play
it in. There's
>> I just love theation of Ari calling in
unchecked powers, [laughter]
>> clear out the battlefield.
>> Exactly. Exactly. Not exactly what uh
what you're looking for. And uh thank
you for joining us everybody early here
in Utrex. If you're waking up with a
team Oi matchup, I don't think uh
anybody expected it either, but uh happy
to in round one take you through some of
our lesser scene decks. Um, at least
since Origins, I mean, Teemo was played
quite a bit at the beginning.
>> Step aside, coffee and tea. It's time
for YMO and Teemo.
>> Yo, and Teemo. I'm I'm I'm coining it.
>> That's fair. It is the YMO matchup. Um,
and it does have some niche
interactions, I think. Um, hidden cards
are always
keeping in mind all of the the potential
paths in front of you when a deck is
full of hidden cards is incredibly
difficult, especially when you're not
warmed up. When you run uh into a deck
that has three hidden cards, three of
that is easy.
>> Yeah, five hidden cards. I can work
around five hidden cards. Temo plays 20
plus hidden cards in certain in certain
lists. Then it's like, well, surely
surely he played a sprite there. He
wouldn't play the switch. He wouldn't
hide the switcheroo there because then
he can't hold it. Obviously, I will be
attacking that one. Like the the mental
warfare that you're putting your
opponent through is very uh it's very
Bandal City-esque. Well, and and now
we're going to Bandal tree on uh on our
third game, which means that the hidden
cards just everywhere. It is all about
getting that two drop quickly.
>> If the Yei misses the two drop, they
might be in a world of trouble. Expect
aggressive mulligans to dig as deep as
they can. I mean, there's plenty of of
hits out there, but end of the day, it's
a card game all the same.
always will have uh that RNG factor.
Number of times I've I've mulliganed and
be like, "Well, I really hope the top of
my deck is kind to me today." And
>> they sense your fear.
>> They It Yeah, the top cardio deck does
know. It's like
>> they're like printers.
They They can sense, oh, you really need
me. No, no, no. I'm out of magenta.
[laughter]
>> Just going to break today.
>> Yeah. Good luck.
>> So, round one. Uh if you don't want to
wake up to to play round one, you can
hit up your local summoner skirmish and
uh win your skirmish and skip round one
at an RQ. Uh if not, you can show up and
have a match up
>> exactly like this.
>> Hey, I know. I was going to say, all
right.
>> See, it's it's it's good to to wake up,
get that first point going, make sure
we're we're all on the same page.
>> Will we get through it?
>> You need coach.
>> Yeah, we need to mulligan first. It's uh
something that we see relatively
frequently. Patrick reveals the top
three cards of his rune deck instead of
uh drawing at that point. So the judges
are going to going to sort that out.
>> So this is a lovely opening position um
for for for our our team player to be
in. It is going to be a little more
tricky though because
>> when you got go second as Teemo, but you
do have access either the sprite burst
or fountain, you are still getting on
the battlefield before Y is. And then
you're in a similar position
to the Y
>> to dislodge the team up on the
battlefield because he can't just hide
out on the other one because he'll be
behind.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. is our judges are
just going through uh start a game
procedure just where uh it happens
people just reveal you know you're
playing feature match round one and RQ I
think everybody would do it at that
point I've I've definitely done that uh
skirmish I'm like I'll draw from the
wrong ah
>> the it's it's been a long day for these
players uh you know RQs are notoriously
marathon-like experiences
>> if you've never played in a featured
match the ability to forget how to do
the basic things of a card game I forget
how to shuffle, you know, like that kind
of thing when you when you play in a
feature match. But
>> another notorious one, counting past
three is suddenly a lot more difficult
than wildly difficult. Uh anytime that
there's like a live camera, a live
microphone around you. So
we are heading into uh the mulligans. Of
course, my cursor will wait for
Patrick's decision on mulling. So there
is a lot to to get through here in
mulligan and there's not a lot of time
to be talking about it but there
mullying away your bombs feels bad. It
feels really bad but if you can't even
get to it you need to secure yourself a
solid early game especially against a
deck like Teemo that can punish a weak
early game.
>> Yeah, that is very true. It's always one
of those ones though where you're like,
I really wish I wasn't sending it to the
bottom, but I think I have to in order
to just play this matchup out. Lonely
Pro is going to drop as the first place
sprite call in response. This was one of
the the moments where he said you can
get out earlier than the Yei even going
second with this Teemo.
>> We we just saw a little glimpse of it,
which is very in character. Uh but the
the Evelyn has been been spotted on the
Teemo site where
>> if you charm on a stick, it's pretty
pretty lovely. If you can play it on
your own turn from from hidden
messing with the board state, it is I
mean there's a reason people love to
play charm. They love to play Moonfall.
Teemo gets to dip in that pool as well.
>> Yeah, I actually uh have really enjoyed
playing uh with Evelyn and being able to
use that as you said, charm on a stick.
But you do have to remember again people
who don't play against Evelyn a lot, it
is only on your turn if it's revealed.
If you have to reveal it on your
opponent's turn,
>> she's just a unit.
>> She [laughter] just is helping out.
>> He's just chilling.
>> It's that Evelyn when you're like in a
game that isn't hiding in the jungle
anymore. They're just like running
around in the lane and you're like,
"What are you doing in League?" You're
like, "Please don't do this." as uh
there's the Miy
Temo coming from the reveal
>> and and that is the the nice part of
having the strategist in your champion
zone
>> if need be and you don't have a hitting
unit in hand. You can just drop it from
the champion zone. Ensure yourself that
you're getting that whole trigger. And
now once more we have more options
available to be hiding more cards. And
it is really really key right now to be
hitting the consult the pasts otherwise
you are burning through your hand
quicker than you can answer for.
>> Is that perhaps one of the reasons why
we didn't see the double hide at the
beginning? Cuz of course Bandal tree is
going to open up that option of like you
can hide an additional card there like
having control like is that one of that
uh conversation topics there where you
don't want to damp you don't want to
burn through cards too much
>> and also uh it's quite you can't unhide
cards. You're going to have to commit to
to playing them. So
>> having an extra slot open
>> just in case
>> can be very reassuring.
>> Okay. Okay. So here's the juggle with
Teemo where you uh bring it back to hand
using a legend ability. The sprite will
just go there. And this is at this point
I guess more just saying
>> you're going to have to commit things in
order to take this battlefield. So let
me hide some cards here. You don't know
what it is. It could be the Teemo again.
It could be something else. It could I'm
taking back team. I'm going to hide
something. It could be anything. It
could be even the Teemo. And there's the
double hide. Yeah, exactly. And this is
where this is where you have to play a
different sleeve uh the same sleeve on
your your your uh chosen champion Teemo
because you don't want that like hide it
in and up. Well, I guess you know which
one it is.
>> Yeah, it's uh definitely not something I
have done more than once. Whoops.
>> Well, yeah. Now that you mention it, it
sounds obvious.
>> Yeah, every I think everybody that plays
Teemo realizes that once. Um, so they
say the game of rune economy at this
point feels quite tense for Teemo, but
Patrick on on the Marci on the other
side uh feeling quite flush right now.
Has just been able to not really recycle
their way through the early game. Um,
will be able to build into some quite
big turns later on.
I did see the thousand tail watcher in
hand for Nikurs. So I I wouldn't be
surprised for the next couple of turns
to see it
>> be a growth moment for Nik where it's
like I have to build up to be able to
play this.
>> So I'll hold to four.
>> Here is the awkward situation to be in
because of the the passive and the the
lonely parro and jumping up to four
might if they were to defend. The sprite
is not going to start a lot there
>> which means that he can keep up pretty
comfortably. Yeah, they will have to
address the battlefield at some point.
>> Yeah, but there is not that that leeway
we're talking about where team can take
two turns after being pushed off to
reestablish themselves on the board. So,
it's going to be a little bit of a of a
race that we're going to and when when
rune runner is already on the board,
>> no,
>> that race can um require some pit stops
real soon.
>> Yeah, especially when you look at like
the options in hand to deal with a rune
runner are the thousand tailed watcher.
You have to get to the point where
you're able to play that.
>> But is is it even enough? Because I feel
like after that as well, the combat
tricks that Yei has are so powerful and
so efficient.
>> That's a really good point. But if it's
not enough, then it's unlikely unless
you can win this game quicker.
>> Can't live in fear.
>> Exactly. I'm like, if it's the only
option from this point cuz as we said,
Switcheroo can't target the Room Runner.
You you maybe have to look at a
situation where are you able to I mean
he's never going to hold with the rune
runner and something else.
>> Evelyn will get revealed. We're talking
here about the charm stick
>> as he now going to be the attacker in
this situation. Does not benefit from
the master legend ability.
>> The important thing here
>> is that Yi is stepped out.
>> Yeah. So in this regard,
>> you're going to have to
>> make sure you are you're getting enough
damage through, right? turn
>> with enough hidden it should be fine.
>> I'll put on a second.
>> Already finds a noctturn.
>> No damage,
>> one damage,
>> two damage, three damage.
>> Okay, so
>> a Noctturn and three points of damage.
>> But they need to recycle
>> to go onto the mind.
>> Yeah, but here is uh so I can any Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Uh only when play I have to
recycle that one. Oh, yeah. Thank you.
Mhm.
>> So, the Yi is going to end up uh dying
in this exchange. It just play
>> wherever
>> whatever Nikos ends up putting behind.
Uh the thing is if you don't put the
Noctturn
>> to the battlefield, he does just trade.
[laughter] So, you either have to commit
the switcher route,
>> which you don't really want to do. it's
going to damp you or you have to just
say well you're going to either take two
units or an
>> the positive part about this is that it
does kind of push the ghee back a little
bit.
>> It gets you that little bit of leeway
where you are not immediately
sentenced. Yeah. And
>> which one you are left out to dry now
>> kill him.
>> Noturn. Okay.
>> Out on the Y and only being left to two
bodies out there. the sprite will come
here
>> if Ye taps out once again.
>> Five conquer.
>> It's going to be very very costly and I
think you really have to think twice as
the Ye about continuing to tap out
>> against the Teemo that has a stock top
hand. Yeah, we are now at five points
for for Teemo though. So if I I haven't
seen Patrick's options in a little
while. So depending on how this next
turn of of developing cuz just to ruin
run alone probably won't win this game
for for E probably won't turn it around.
It is obviously one of the toughest
things for the team to play around. So
this already is is a pretty good
position
>> for at least having options for for
Teemo.
>> Nikos are just checking they're able to
change rune assignment on what is being
hidden. for one.
>> Now, there's some tells there
>> when your opponent says, "I want to keep
my two purple runes." [laughter]
>> There's some games of the same.
>> There's some very specific cards uh that
we've seen both of already in rebuke and
switcheroo.
>> There's a [laughter] sprite. You will
hide units at the sprite. Nobody would
be hiding switcheroo under the sprite.
Wouldn't make sense.
>> Well, it's also to play it from hand,
right? So, you're also like figning
figning rebuke. So I I mean it's at
least better to do that due diligence
there and like tell your opponent
basically like hey I need two purples uh
rather than recycling the purple and
letting it go.
>> Here is something interesting in hand
that can change the math of the game.
>> Uhhuh. when Trinity Force is introduced.
Yeah. Suddenly that points discrepancy,
that little gap that the team was
working on,
>> it's not that big of a deal anymore. If
you're managing in this case then to
score extra on on your on your holding
rate,
>> that that is going to allow you to catch
up and suddenly it's back on the Teemo
side to be launching an assault into the
Y. And that is just something that Teeos
don't really excel at, let alone if you
have two runes next turn four to work
with.
>> And here's where you're like, well, I
don't care if you have rebuke if I have
a ruin runner with a Trinity Force and
I'm going to start going into a
battlefield. So, looking at the options,
there are not too too many that you're
worried about here that I'm thinking of
uh when Teemo's defending in this
situation if it's a Ruin Runner. Again,
so many of Teemo's combat tricks and and
abilities to to change a showdown are
based on targeting at least one of your
opponent's units. So, not really care
about that.
>> 100%.
>> Yeah. Rebuke this you casual. [laughter]
>> It is. It is. But we were talking about
it in our prediction as well. This is
the menace.
>> Yes. Yes, that a ruin runner can be
>> and leaving alone
>> the sprite just for now.
>> Okay, so it's a tie turner. We'll bring
the sprite over
>> as uh
>> and uh
>> tieer will take the arena's greatest.
So again, not really too many options to
actually fight this ruin runner. So
we'll end up uh keeping the tide turner
alive. The sprite would have had
temporary at the beginning of the next
turn. So, uh, just saying, "Hey, I want
the permanent unit for now."
>> And now you're going to have to do some
math, which is by far my favorite part
of the game.
>> And my least favorite part of the
[laughter] game.
>> Oh, no. I I was really hoping I could
manifest it within you.
>> So, just just walk it through here.
Right. Timo will go up to six.
>> Yeah. Lovely.
>> On Y's turn, they'll go up to six.
>> Yeah.
>> And then Tim will go up to seven.
>> Yeah. And then Y goes up to eight.
>> And then you say, "Congratulations on
winning round one."
>> Yes.
How do you like to to even start melting
that snowball that has arrived a full-on
avalanche on the battle tree is going to
be quite the task and they
>> they simply don't have a lot of time to
be worth it. That's that's the thing is
even now in a best case scenario of
playing a thousand tailed watcher alone
it would only trade uh because rune
random go you can't play it anyway they
don't have the runes
>> it's just not a viable option right now
um so I think reveal
>> oh the the fact that he is going to have
to recycle the unchecked power is
>> I mean I mean clearly the the the the
price card of that card just energy wise
is already quite of an ask but now uh
well the sentencing is almost signed
sealed not yet delivered
>> they're holding on still
>> yeah finds a noctturn and a teemo so I
don't know but they're playing
>> how you're going to be able to to take
out the rune runner though is is half of
the problem
>> especially if you play it on the
battlefield
>> exactly it's how do you ever get the
amount of of might on the back end to to
on your next turn deal with the room for
it. Jumps up as you said to eight points
quickly over two turns
>> and going down yet another rune.
>> Yeah, Charm is going to going to really
hurt at this situation. Ruin Runner not
going to really have any options to deal
with it
>> and Ruin Ruin Runner will stand by. And
as as good of a start as this was for
Teemo getting out of the gates, I think
unfortunately Yei has turned the corner.
>> There is something really sad about
seeing a single Chaos R [laughter]
sit there holding out. But I do have to
to call out
>> the commitment to just play through it,
play it out, make the most of it, right?
Because end of the day, you're playing
against a human. Humans tend to make
mistakes all the time.
>> Yeah, it's going to be a a hide
>> on a wage is a pain.
Has to look for another option somehow.
That'll be the the hold to six.
>> Tick tock.
>> Oh, and alpha strike picked up as well.
That again means that if there is any
moment in this exchange where you're
like, "Ah, that Teemo is looking like he
could build a scary board." Nope. It's
immediately going to get taken out in in
uh any kind of showdown situation. So, I
think we are closing in on our our round
one win here.
>> And and that is really the the position
for Y can really take all of the oxygen
out of the furnace of their opponent
where the rune differential uh in the
pool is just so great. the cards in
hand. They are drowning in options.
>> Meanwhile, Teemo is really struggling to
to keep their head sticking above
>> the water. They're really keen on
pushing off the tie turner.
>> Yeah, they really want to clear it out.
I was anticipating the ready and then
move to battlefield because of course
you want to be able to
>> wage this gets revealed. Rune runner
again, not a legal target. We'll create
a gold token, but uh it's not going to
be enough cuz we're going up to five
runes.
Not going to be enough to even play the
thousand hell watcher.
>> Vex won't do enough out of hand.
>> The last grains of sand ticking away
through the hourglass and out is a
valiant stand.
>> A hidden card. That That is
>> disrespect. [laughter]
>> That is accidental disrespect to this
one. You're against the the hidden deck
and you're like, "Hold on a second."
>> GG. What if I hide when GG's round one
goes to Patrick taking it down on the
Mi. Uh, but I got to say, what a fun
match up and, you know, an unorthodox
one, but a fun match up to start the day
here in it immediately to to to start
off the game where you do get some
amusement chain questions. It kind of
defogs the mind a little bit. It makes
sure that we're all here. We're all
still in the game. Good wake up call.
Good wake up call. Nice warm up. Round
one in the bag.
>> I want more. Yeah,
>> I'm I'm not done yet.
>> Making us think about all of the
different hidden cards at this point.
We're just showing the showcase of uh
what came out recently and and what is
available for our players when it comes
to the blue purple domains.
Uh always always fun to to see like a a
Teemo matchup. We're going to see some
of the highlights here. This is the
reveal of Thor taking out. In fact, it
was the backto-back uh reveals that just
decimated
>> that was Pyroch that was trade of Pyrox.
And I will say getting the the double
knock and throw
>> even though the uh the games were if you
were to summarize them
>> a little one-sided.
>> Sure. Yeah,
>> they were entertaining and that is that
is kind of like the decks clearly got to
do what they wanted and just paint a
boogeyman out there. this is why he is
feared and why we see an such a large
part of our player base.
>> Yeah, I I think that really does uh
stand to why as you said he is feared or
at least he is going to be a high
presence deck here is it is insanely
consistent. Uh it is easy to play a two
[music] drop and then play a unit on
turn four cuz it's in the ch uh sorry
turn two in the chosen champion zone. Uh
and then you just kind of play it out
and by the end of the game you have a
handful of of combat spells where you're
like I'll just plus two and draw a card.
I'll just punch first. I'll alify. I'll
charm. Like lots of different things in
different stages to just keep you in the
game.
>> To me, the beautiful part about combat
tricks is if you are not confident
enough in your current situation, you
don't have to commit to it and save it
for a rainy day. You can really pick
your battles, how how cliche as that
might sound, but knowing when to
capitalize on your opponent's perceived
weakness is really what separates the
weak from the chaff when it comes to Yi
pilots.
>> Yeah. And we'll see a lot of Yi
throughout day one. Uh I I feel like it
in the majority of tournaments that
we've seen recently, Yi does have a
little bit of a falloff going into the
top eight. uh not necessarily as good
success when it comes to those last
rounds of Swiss at least when you have
so many there's only uh so few that can
actually make it through but
>> it's linear right like even though the
the the deck is inherently
>> fair where like it plays a lot by the
rules that are set out there where let's
say a a Diana or a Rengar tend to break
the the the normal rules like oh no no
no I I will be cheating out the tempo
here no if I was attacking with one no
there's four units now good luck with
So, it's really up to up to them to to
decide how will I push through.
>> Well, we have our first winner here at
RQ Utract. Let's head over to Barrett
who is standing by to find out more.
>> Thanks so much for an excellent cast on
that game. I'm Barrett and I'm joined by
our round one winner here in Utre,
Patrick playing Master Yi, the Wu
Bladesman. And I got to ask you,
Patrick, right off the bat, I believe
Master Yu Bladesman might be the most
represented legend in the room of this
event. So I got to ask you, why would
you pick it and then give us that sort
of dominating performance cuz you're
going to have your work cut out for you
if you're looking for something like
that best of.
>> Yeah. Okay. So Alil, I played uh Rexai
and Kaiser and during the preQ, I played
against Julian from R left and he beat
me. you know it was and I saw him play
and I also played against another master
during the pre-Q and uh when I came back
to where I live and then I said okay
looks like Mercer seems to be a fun
legend to play because I believe uh that
is good to have like a legend that add
extra value without paying extra cost
that was that is why one of my previous
uh legend was any because of the two
extra runes so master with the plus two
you always have extra value to play and
you always force your opponent to bring
more and that's what I felt when I was
playing uh on the limb. They said, "Oh,
I like this so I'm going to play more."
And I started to play his uh limb
mastery until now. Yeah,
>> that makes a lot of sense. And I'll be
honest with you, we were looking at the
sort of like matchup statistics with
these two different legends and it was a
lot closer than I would think it
normally is. And the reason why I say
that is because exactly what you said.
If Master Yi gets on a battlefield
against a Teemo, that kind of defeats
their entire purpose of wanting to hide
cards at their battlefields and your
extra two might as well as tricks like
discipline, which you saw a lot of them
across those games, which really help in
those sort of combat tricks because
Teemo strategist can be really scary
sometimes as we saw in that game where
there's two of them on the battlefield
getting rid of your auctionons. So with
that in mind, do you think that sort of
combat tricks and that solidified of
plus two might as well as your
battlefield selections of that more sort
of aggro mid-range type of master Yi is
going to be enough to kind of fight
against things like Diana in the field
as well because you have these combat
tricks, but at the end of the day, your
legend just gives you the plus two might
and it's usually cuz you're by yourself
at a battlefield. Do you think that's
maybe an a downside to the deck when you
go against these other sort of like
control style matchups? So what we do as
bas you always force your opponent to
spend resource while most of the time
you're not spending so they always need
to put something extra right so the plan
against other legends is always to say I
need to make them to spend resource and
there are some legends that are not very
good on defense right as master is and
has a lot of tools also to boost his
might when he's going over so then I try
to do this like uh make them spend
resource then when I know that they have
spend resource they have less less room
open, they use it like some power and
some cards. Then when I go over them and
I can use better my resource that I have
all my runes up and then when I need to
defend again they need to spend more
resource take over. So that's the
usually the plan that I do.
>> That sounds like an expert game plan for
this entire tournament and you're off to
a good start today. Patrick,
congratulations in that round one win,
but you got seven more rounds today if
you want to make it to that day two and
you have a lot of competition in the
room. But we're going to go ahead and
send it back.
Thank you very much, Barrett. And lovely
to see you on our European broadcasts.
We stole you. We stole you. You're not
going back. We're going to keep you
here. Uh lovely to hear as well from our
winner in round one, hearing a little
bit about the ethos around Ye and how it
played out in the Teemo matchup. Uh the
good thing is we get to have more
Riftbound. Believe it or not, we weren't
only going to show you one matchup this
weekend. We were going to just keep
going while our players are playing. Uh
we're going into our second feature
match for round one. Uh, and we're going
into game two. I believe it is between
Diana and Lilia.
>> Well, I'm so glad you you managed to
pull some strings for us there. Uh,
James,
>> I have no strings to pull [laughter]
as uh we'll we'll see where we uh end up
on this matchup. I, as I said, I believe
that is the the decks that we are going
into.
>> Here is the the thing when you're
playing as Lilia, right? Trixie
>> very ephemeral. Okay. kind of hard
as a Diana
chains now and then like oh no no don't
you worry you're going over here now.
>> Yeah the card that can really lock it
all up is of course that lilting laai.
>> Sure. Yeah that's to look at the Diana
side of the matchup. Um as we got sorry
the Lilia side of the match up as we got
Diana on on stream. I think this is a
deck that people are relatively familiar
with now. There are some minor tweaks
and changes that we see from people. Um,
this one I I see an eclipse in there.
Always interesting to see the eclipse
come out in in the lineup, but uh yeah,
as you said on the Lilia side, that
signature spell liing ly and really say
no, actually you don't get to cast any
more spells for the rest of the turn.
>> And the tricky part there is like the
only way to kind of wiggle your way out
of that is if you were to main deck an
abandon.
>> Sure.
>> To to kind of alleviate that pressure.
But since Lilia is not one of the main
threats that people are are mainboarding
against
the game, the first game should be less
risky for Lilia. But we are not going
into game one.
>> No, we're not. We're going into game
two. Uh so we don't have full uh
sideboard information at this point in
the tournament for for the players.
Yeah, we got to got to see what comes
up. Keep us on our toes. Uh try and
guess like was that card in the main
board? Was that card in the main board?
Luckily on the the Teemo game, we uh got
some easy ones. some easy differences uh
there. As we said, good morning to all
of you joining us. Um if you stayed up
to watch football overnight, good night.
[laughter] Now, stay up to watch
Riftbound overnight too for you
throughout the day. It's okay. Just
don't sleep this weekend. Watch plenty
of plenty of Riftbound. We've got lots
for you as uh Soul Ghost on the Lilia.
We get something different as well in
the beginning. And you know what?
We've This is not connected here at all,
but the Hail Mary shot is does if the
rise of like these infinite combo decks.
>> There's the one card that deals with
them like very easily is Lily, right? Do
we see Lolia rise in
>> priority because Lux is people are
playing it. That's I'm meing. I'm
memeing at this point. That's not a real
statement.
>> No, I I've already taken you serious and
now you will be made fun of.
>> It's a [laughter] classic. It's okay. I
don't mind.
So I honestly
>> a seal of any color.
>> I would love to see it.
>> I know, right?
>> That is what it takes to see more Lilia.
>> I'm okay with that.
>> Everybody is playing like combo decks.
Yeah, we'll we hopefully later today we
will see if a Lux or any of the infinite
combos are making it through. But uh
early part of the day we're like, hey,
let's let's just get on with some of
these matchups here with the legends
that we might be expecting to see.
>> Make sure that people get to properly
wake up with their with their Teeos and
Limos, right? I mean, if you're playing
against Lily, uh, she doesn't want you
to wake up. She wants you asleep.
>> And I would like to go over here.
>> Keep on napping, snoozing.
>> This is kind of a problem when you are
>> as into Lilia. Okay. Because with the
overwhelming presence of the sprites,
it's very hard to trade efficient. And
even if you do get a good moonfall off,
oh, you're you got rid of a bunch of
tokens. Good on you. Meanwhile, for the
Lilia to mount a assault onto [snorts] a
a battlefield with an overwhelming
amount of
>> trigger the Diana.
>> Yes,
>> you're not as invested in those those
larger showdowns.
>> And then for
conquer is good.
>> Slight note here.
and another Vex. Okay,
>> but I will say that's always one card
that Lilia hates to see and that is Vex
because Vex just says uh no actually
your tokens don't do anything. Your
sprites sprites don't do anything at
all. Uh they will come in and they're
stunned and you can't move them this
turn. And oh, what's that? Temporary at
the beginning of your turn. Goodbye.
>> How unfortunate for you.
>> Oh, that that's that's really a shame.
No. Uh so from this moment it does
become quite difficult
to to break this uh Diana situation cuz
as well Diana uh only having one rune
available right now in the legend is
tapped. So you do have to always be
aware when that is ready you have that
extra
>> die in the beginning phase
>> energy. It's just a five might unit.
>> Okay
>> here soul ghost explaining shadow
watcher not something we see very often.
He's like just a five might unit. It's
just a five unit. It does the thing
>> sometimes.
>> Sometimes.
>> My my favorite type of card.
>> Sure.
>> Honestly, why why even bother to put
rules on there? I do something
sometimes. Look it up, mate.
>> But at this point, it's looking for a
body. Uh again, when you're playing
against a Vex,
the the card the apathetic wait where
you have to you have to put down a unit
and then wait an entire turn and say,
"Well, I'll deal with the Vex next turn,
maybe if I can."
>> Pushing it out in front of you. Ah, I'll
I'll deal with it tomorrow.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm concerned.
>> Now it's all about all right, we have
finally a unit that can start contesting
next turn
>> that Vex, but you're walking into a
Diana who has plenty of access to the
stupifies.
>> Yeah.
>> When is enough enough for you to commit
to an assault? Because you can't wait
forever as the lead is already starting
to mount just two points now.
>> Yeah. And and part of the problem is
like a lot of the the later game
options, there's going to be a uh a star
cross. Part of the later game options,
>> you would normally look to be like,
okay, I can ambush a vial more. Defy to
the the star is going to deal with that.
Normally, you'd be like, I'll ambush a
vile more, but again, it doesn't deal
with effects. Like it's again, you're
playing it that turn, it's going to get
stunned. You won't deal combat damage.
So, I'm looking at this
>> the main board. Maybe there's a way of
doing like Heart of Dark Ice shenanigans
where you like really really do a
telegraphed attack in the leadup to it,
but uh that is like really easily
readable by a deck like Diana who's
like, "Yeah, I have a million options to
deal with that. That that's not actually
going to be a problem for me."
I guess maybe um if Lost Stand is still
in the deck. We saw it in the main
board, I'm pretty sure. So maybe that
would be another option to to kind of
chunk through it. But for now it will be
the Vex being pulled back as uh
>> Diana will just say I don't have to keep
Vex here at all times. Do we have to
talk about the elephant the room that
there that there's a ground plaza in our
game
>> where all right the the point
discrepancy doesn't really matter when
there are seven units on
>> uh
>> yeah I guess even if the units are
stunned uh it doesn't matter. It's like
hey they're all here. That that all
makes sense.
>> The tricky part is, as far as I know,
>> those sprites,
>> yeah,
>> they're going to stick around
>> unless
>> we're gearing towards that. That would
be quite quite of an angle of approach
>> to to
chew through the the temporary.
>> Yeah, there are a lot of spells and
abilities that you may not end up seeing
uh when you you play against Ailia. For
instance, we might end up seeing uh
there's a couple hidden cards like uh
Keeper of the Masks, which just kind of
says, "Okay, put a bunch of units out
real quick." And the way that the
beginning of the turn is layered, they
don't get temporary to die that turn,
you get them the whole next turn. So,
there's some trickiness there. Um
definitely a deck that if you're Diana,
you're like, "Well, I'm just hoping that
I hit my matchups that I know inside
out." And then round one, you sit down
against the Lilia and you're like, I
think if I slam Vex, I'm fine, but then
I've just got to
>> that's the needle on everything else.
That that's just the beauty of an
alternate wing con. It really
>> kind of makes it into more of a binary
experience where it's like, oh, you
worked so hard to get those seven
points. Would be a shame if I were to
win the game anyway. Now, Starcross is
going to force out the hidden card. it
is keeper last
>> which unfortunately as said if you do
that at the in reaction to the temporary
trigger on the sprite previously then
they wouldn't end up falling that turn.
However, doing it now during Diana's
turn means that they will of course um I
believe end up dying at the beginning.
Yeah, the keeper of the mask original
token does have temporary or original
unit as temporary anyway. Okay,
I
>> to get tricky with it. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's just one of the things about
Diana. You you think you've dealt with
the star cross with the defy and then
you're like, "Yep, fizz. Okay, cool.
We'll just recur that." Do it again.
>> Three basically.
>> Incredibly difficult to deal with is cuz
Diana spells are never truly gone.
>> Yeah. And and because Diana is not in
calm, the third time can't be the charm.
>> Yeah. Fair. Fair.
and and you can tell that that at least
from the play we just seen and you're at
>> there's no such thing as oh I am
prepared for the Lilia matchup when they
slam down the Grand Plaza. Uh I am I'm
fairly certain that is not a matchup
that they have encountered in their
locals a whole lot.
>> Now on the other side I'm fairly certain
Ailia has encountered plenty of ways.
>> Yes. Yeah, definitely. That's one of the
things I've always thought at the RQ
level is when you're when you're playing
a more unique deck, you actually have
weird better understanding of the
matchup than your opponents most of the
time because you've probably drilled
against the the meta deck. So, I will
say I think this probably is quite a
difficult match up for Soul Ghost in
general, but I I I think that Diana not
necessarily just locking a battlefield
with the Vex is,
you know, a sign I I can't tell yet
whether it's like a familiarity of like
I don't need to do that cuz if I lose
the Vex that's more of a problem and I I
want Lilia to play around having to
think about, okay, if a Vex does end up
on a battlefield, what do I do? Or is it
just that Hay is
>> Hay is a great unit. [laughter] Quay is
just good enough on its own that you
don't care about the Vex in this
situation
>> and then I would like to move in here
>> coming out through accelerated. Get a
presence back on these battlefields.
>> You're good.
>> Then I
>> You're going to have to be pushed
>> to
>> and you're going to have to keep your
eye out for the smoke and mirrors here,
right?
>> Yeah. Making sure that they can take
back the Lilia.
>> Another card here.
>> Mhm. snatch some points cuz they are
currently in the lead. It is up to Diana
to overcome that that smaller deficit.
>> Yeah, that's a a really niche
interaction on the specific wording as
well on Lilia Faith. Uh because you're
leaving the sprite where Lilia moved
from. It's also not a readied sprite.
It's like one of the few times that it's
like play a sprite that's not ready.
Like that's that just feels weird to me.
Every other time I play sprites I'm like
yeah ready ready.
Sprites are all followers of Lilia.
[laughter]
>> They're asleep. She's But everything's
asleep.
>> Story of my life. I I wake up exhausted
and then I'm temporary. [laughter]
>> Wait, what at what round do you
disappear today? Cuz I I don't want to
be left alone. So So
[laughter]
[gasps]
>> okay. So that is uh
>> good
>> going to be a ride the wind going to
hand
>> now
>> as you can just kind of hop on hop off
the battlefields
>> filter through your deck a little more
with the with the Diana ability like we
just saw.
>> Mhm.
>> Keep up for now. Launch separate assault
that will start now. Hu move trigger is
on the chain.
>> So draw discard
discards a unit. We've seen this so many
times. So, Huay will obviously get
stronger in that situation. #
>> liftbound focus.
>> Yeah, exactly. [laughter] Show us how
you're lifting uh on social media.
Honestly, have you seen the size of that
brush that he is curling every day?
>> Yeah, that's fine.
>> That's fine.
>> So, it is going to be
>> I swap have a pending move to
>> another keeper of masks.
>> Smoking mirrors.
>> Oh, smoke mirror. Sorry, I was looking
at the uh upside down. It's actually
quite similar. Yeah, smoking mirror.
Sorry. Thank you.
>> One of the other hidden options
>> in the deck
>> threatening the trade now onto the quay
and losing the quay as Diana is such a
painful way to go through.
>> Correct.
>> Currently it's I mean you have some
bodies uh to to go for and with Vex no
longer on the battlefield
>> that sprite is not stunned right
>> so they are threatening the damage right
here. What happens?
>> I will resolve.
>> What more do we have in hand? I mean,
there's plenty of out your way through
here. There's
>> And it's up to you to play something.
>> A lot of roads that lead to roaming.
>> We also saw the ride the wind earlier.
It's going to be way back to base.
>> It's good.
>> Which means uh
>> we get to do it all over again.
>> I just can't get enough of it.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So we'll obviously get
>> you can see
>> the move from Qu.
>> It's important to to get your cardio in,
right?
>> For all for all the lift bounders out
there.
>> Exactly. You know, I mean cardiobound
doesn't really have the same
>> No. [laughter] Well, although if you're
using cardio to track your riffbound
entry into events and here at the venue
that's
>> you have how much next?
>> We've done it. We cracked it. That's
that is my favorite unscripted moment so
far.
>> Eight runs.
>> All right. Now we get to draw again. He
keeps the might. We get to launch a
second assault. Yeah.
>> I'll
>> How many more tricks are up there?
Smoker mirrors are gone. The discipline
is gone. Yeah, you get to stuck up a bit
with only three energy left.
>> Okay. Um, move
>> and do it again. Another draw discard.
[clears throat and cough]
>> Has been a handful of spells for the
most part in this exchange.
>> But there was a fizz, but you kind of
don't want to ditch that.
>> Go to 11.
>> You do now. They'll do it anyway.
>> Nothing I can do against that.
>> That's for time zone.
>> Yeah. Well, fizz is always one of those
ones where it's like
>> four.
>> It it just unlocks your entire
graveyard, your your entire trash to to
be able to be like, well, I discarded
spells that turn, but I can get to play
them all again.
>> And like Fizz is definitely up there as
one of the best units in the deck. But
the only one that beats it probably is
the Quay. And if it's your only option,
>> Sure.
>> they had to discard a unit, right?
Otherwise, they're still ending up
trading because they discarded the spell
last turn.
>> And I get the the the other rational
there is like you look at the rest of
the hand, you see a star cross, you see
a ride the wind, like you're like, I
have options. It's fine. I actually
don't need the Fizz at this moment. It's
like, ah, it is really good. I do want
to hold it, but do I need it?
>> Becomes a little bit wind more in that
moment.
>> And now you're back in that awkward
position where you have to fight into a
Vex on Battlefield. So either you're
going to have the uh conservatory
trigger with right there.
>> Yeah.
>> Giving over more options. They still
have
>> at least four energy available. I can't
make out if Diana is tapped.
>> Uh
>> I think we'll figure it out. But the
point to keep in mind when you're
playing into
>> on her turn, it's really
>> sets of three that you need to worry
about the moon
right the wind plus a stupid like
>> things in that regard. So if there are
above two, you really have to think
twice.
I'm not sure if a brutalizer will be
enough to turn the tide alone,
>> especially when we know for instance
there is star in hand and there's good
targets for starrust on Diana like yeah
I'll bounce raven blue
>> that's fine
>> yeah just threatening to trade right now
I would love to just take out either
>> the Vex or the dependent
>> but I I don't think they'll they'll get
that far like you said that star cost
seems locked and loaded
>> do you gamble and say pass priority and
see if they use a pump spell and you get
even more out of it.
>> And obviously
>> I feel of course priority has passed. So
yeah,
>> as of the right now you are the one
about to lose. So
>> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Sorry. I I
don't don't
>> miss mis appropriated our our priority.
Of course it was soul ghost going for
the showdown. So yeah, we'll starr
exactly as expected. Going to try it
again.
>> Yeah, brutalizer will be getting off
some of that value throughout there.
Another an extra three might pumping
that up.
>> Now
>> one move in. We'll create a sprite on
move.
>> How much will you have left in the tank?
Cuz that Diana is gone now, right? With
only two energy still left up.
>> Go to seven.
>> Will you get pushed over?
>> Play on God would go to nine.
>> It's costing them so much. Look at the
cards that are they're investing
already. Even if they do manage to hold
on, that is such a costly costly assault
to push off the Vex away.
So from what we can see in the hand,
they at least have like an emergency
exit.
>> Yeah. Win for at least one of them.
>> So you just say Hay is the more valuable
unit at this point. You just say, "Hey,
I'm going to ride the win."
>> Happens
>> in this. And
>> here's the thing. X is great when you're
already ahead.
>> Uhhuh.
>> But they're not ahead right now. And if
they are to lose this showdown,
>> right, they're just keeping up. And
that's a replacement Vex in hand, right?
I think the the middle card I believe is
Vex just from the angle the the artwork
looks
>> similar. So maybe just say ah right the
wind
>> right on
>> Oh, they're not very certain either.
>> It's it's an understandable decision if
you're like there's one that breaks the
match up and one that
>> to the Raven Bloom Conservatory.
>> Okay.
>> Is just better for me. So quer
conservatory is the play.
>> Um
yeah
>> and this resolves you get to conquer.
>> I was not necessarily expecting them to
be discarding a unit there
>> because in this I would think ah what
are the odds I'll have another showdown
for the to be
>> for free.
>> Is is that just overly cautious or
>> less for this fight? I guess it's
looking at what resources are on the
back end of like how much can you
actually then go aggressive with will go
in look of your
>> Diana if I can.
>> Okay, Raven Bloom.
>> Yes.
>> Uh
the only consolation right now
>> is the fact that this Diana is tapped
out finally.
>> Yeah. And that is always such a
commitment to make for uh Diana and you
whenever you see all the runes tapped
and and the and the legend
>> you if you cannot punish that
>> they kind of got away with a free crime.
>> Yeah, that plus three as well on the way
kind of an insurance policy of just
saying h maybe I don't want to I don't
want you making a different decision and
going over the top somehow with with
what you've got as
>> proving themselves not overly cautious
at all. It's not paranoid when they're
actually coming for you. [laughter]
So [snorts]
the right the wind being used at least
the one was like ah I would like to be
able to utilize that maybe a little more
offensively at times but still having
another and still having options but it
is just down to the way without the
likes of like a moonfall to you know
bring in more of what soul ghost is is
is putting on the board might be tricky
to hold control of both battlefields. We
might be playing a bit of a tit for tat
on one battlefield at a time right now.
>> And that is where you get pushed to the
absolute limit as there is another right
that we just hiding in hand.
>> But you've always got stack deck. And
the great thing is that Diana can just
go, "Oh, well, if we start a showdown,
I'll I'll use my legend ability for
that." Or you could just do it now and
just say, "Give me some information like
give me give me another option."
>> It it it really feels like uh could you
show me again what's behind door number
uh
>> Yeah. I want I actually want to see the
three doors. Like there's no surprise to
this. Like let me let me see. But moving
back to base.
>> Of course, we'll be able to still move
it with or ride the wind when it
happens. So draw this. Oh, of all the
cards to draw. Oh, look who is at the
top of the deck. Moonfall. They would do
a moonfall at this. They've gone through
like at least like a third close to half
of their deck right now.
>> Getting rid of us. Get another.
>> Oh, this I this happened. I saw someone
do this last week. If both of these go
off, I mean you can't at this point
because you need the the the way. Tell
me anyway.
>> Uh double moonf falling is so brutal.
Like if you thought thousand watcher was
bad like moonfall into moonfall. Move
two units and give everything minus four
is disgusting.
>> Where where are all these moons coming
from?
>> Um yeah. Um
>> they're not two. That's why they're
playing
in here.
>> Mystery resolved. Thanks.
>> So right the wind will come through. Put
on a battlefield. You don't need two if
you if one's good enough is what I would
say.
>> What was true for our Diana where I
finally tapped out that makes it so much
safer to start these engagements at the
same when your Lilia is stepping out. No
threat whatsoever.
>> Go to five with your mask. Huh.
>> Yes.
>> God damn it.
>> Thinking it through. Just going through
all the options. Is Moonfall even a
necessary option? Uh just deciding what
to discard will be Vex. So uh
>> gets the plus three already. So does you
know doesn't have to all in here.
Depends on what comes from this mirror.
>> It'll be saving.
>> That's counter
>> their champion. But what remains even
though the sprite will once again get a
little assist from the mask coming
through.
It feels like with every passing turn,
Soul Ghost is losing grip of the losing
ground, being pushed further and further
back. Meanwhile, Diana, even though that
these showdowns are growing rather
costly.
>> Yeah, lots of resources being used on on
the Diana side, but this is one of the
things that the deck does do really
well. You can utilize the Diana legend
plus also then just the massive amounts
of draw
>> really just supplements the draw, the
utility, everything that you need. uh in
that exchange.
Is that a hard bargain in hand? Is that
the the thought process here? Yeah, it
is going to be hard bargain on the smoke
and mirrors
>> and that is hard to react to when you
don't have any when you're
>> can't deal with that. Can't end up
paying the two. Nothing really.
>> Deck or something. Okay,
>> you have to take into account
>> and then we'll play a stack deck during
the showdown still.
>> We'll see what ends up coming from it.
You have to take into account that from
the Lydia side now even trying to keep
up by launching an assault onto the
conservatory which is open at the
moment.
>> It [clears throat] really feels like
>> as long as you cannot answer the quay
this will keep running away from
>> not necessarily in victory points just
yet but all look at the trash move back.
The more cards you get to see in your
deck, the closer you are to hitting
>> the peak of power of your deck
>> because there's less variance. You you
get to see all the cards. all the
options are available to you or at least
have gone through your hands
>> and that is just so hard to really
compete with
>> as a Lilia and
>> then I will
>> even though they they are burning
through Vexes like it's nobody's
business taking them down in combat
being discarded by the quake
>> that alleviates some of the pressure.
>> Yeah,
>> but you're still not comfortable.
>> No, you're still not comfortable. Um, is
it too early in the day to say that
Diana is running away with this?
>> Just let that sink in for a bit.
>> Yeah, I know. I know.
>> That's
>> I'm sorry.
>> No, you're not. [laughter]
>> I kind of am.
>> See you smile.
>> I know. I'm I'm deep down I'm There's
There's regret.
>> I do I do love a good quon. I'm I'm
mostly upset that you got to it before
me. Sorry. [laughter]
If I'm not here for bad humor, what else
am I here for really?
The love of the game. That's what we're
here for. Um, as Soul Ghost is going to
try and figure their way out of this
exchange. So, five points on the board.
So, you know, there's no way of of
conquering both to win this. Have to get
to eight. So, it has to be how do I stop
the million options of Diana on Diana's
turn? Because
>> remember, all you've got to do is draw
into a fizz and you get access to those
ride the winds that are already in the
trash. You just got to draw into one of
the many options that Diana has to say,
"Yeah, I'll just go to one battlefield,
go to the other. There we go." And
shields are mostly down now.
>> It you you're threatening it. There's a
lot of card and you still you get to see
another card when starts to move.
>> Double stupifier as well in hand is
going to be another two cards just to be
able to see. You got a bunch of spells
in hand to just discard. Even if it is
stupify, you don't even want to pay for
it. And a stack deck on top of it as
well. We'll just say, "Ha, all I got to
do is find a fizz or ride the wind." And
I take this match.
>> We're going to leave no card unturned to
solve this little uh this little
dilemma. Just looking for the answer.
Trying to hold on.
>> Absolute worst case.
>> At least two more digs.
Absolute worst case. You move on to the
battlefield and you just start moon
falling. Just make life as miserable as
can be for the Lilia. Make it as hard as
possibly can be to push them off the
conservatory. You'll get another reveal
trigger if you have to defend there. So
even though the most comfortable way out
would be to write the wind would fizz
and get the double conquer this turn,
>> you [snorts] don't have to. And end of
the day, you're not being rewarded in a
greater way if you're double conquering
or just
>> No, that's true. Winning is winning at
that point. Um, so it it doesn't matter
how you get there. There are, as you
said, multiple ways to you get a lot of
looks on as well. If if you for instance
are using the Moonfall, if you move to
Raven Bloom, Moonfall, bring them in
your defender, you get another look at a
spell. Ah, what do I get? Um, so you can
go through a lot of your deck. Um, even
on this turn,
>> not necessarily related to the game,
>> but I love it when their cards are like
fanned out like that.
>> If you like lift up the bottom cart,
they all domino over to the other side.
>> So, now it's just down to uh
the methodology here. We got to see the
first draw.
>> I I wonder what if you're a Lilia right
now, right? You still have the single
energy up. You're still threatening a
defy.
>> True, true, true, true.
>> So, are you going to try and bait it out
>> as a
as a as a Diana?
>> Oh, well, if you do bait it out, now
you've got the Fizz.
>> So, Moonfall discarded for a draw.
>> Um, then I play for
one.
Stupify on him.
>> Okay.
>> Is that good?
>> Yeah.
>> Takes a stupify. Could be setting up
whether it's just a draw.
>> Action to you.
>> So, do I conquer?
>> Conquer.
>> Yeah. So, conquer to seven.
>> Whether it's just a draw or whether it
is to set up a move is neither
[clears throat] here nor there at this
point. [snorts]
>> Conquer to seven.
>> Constantly just just
throwing little bits out there. Will you
want to defy this or maybe that?
[laughter]
Oh, wouldn't it be so awful if I
couldn't stack deck right now?
>> Yeah, I mean that's the that's the
thing. You only have one option. You you
just have to wait for the the most
significant thing.
>> Uh the funny thing is if it was a ride
the wind from hand, you just then play
the fizz after it. But there is no ride
the wind in hand. Uh so
>> yeah, there were a lot of ride the winds
already expanded. Uh
>> there's I at least two. Oh, it is three.
It is all three are in the graveyard.
Okay.
>> So not a lot of options left there. And
at that point, do you play as if they
have it?
>> And you have to moonful, right?
>> Okay. Just going to go for it. Uh, with
the fizz. I I mean, I don't I don't hate
it in that regard. You're saying you
have to have the def,
>> but you are you are shooting yourself
in. Yeah. See, it gets the fight
>> and now your hold position is
>> I'm not going to say it's horrible, but
it is more fragile.
>> Sure.
>> You still have access to the Moonfall,
of course, if needed.
>> Exactly. And that obviously uh is
something you can play on your
opponent's turn. You don't necessarily
have to
>> decide to do it now, but that does allow
them to
>> untap.
Okay. going to Titan bring back
>> Lee get another draw.
>> It significantly hurts the chances of uh
of moon falling.
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Uh by by 100% I would
say. But what helps the chances of moon
falling is drawing one and then either
being able to discard it or not.
>> Do they have all of their moonfalls in
hand right now?
>> Uh one went into the trash earlier. Now
the second one is looking like it's
going into the trash.
>> I think they have another one in hand.
>> Draw one. How do I hold all of these
moons?
>> Emp.
>> Okay, so not
>> the easiest position to be in.
>> However,
>> first first things first,
>> we need to deal with the tight turner.
>> Get it off of the battlefield. That is
part one.
>> Make sure that they're not hobbling over
to a different battlefield to be
annoying about it.
>> It's going to be tough for for for a
single energy. Got to cover your bases.
>> How much do you even want to invest? And
this is a nice start by just adding the
bodies to the pile.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Just saying, "Okay,
I'm going to need more. I'm going to to
need to go over the top of this at least
to to to hold on.
>> Can we refer to sprites as bodies?"
>> Quite ephemeral, right?
>> Yeah, that's a good that's a good that's
a good question.
>> Let's be inclusive. They're units. There
you I I I don't want to body shape
[laughter]
for all the ghosts among us.
>> Appreciate that.
>> Yeah, that's good. So going up to six.
Good. Going to six.
>> I mean, this game it's tricky because
being on five on that turn just
>> come over here. Get my
>> If you were looking to go to eight this
turn, it's a very different situation.
But there's like a sense of security on
the Diana's side where you're like, I
just I need you to spend enough
resources so that when it comes to my
turn, I have multiple options of
clearing you off both battlefields.
>> And at this point,
the double conquer.
>> I will equip my
>> not impossible, right? You have the
moonfall still ready to rip and roar.
>> And
>> but that comfort where you were like,
oh, we just need to hit the right the
wind and win the game, scoop it up, get
a coffee, go to round number two,
>> that comfort that was also visible
whilst they were digging throughout
their deck
>> is seems a far a ways away.
This is the turn to do it upon.
>> So, we know we're gonna get multiple
draws.
>> How many cards in hand?
>> One, [snorts]
>> one card in hand. One card in a dream.
>> It's all you need. Card in the chair.
[laughter]
>> That's uh always reassuring. Looks finds
two divisi at least in the trash.
>> Sure.
>> He's like, "Okay, well, I have the
resources to
>> nine here and [laughter]
I get to move in."
>> But he he doesn't have two. He only has
a single one in hand. Or there's another
Fizz. He uh
>> Oh, yeah. You're right. They did uh did
did put one in in trash. So, uh
we'll get to to look at a couple more
with on the move.
>> And if you want to take it even further,
right, if you give the turn back over,
they will be spawning another sprite.
So, it is not even guaranteed that you
will in fact um be able to to hold the
battlefield and deny them the double
conquer or the hold. I mean, yeah, that
that's fair. But
>> so even though I mean I think we were
both almost counting the Lilia out a
little bit. She move
>> trigger up the Yeah, I think that that
defy on the um on the ride the wind has
has really punished and at least made
the the options more tricky. So Quay
goes up to eight.
>> Then Rain Bloom
>> still needs uh another one. Raven Bloom
trigger comes through. will not be oh
missing out on that. It's painful. That
that would have been five might ready to
go on their own turn.
>> So that that does explain some of the
emotion.
>> Moonfall going to bring the sprite over.
There's the fist bump cuz the minus twos
on everything would be just too much to
go through in a very close end of the
game puts Diana over Lilia and through
round one with a win. No third to fivey.
I mean, and and and that is that moment
again where you have to make the
decision, am I going to play respectful
or am I going to make them have it?
>> Yeah. And made them have it. Uh but
eventually still ended up picking up the
win. Uh that is round one done, Bandit.
Uh your first round at an RQ in the
books. We're going to go to a break.
We'll do the old switcheroo on ourselves
and when we come back, we'll be round
back with round two.
All right then, Riftbound fans. I'm Shay
Burton and we're here at the Utre
regional qualifier. This venue is
massive with a lot to look at. So, why
don't we have a look now?
Starting off with the trophy. Only one
person will leave here this weekend
holding that trophy and securing
themselves a slot in the regionals later
on in the year. Who will it be? Only one
way to find out, that's by watching the
rest of this stream. But there's also
some other things that people are
playing for here. This is your last
chance to [music] get the best of legend
cards for Origins, and we can see them
all here. A fantastic different way to
play in the tournaments is to try and be
the the top legend for your chosen deck.
Okay, so we finally made it to the prize
wall. For the for the players who are in
the side events, they actually get
tickets which they can redeem for a
multitude of different prizes. We have
packs, we have sleeves, we have
playmats, we have badges. So, it's not
all about the main event. And there's
actually currently an event happening
right now that players are competing for
these points. And there's events
happening right now, a team 2v2 event
and then the pre- regional event as
well. And quite honestly, the scale is
massive. There are hundreds, maybe even
thousands of players right now all
battling it out. But it's not all about
competition. You can actually open packs
here at the event right now. And not
only that, it's actually live streamed
for the rest of the venue to see. We
have to have a look at this. Come get
involved.
Okay, here we go. So, we have two people
opening their packs right now. They even
have a big red button if they pack
something good. Here we go. Let's keep
our fingers crossed.
Oh, here we go.
That's not bad. That's not bad. Hey, we
get the big red button hit as well. Come
on. That's what it's all about here.
Okay, so I was just catching up with our
person who just opened up the pack there
and turns out you actually really needed
this card, right?
>> Yes, correct. I want to play Ivan
tomorrow and in the main event and this
is your alad I'm missing and I want want
to go to play this tomorrow.
>> Okay. Wow. See it was written in the
stars. Best of luck for you at you and
your event. And of course when you're at
these events there's always cosplayers.
We see one there. Let's see if we can
quickly chat to him. Excuse me. Excuse
me. I must say I love your cosplay. How
long how long did it take you to make
that? Well, this is amalgamation of
three years to four years of cosplaying.
Continuously upgrading tats and bits.
Sometimes something get tatted,
something something get broken. So, I'm
always working to improve.
>> For the people, why did you choose to
cosplay Ekko?
>> Well, everybody tells that I look like
him, so I might as well commit to the
bit.
>> You definitely do. You definitely do.
Uh, why is Ekko one of your favorite
characters?
Ekko is maybe one of my most respectable
characters, mostly because we share a
lot of ideas and opinions about a lot of
things. Yeah, I can respect him a lot.
>> There you go. Playing the character.
We've got some fantastic advice there.
Thank you so much for your time. It's
been a pleasure.
>> And here's something I love about the
Riftbound events, the community aspect.
And I think that's immortalized
perfectly with the [music] graffiti
wall. You can come over here, write down
anything and everything you like and it
will stay there for the whole event. And
we can see card shout outs there. You
can see people saying that they was
here. And quite honestly, it's a bit of
me. I'm a big fan. Look how colorful it
is as well. Who doesn't love colors?
But of course, the main event, it has to
be all about the stage with two feature
tables. So, we can feature two matches
per round and the interview area as
well. so we can hear from the winners.
[music] Now, at the end of this weekend,
our finalist and champion will be
crowned here. Who will it be? Who will
be getting the last of best of the
origin set? Only one way to find out,
and that's by getting back to the
street.
All right, then we are back. The rift
has been ripped wide open. It's time to
see who will be getting the best of the
best of the last best ofs from the
Origins set. I'm Shay Burton joined by
Leo. How are we feeling this morning?
>> I'm feeling fantastic. Just really can't
wait to get things going. We've already
seen one really, really cool featured
match and now we have two more up and
coming. We have someone who you should
know if you've been following at least
the European side of the broadcast for
Riftbound. Yeah, we have a pretty star
studed allstar matchup coming at you
here for our Swiss round two match. We
have Squirtle, the Lil regional
qualifier champion versus Rune Breaker.
>> And to no one's surprise, Squirtle is
again on the Zir deck. What a strong
performance of this deck. A legend that
came out in Spirit fortune. People said,
"Hey, this is maybe a Btier deck at
best." And then all of a sudden people
started to play it more
>> and then again it was so incredibly
strong.
>> Yeah, it was such a strong deck, you
know. Actually had some buffs coming in
the unleasher via that soul sword card.
Another equipment one cost equipment
that's what is all loves equipment low
cost and getting those sand soldiers
into play. So it's a deck, you know, you
can't be surprised to see do super well.
always taking a regional qualifier home
and when it's in the hands of someone
that already took a regional qualifier
home, you have to be a bit worried.
>> It was an absolute masterclass. There
was basically no mistakes in his entire
play in the tournament. He had so many
flawless turns with Azir. It's all about
getting those steady conquers.
>> Y
>> and the deck that his opponent is
bringing, the good old rune breaker,
that is not necessarily a deck that can
stop you too much from conquering. So, I
think we can take that away as well.
When we're talking about Azir, it's
going to be the Azir versus Civer
matchup. Se civer traditionally played
with a dazzling Aurora gear, even though
we had quite some time where it was
played with other gears with the seal of
discords
>> and then other cards like Ezreal
Prodigy. Good times, good times. But
>> now it's all about that big elder
dragon.
>> The thing is that this deck takes quite
a while to stop you from playing the
game. Yeah, if you get this Elder Dragon
out, it's really hard to come back from
it. But Azir should have a rather
positive matchup into it just because
you can generate those tokens like it's
nothing before the Elder Dragon turn.
You can push back all of your sand
soldiers and then push them back in one
by one because there's not much you need
to overcome. So I think in theory that
deck, especially after siding, should
have a decent matchup into serin. There
you can see some interesting
battlefields. The forgotten monument is
not something you see all the time, but
in uh Aurora decks, you see it quite
frequently actually. Players can't score
until the third turn. Yeah,
>> it really helps against those decks that
can go wide in the base.
>> Yeah, probably could be something we
actually see in this match up, right?
Cuz as you say, this is like a battle of
polar opposite decks. You know, the
Aurora loves that old dragon to come
into the late game in combination with
flurry of blade and just, you know,
slaughter your opponent as it were. It
takes a long time to get going. Azir,
we're talking about sand soldier tokens.
We we can get them going turn one and as
you say you want to try and conquer both
battle force at the same time and get
points that battlefield could stop that.
>> I really want to point out that Rune
Breaker did something great during deck
building here. Some people have seen the
Lux infinite loop deck with the Renata
Glask and everything and that's
basically a free matchup versus
this deck versus the Aurora decks but
with the inverted timelines you could
take away like 20 cards from hand. But
this actually shows that the Civer
legend is favored in this matchup which
I find interesting.
>> Favored by the legend, but our win
prediction here based on legend matchup
performance and recent form from our
players actually has this down as a
straight 5050. So, I'm intrigued to see
how this is going to pan out cuz as
we've been alluding to, this is a a very
different play styles in decks here. And
I think as I'm sitting down here, I
would assume a has to be favored. But
well, only one way to find out.
>> I think it really comes down if you hit
your important spots. If you find those
rises that when your field actually gets
cleared, if there is a big elder dragon
that might surprise you or something
like a flurry of relates when the elder
dragon is already developed if they hit
their ramp early on then there is some
compact mechanics there with a rise but
that is a very very clean list. The Azir
decks there's not too much
>> crazy invention going on with those.
There's not like those completely maniac
decks that you're seeing all of a
sudden. The decks really do look a
little alike, but we're actually seeing
two back offs. I think that most of the
time you see one back off.
>> I was about to say, yeah, I think the
increased back off count is something we
see we haven't seen a lot of, but you
know, fantastic card stunning something
that comes in there. Scary times. I
think the main addition has just been
that soul sword right in the unleash set
giving you another equipment a one cost
equipment which is all about all you
want to do as is get a bunch of
equipment in in play get your sand
soldiers and then build towards that
signature spell that arise to bring in a
lot of sand soldiers in combination with
your champion Azir sovereign that is
where the game can get out of hand fast.
>> Yeah, you got the ready sand soldiers as
well so you can score immediately
especially against decks like Aurora. I
like the double back off for the Aurora
match up for example because if they get
to play and they want to push in an
Elder Dragon, you can most of the time
prevent Elder Dragon from taking away
three of your units. You should have
built up multiple copies and if you push
it back out, it's going to be sometimes
tough for them to get back in there.
Also interesting one VIP peacekeeper.
Some people have already started to play
two. Some people play multiple copies in
the side deck. I really like this deck
so far.
It's a deck that we can't really be
surprised to see, you know, doing well.
It's a deck you can't be proud to play
against, but it can be scary when it
gets rolling. And I'm just so intrigued
to see how this is going to pan out cuz
you would imagine, you know, as it's
going to get off to an early lead. Can
you eventually stabilize? I'm not so
sure. So, we're going to see how this
pans out going into our round two. But
Le, I'm going ask you a question here.
So, let's say you're a player who's
currently one game up. We love to see
that
>> of course.
>> And let's say you are trying to go for a
top eight and beyond. What do you think
is going through those players heads
right now?
>> I mean, you should go one by one, one at
a time, right? In the such a big
tournament, you have 13 rounds of Swiss,
12 more ahead of you. You're already
immediately in the feature majer playing
versus a Le champion, for example. It is
quite threatening, quite intimidating,
but you're also playing with the heart
of the Aurora. So you can basically
sometimes even say hey you know what
deck just do your thing I will just uh
roll with you and let you win some games
for me by hitting all of these elder
dragons. However it is really important
to take a game at a time right so you
cannot already say hey I started 10.
This is my chance to get the top cut.
That's not how it works. Especially
[laughter] since most of these rift
bounders have already gotten their round
one buy from skirmishes.
>> Good point. Yeah.
>> So basically some of them haven't played
yet. So, so already starting to
calculate how easy it is going to be for
you to to hit the top cut. I don't think
that's right. But I think some standard
things you need to watch out for in
those tournaments is that you pack some
snacks, some healthy snacks. Uh nuts
always a game changer and water.
>> Of water as well. Water, hydration so
important. A good night of sleep the
night before as well. It's actually
something if you do make your uh your
day two is fun to like test with your
friends, you know, celebrate with your
friends. Get yourself good amount of
sleep though. Need those 8 hours to
trading card games. Riftbound. There's a
lot of concentration. Make sure you get
that sleep in. But it looks like Leo.
Here we go. Our Swiss round two feature
match here at the Utre regional
qualifiers kicking us off. Room breaker
getting the chest down. And it is over
to Squirtle. Let's see what we can do.
Sand Soldier immediately into play via
the Azir Legend ability.
>> Yep. Soft start. Of course, the treasure
trove is always nice to hit that two
drop, but it is not quite immobilized.
We're going for the catalyst of Aons.
>> That is of course not the worst start,
but if you're looking closely, this is
only six runes. So, the next turn you're
not going to hit that Aurora just quite
yet. And that is already something good
for Squirtle. Yep. Squirtle just needs
to get off to the races as soon as
possible. Here we go to the aim of the
game is equipment early on for that Azir
deck. when you play an Az when you play
an um an equipment I should say you can
use your Azir emperor of the sands
ability to pay one and get a sand
soldier with weapon master as we can see
it being used here we're conquering up
into that first battlefield there first
points on the board Squirtle
>> and I really like the uh hall of legends
versus the Aurora deck I mean it's it's
really good in general but you can
actually make two of those sand soldier
tokens in the turn you played just one
gear also very interesting that it is
not immediately
weapon mastered onto the brutalizer here
because he knows hey most of the time I
just need two might to conquer anything
here and I want to keep the brutalizer
free so I can abuse the two more might
if there is a unit on board st deck is
now
>> not finding the aurora is finding
actually two of those units for now
that's kind of good because they're
under the deck
>> yep
>> so that is something very chill you're
not going to draw them next turn but
next turn has to be the Aurora turn. So,
you kind of want to find one of those
top decks now with the trove.
>> Okay, so we're getting in the gear from
the silver legend ability there as it
were. What else can Roombreaker be
piecing together?
>> Squirtle has a very, very chill hand
here. That is something that is very
much looking like one by one build up in
a game versus other decks like Diana or
a he which is a little bit more
interactive with your board state. Those
hands do not really work too well all of
the time. You don't have a lot of
interaction. You just have more and more
weapons to build up against Aurora. That
is kind of insane actually. You can just
drop something every turn and then
overwhelm your opponent with a big arise
in the end game. You don't need anything
like those crazy defies. Even though 85
on the catalyst of aons does slap
>> going out of room breaker so we did see
the fading memories to give one of the
unit out of battlefield or gear
temporary and it is back over to
Squirtle now let's see what he can piece
together what is that one two three six
runes I made that six seven there's a
lot going on
probably not in a rise turn a lot more
equipment for that to be super valuable
yet you don't hit the units just yet,
right? You just need to conquer once and
you just need to push one sand soldier
into a battlefield at a time. So, I
think this Azir versus Aurora match up,
that's something to to wake up for both
of these rift bounders just because they
are aware, hey, there is not a lot going
on on the battlefield right now, but of
course, you still need to play out your
sequencing correctly. Forgotten Monument
is a battlefield that you want to hold,
not conquer, but of course, uh you can't
hold anything without conquering it
first. So going to push a sand soldier
in there. That is going to force him to
recycle a rune if that actually does
resolve. Oh no, that's the forgot
monument, not sigil. It's sigil. Okay.
Yeah, you have to recycle rune.
>> And we did see the gust coming in there
as well there. Leo
>> recycle one run.
>> That is perhaps going to bounce unless
we have a discipline that could push our
might to four as reaction. So Gust would
fizzle. And now we see a BF sword come
down there for Squirtle. That's going to
come equipped to that sand soldier as
well.
>> Okay, three points on the board there
for Squirtle, but we are getting to sort
of danger zone here for Roombreaker.
>> This is where his game plan will be
unlocked.
>> I like what he has put together in his
hand though. Of course, you would always
want to throw down an Aurora here of
course
>> at the very late game.
>> Yeah. Yeah. [laughter]
But flurry of blades, if you have two of
those, it can sometimes even help you to
get rid of some sense soldiers when
they're trying to conquer. But they even
playing Aurora.
>> I don't I don't see it. We see a
sabotage. Then you look at Squirtle's
hand. Recycle a non-unit. Let's see.
Plenty of options there, but Arise
immediately
sent to the bottom.
>> Taken some notes. Those are just a few
equipment gears that you don't need to
worry too much about. You need to worry
about your own cards a little more. You
definitely want to have this dazzling
aurora in your hand. And I think even
though the sabotage is a little bit
annoying for Squirtle,
>> that should be eight open runes right
now for rune breaker. And that means out
of the Aurora territory. Therefore, one
more turn to chill
>> for Squirtle. I have a question for you.
So, we're not going to see Aurora this
turn. It's looking like
>> if you're Squirtle, how many turns can
you sort of get away with um or how many
turns you want to see without the
Aurora?
>> All of them. [laughter]
I think I think it's just definitely all
of them. The thing is you have so many
resources on your board right now in
terms of sand soldiers that you at some
point don't really care about the Aurora
anymore. When you hit that six that six
mark and the Aurora drops, that's fine.
You wasted your entire turn on this
gear. You play an elder drake. You can
kill some of my sand soldiers, but then
I'm just going to reconquer both of
those.
>> Now Roombreaker has to develop the
civer, which is a unit at least. That is
already something.
>> We start to pressure the board a little
bit now. Is over to Squirtle. Brutalizer
going to come down. There comes another
sand soldier as well.
>> We are battling in the desert. It seems
sand soldiers here, there, and literally
everywhere.
What else are we eyeing up here from the
hand? Looks like we're going to see some
movement there. Going to be a conquer.
It's looking like Oh no. Oh, he's toying
with us there, Leo.
>> Yeah, he's keeping us on the edge of our
season in [laughter] this game with the
the BF sword equip. I think he's now
contemplating
>> which fan soldier to push to see how to
get the most usage out of those
equipments. that I think when there is a
civer developed on the opposing side of
the board, then it makes sense to push
that BF sword. Even though if it's now
an Aurora turn, the Civer is going to
get plus two might. So, Civer is going
to be able to overpower that sand
soldier.
I think this is a very micro decision
that
really doesn't have a good answer to it.
However, if if there is no Aurora being
played this turn, the civ can't
overpower the sand soldier. Otherwise,
you're just going to re-equip this BF
sword at some point anyways. So, I I
don't think it matters too much. This
should have been the right decision for
Squirtle.
>> So, on the back of the Conquer into the
Hall of Legends, we are going to see the
Azir Legend reuse. We get another sand
soldier. We're attaching a brutalizer to
that sand soldier is currently at the
Hall of Legends as well. So he wants if
an Aurora is played that or another card
that costs two power or two power in
total that the C mercenary would have to
crash into this still war though.
>> Yeah, but we have the lunar boon that
costs three energy. So that is quite
costly and we are again out of Aurora
range for this turn and so I think Pedro
is just more than fine to just go yep do
whatever.
All right. So, let me let me rephrase my
question earlier then, Leo. If you are
Roombreaker,
is this game sort of slowly slipping out
of hand now or can the combat still come
on?
>> I think it's rapidly slipping out of his
hand since the last two turns where he
didn't find the Aurora to play on nine.
That deck is so reliant on this one gear
and that is the big risk of this. Of
course,
>> dazzling Aurora relieves you from some
of the decisions that you have to make
in a game, right? So it it really
delivers you those big powerful
impactful units on a silver play without
having to do too much because it just
plays them at the end of the turn.
>> Mhm.
>> If you don't find it,
>> yeah, you're not really playing the
game. As you can see here, he has the
option to conquer the sigil of the storm
here for free, but he also doesn't want
to do that because that would mean
further DM. It's also very interesting
to see that Squirtle has decided to
actually push the sand soldier out of
the sigil of the storm because every
time you reconquer it, you are going to
have to recycle one of your runes. But
that was to play around the elder drake.
You know, elder drake chooses three
locations and then deals one damage to
each and then kills every unit that has
taken damage. So decides, hey, I'm going
to keep every sand soldier I want around
and I'm going to pay with runes for
that. That is fine for me.
>> Yeah, something to be said. You know the
elder dragon is coming in trying to
spread your units out. Try and don't
have them you know here then there and
everywhere. So the elder dragon can just
clean them up. We are going to see a
conquer into that sigil of the storm
though. That is going to go through
squirrel onto seven.
>> One
>> and we are going to see the sigil of the
storm as well. Forcing you to recycle
one of those runes. One still to play
with.
>> Now seven. It's very interesting. You
have two ways to go now.
>> Yeah. on the side of Squirtle because
you either pull out of the Hall of
Legends again to save another sand
soldier from a possible
Elder Dragon. However,
>> you can also just say, "Hey, you only
have one Civiver here and that is not
too threatening. So, if you cannot push
or if you find Aurora and hit a mine
spplitter, I'm still going to win with
one holding point."
>> It's quite a few options, isn't there
really? You can even start using your if
you was to pull back a Zir champion as
well. We can see another sand soldier
coming down. And I think if you are Room
breaker,
I'm just struggling. I'm really
struggling. There's a lot going on here.
>> Yeah, it's hard to find a line
[laughter]
to get back into this game.
>> Yeah, we are going to see another sand
soldier. No, I think you're fine just
to, you know, hold it all here.
>> This is a little bit looking like a demo
game where you're explaining how how it
works.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, this is the dream scenario, right?
He's got figured, okay, this is what we
need. This is UT is going to be my event
if all my games go this way. I can tell
you that.
>> Yeah, he also has the still the big push
with the accelerated Azil later on. So
even if a Aurora is found
>> pulls out the sand soldier here, even if
Runeer can conquer the sigil of the
storm with the civer and then drop the
dazzling
>> Aurora. Dazzling.
>> Okay, that that that might get you
there.
>> Okay, we're not there yet. Stack deck.
No way. That is impossible. He's also
slowly shaking his head runer.
>> Does he get rune broken by his own deck
at this point? Because there is just
nothing to be found.
>> Wow. I I don't think the runes have been
the problem here. [laughter]
>> It's been the deck, right? Just hasn't
been able to draw into that Aurora yet.
still have the se as of course but you
know with Squirtle at seven and
literally a cornucopia of options to get
to that eight. There is the mobilize
letting you draw one.
>> Oh but is this going to be the
concession and Squirtle will take game
one here. Our round two feature match
here at the Utrect regional qualifier.
And if you're Squirtle,
>> I'm quite happy about that.
>> This was too much.
And yeah, just players.
>> My hand was fine. Like
>> you had a very bad end, I think. But
>> it was like, okay.
>> Yeah, they're also figuring it out,
right? [laughter] That was that was
really unplayable for Rune Breaker.
>> Yeah, sounds like it. And I think it's
kind of obvious when you see the way pan
out. Yeah, Squirtle. No, you didn't have
a great hand, did you? And Runeer said,
"Yeah, turns out I did not."
>> Well, you still have it.
>> Yeah, I have pieces, so points.
>> Yeah, the the savage was super good. Uh
yeah,
>> the good thing is it was only egg run,
so I knew there was no Aurora.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Like if if if you had Aurora into mind
spplitter, it was
>> No, that was crazy. Yeah.
>> Well, there was no Aurora. [laughter]
>> So there was no mind splitter.
>> Now I will say I think that game one on
the one side should be the easiest for
Civer because the cards coming in from
the side deck are nasty. Every single
deck has nasty answers into a deck. Y
>> for example in this color combination
this domain combination salvage or
>> Ash
huge but I think the other battlefields
that Civer is running
>> they might work a little better against
Azir because you know in the forgotten
monument I mean we saw it on the left
side but it was the sigil of the storm.
>> Mhm.
>> Forgotten monument doesn't let you score
until your third turn.
>> So that's big
>> very important. Yeah. That takes away
like one conqueror most of the time.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we also have the good old
Aspirin climb that also pseudo takes
away one conquer from you, right, by
pushing the game to nine.
>> But there's actually a lot of
interesting cards in this sideboard that
Squirtle can look. We mentioned, you
know, the disarming rake and the
salvage, the most on the nose counters.
You also have that um the Ashy. I think
that's a really interesting card as
well, letting you look at your
opponent's hand. put one card away and
you say until you hold my friend you
can't get that card back. So there's a
lot of options here for Squirtle.
Looking at this Roombreaker's deck here
though, Leo,
>> what do you think they could be
sideboarding in?
>> Yeah. Uh this is sometimes you play more
mindsplitter after sighting because you
want to be able to find the mind
spplitter
>> first instead of an elder drake if you
have one of those battlefield that
relieves you from a little bit of
pressure like the forgotten monument and
the aspirin climb. Yeah.
>> So you want to find the mind splitter
first. Take out hopefully only one
answer to the dazzling aurora and then
start elder draking all the way through.
Sometimes you even have two aurora in
hand. That is of course then absolutely
golden. If you get that engine going and
you have your last rights as well, that
is pretty nifty.
>> But other than that, I think cards like
hard bargain,
>> they are pseudo answers to this removal
because especially decks like Azir, they
don't need to fully exhaust their runes
against you, right? So if you have a
hard bargain for something like a
salvage, they're just going to go, "Hey,
I can I can pay four extra. I do not
care." um throw.
>> So it looks like Cyborg is still being
done here. But I think if you're
Squirtle, you must be feeling on top of
the world. You snuck the game there.
Well, I say Rum didn't really play the
game much if I'm being completely honest
with you. But now we'll have that
sideboarding pressure as you do say. And
I think if you are a dazzling Aurora
player, you know that that sideboard is
going to come in hot, heavy, and
aggressive against you cuz the gear hate
Leo honestly it's in almost every single
deck.
>> Yeah. And here you can see if you have
enough of those equipment gears,
>> going to have a good time. You're going
to build up in the base and then your
opponent if they do not find the Aurora
at all, of course, you're just going to
out outsit them. Basically, you don't
even really do anything. You just push
two mighty units into battlefields and
then you're golden.
>> Yeah, the sand soldiers are doing
exactly what they need to do there. Just
sit on that battlefield, get those
points. This Azir deck though has a lot
of tips and tricks. We've mentioned we
didn't see it in that last game though.
That's obviously a big mid to late game
ender. The guards as well can be hidden.
Get some sand soldiers into play. And of
course, the mighty Aziz Sovereign coming
in play with accelerate. And when you
attack, you can move your sand tokens as
well, your sand soldier tokens, I should
say. Basically saying whatever
battlefield I want, I will take.
>> The coolest thing about Azir sovereign
is that it takes every token. Y
>> doesn't even need the sand soldiers.
It's just every single turn that you can
make. So, you can also play this card in
other decks. It has also seen quite a
bit of play. It's something that Ivvern
players use because Ivvern has
>> of course. Yeah. Yeah.
>> You know, Ivvern likes to build a nest
in a bush [laughter]
>> and then has Azir Sovereign to somehow
get another push into another
battlefield if it gets close on points.
>> It looks like we are getting sorted here
for our game two round two feature match
here at the UK regional qualifier. If
you're joining us, you've joined us at a
great time. Here we go. Mulligans. And
it was always going to be two for
Roombreaker. You just need this. This
isn't this this isn't even a want at
this point. This is a need to get to
that dazzling Aurora.
>> I think we already
>> There it was. The last one off the
mulligan. If you're Roombreaker, try and
poker face now. Don't give too much
away. But there it is. Is there two in
that hand? Actually, there's some that
something huge that I want to tell you
about the Squirtle is that he can play a
big two drop now. Doesn't have to start
with the brutalizer. Has the eye of the
herald for one energy and has a sensor
soldier. That means one energy open for
a defy to a potential catalyst. But that
is something that runeer is sniffing out
here and instead goes off to the pack of
treasures combination
with the trove pack of wonders treasures
trove. that combination letting you draw
and get extra runes into play. You love
to see it there. If you're Rune Breaker
and I think if you are runer, this is
what you need. You need a very different
game too here. Immediately off to the
races there with the ramp and the Aurora
in hand. Over to Squirtle, though, some
more equipment into play. That is going
to be some more sand soldiers, I
imagine. And if you're Squirtle, I mean,
this is all you can do, isn't it? Just
get points on the board, get your sand
soldiers down, get your equipment down.
But the game is kind of in rule
breaker's hand. If that dazzling Aurora
comes out, Squirt will be the one
answering the questions.
>> Yeah, that's definitely true. I mean,
the seat of power is just a really,
really good battlefield against Aurora
specifically,
>> just because in the early to mid game,
you are 900% going to have a bunch of
battlefields that you're controlling.
>> I will.
>> So, you can just conquer this one and
then next turn, you're going to push
your other sand soldier into the seat of
power. going to find some extra draws.
Hoping to find answers or extra pushes
versus the dazzling Aurora,
but this game, don't forget, we're
playing to nine. So, we're looking
forward to these uneven numbers that we
want to actually goes for the sword
without being able to ready the Azir
legend again.
>> Okay, so it is over to run out. A
catalyst of aons.
>> Do you even defy that anymore? That is
the big question. Usually in the in the
turn before I would have said yes 100%.
But now on the next turn your opponent
is going to be at nine anyway. It's
already at seven runes. So if you defy
that it does nothing. I think that is
actually at this point a defy bait.
Cards that you would rather defy are
something like lunar boon
>> that we're also not going to see here. A
last ride is already being set up.
>> Do two points.
>> Yeah. Now last right is going to be
really interesting letting you play a
unit from your trash. You just have to
pay the pay the cost of course letting
you recycle those very hefty units that
dazzling gets into play. We are going to
see a conquer though
>> another battlefield and then we are
going to see the recruit token come down
as well mounting a bit of a defense
here.
>> I will go back. I of the Herald also
really really cool against
>> the Elder Dragon just because you can
leave those recruit tokens in the
battlefields and then still get a
holding point
>> and then afterwards after the holding
point retreat those from the battlefield
back to base so you have all of your
units in the same place and you didn't
have to conquer.
>> Oh we are going to see the arise here
though Leo that's going to be for three
sand soldiers two of which will come in
ready as well. The big signature spell
from Azir.
>> I really liked how he telegraphed this
already in the last turn by just playing
the sword out for basically no reason
quotation mark without getting a soldier
for it.
>> Oh, that is so well played as well.
Playing them into the battlefield,
equipping the eye of the herald with
weapon master and then amassing all of
those recruit tokens.
>> Can I just say what has happened to
Squirtle's board? All of a sudden, we've
gone from sand soldiers to what is this?
>> [laughter]
>> I can hardly count all these units and
they're all spread out. A lot of them
are in the base, Leo. So, even if the
Elder Dragon was to come out, we can
only take away two of those units.
Squirtle playing around that elder
dragon perfectly. But here we go for
Rune Breaker. Finally, the namesake of
the deck, Dazzling Aurora, has come
down. And now Civer has gone and create
a gold token for us. I can imagine that
we're still going to go for a pack of
wonders. Small play here.
But what else is Runeerreaker going to
do? No, he's just going to pass and
finds the Elder Dragon off the top.
However, that is, as you said earlier,
not going to deal so much.
>> And in the next turn, Squirtle is going
to go up to five. That is two more
double conquers that he needs.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that elder dragon obviously the
build around when you put it into play,
you can deal one damage to any unit at
work, any one location. So you can do
one at both battlefields and the base.
But because of the elder dragon's evil
ability, any amount of damage can kill a
unit. So in theory, that can be a three
b a three unit swing. However, if you
play around it like Squirtle did, it's
not as costly.
>> Squirtle already because the mind
spplitter wasn't hit.
>> Salvage.
>> Oh, there's the salvage. Leo one turn of
dazzling Aurora and we can get rid of
it. Does Runeer have response? Doesn't
look like it. It has gone through. The
nastiest thing about that is the card
replaces itself immediately, right? Your
biggest power plays, you've already
thrown down the Arise, your other
biggest power plays that you have right
now. They don't really cost a lot of
energy,
>> so
>> it's good for me.
>> That's just uh basically free there.
See how Roomreer can follow this one up
because I believe there's multiple
copies of this in hand. And this is
where it gets tricky for your opponent.
>> Mhm. Does have another Dazzin Aurora in
hand. Does have the last right as well.
So, Squirrel isn't out of the woods yet,
but has had some fantastic answers to
Room Breakers questions. Does have this
big bad scary elder dragon to play with.
Has played around Flurry of Blades
rather nicely here, keeping those units
in the base as well.
>> Yeah, and I think keeping the defy from
the early game is really, really
important there. I I said something
about trying to defy a lunar boon if
your opponent can't so that your
opponent can't find Aurora. That's one
way to go. But I also like the approach
of Squirtle. I mean, there wasn't a
lunar boon played so far, but I like the
approach where he's just gonna go, "Hey,
I know that I have a bunch of small
units and I need to push as many of them
as I can into a battlefield with an
elder drake."
>> Yeah.
>> So, you will have to flurry of blaze me
and this is where I keep the defy
treasure.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we are going to see the pack.
They're going to get put back into the
hand to draw and channel.
So, let's have a think. If we have Rune
Breaker here, what we need to get some
more unit. Oh, there comes the other
dazzling Aurora coming down. Will
Squirtle be able to answer that one? Cuz
I feel as if you can't let Rune Breaker
get too many of these big units into
play. As you say, you might have an
answer for one. You might be able to get
rid of one Dazzling and War. Sure. But,
you know, if one Elder Dragon becomes
into two, becomes into a mindbreaker,
that could get out of hand. But here we
go. The big, the bad, the scary elder
dragon swinging into that battlefield.
>> Yes. And that's going to be a nice easy
point there
>> knowing that he is much more likely to
hit another Elder Dragon instead of a
mind spplitter.
>> Yeah,
>> probably he is pushing this one into
>> Oh, there's your Luna Bloom though that
you mentioned earlier.
>> Let you discard one to draw two. Work
towards those resources.
Oh, and here is a dazzling Aurora. What
are we going to hit? Is it going to be a
Mender? Is it going to be the Elder
Dragon mind spplitter?
>> Where to put it? Now, this has an
interesting coming into play ability
is you get to look at your opponent's
hand and they discard that card as well.
>> See what the players have to say about
this.
>> Okay.
>> Plays it into base. So, there was a
little bit of thinking where to put it.
>> Okay. So, let's see. The defy seems like
the easy choice here. I think it looks
like that's immediately been popped to
the side. Again, Runeer taking notes cuz
you get to consult your opponent's hand.
When you can play Riftbound with perfect
hand knowledge and you know your
opponent hasn't got any answers, that
means your cards like your flurry of
blades can be used.
>> It's already
super huge to hit the mind splitter
there because
>> yes, I believe so as well. Yeah,
>> you only need one rune for a flurry of
blades and as long as Elder Drake is on
there, everything will die.
>> Yep, that flurry of blades becomes
rather terrifying. Flurry of blades let
you deal one damage to all units at
battlefield and in combination with the
elder dragon that basically says
whatever flurry of blades hits will
immediately get sent to your opponent's
trash.
>> The thing is even if you have a flurry
of blades,
>> that is the beauty of equipments, right?
So if you throw in two sand soldiers
with a BF sword on them,
>> yep,
>> that is threatening the elder dragon.
>> You have to flurry of blades that or
else he's gone.
>> Then you can just re-equip those BF
swords. I think as Squirtle has already
developed all of those units, like a
crazy amount of units in the early to
mid game. He set himself up for success
to push through multiple flurry of
blades even in the end game because his
runes are not as important to him
anymore. He can just start paying power
cost after power cost.
>> Was that another BF sword coming down
that recruit?
>> Yeah.
>> Wow. We have so much on on a sand
soldier, I should say. We have so much
might
>> on the board here.
>> Quite honestly, I would love to see the
mental image of this sand soldiers dual
wielding BF swords running into that
elder dragon.
>> I mean,
>> that currently trades just on those two
on their own, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, you need you need another
sand soldier. So you are at eight might
with these and you push another one in.
I think this one has the
>> Here we go.
>> Eye of the Herald. So you get another
>> recruit's going to come in as well.
>> So here we go. Big showdown here. 10
versus the 10 11 Elder Dragon versus the
double sand soldier.
>> And there's the flurry of blades. The
instant response. And with that defy
going out the hand with a mind
spplitter. Squirtle just has to eat
that.
>> But that's so fine for him, right?
because he still has plenty of runes
left. Only two order runes though. That
is very important in this scenario
because
>> that means that you can only attach
those double BF sword
>> one more
>> and have no more left to play with.
Exactly that. No room for error there.
>> Yeah, but I would say that is completely
fine with him.
>> So floats one of the order runes and
floats another one. So we are going to
go into the double BF equip. I really
like that we're seeing much more of a
game now than we have seen in the first
one.
infinitely more game. Right
>> now you can actually see how Squirtle is
piloting this knowing his opponent is
completely tapped out.
>> So here we go again. Another big
showdown into this elder dragon. We have
the sand soldier with a double BF sword
>> and a soul sword and a recruit. And it
looks like yep runer has to concede that
one. And Squirtle has cleared away that
L dragon and Squirtle can just
immediately with free rain charge the
rest of his recruits. and or sand
soldiers wherever he wants and start
taking points. Bear in mind, Leo, he's
currently at six. We have to go to nine
cuz Aspen's climb of course, but
Squirtle is getting towards gamewinning
territory.
>> Oh, and he actually wants to hold one of
the battlefields. That is very
interesting because of the eye of the
herald. That is so well played by him.
And he says, "Hey, you kind of want to
go into this battlefield otherwise you
cannot elder drake it off. This is one
where I have more might but he also
needs to pay attention to the rune
management in the next turn because
>> I was about to say yeah
>> doesn't hit to order
>> trouble
>> I was about to say I got to keep an eye
on those Res is in a fantastic spot
>> but you don't want to be caught runeless
as it were is over to runer though who
doesn't really have to worry about runes
has too many to count realistically to
play with here and two old as well.
>> That is a lot of possible draw on the
side of rune breaker because these ramp
spells
>> I think only catalyst of Aon. I'm not
too sure about mobilize when you are
already fully rammed. Oh yeah as well.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Elder dragon in the hand. How many does
he play? Just play three. So we've seen
one. One's in the hand. So is still one
available.
decides to not play that one, but goes
for
>> sorry, it's okay.
>> Predict effect.
>> It's also such a nice addition to the
deck.
>> Not only because it adds consistency
blue,
>> but also because if you're playing into
a lot of Diana and they will have
acceptable losses, you just know in that
matchup when you're expecting that one
energy spell, you just keep the scri
bloom on the board. Yeah,
>> you just never use it and then you drop
Aurora and then each player sacrifices a
gear becomes a lot less threatening.
Nice little interesting addition to the
deck there which is what it needs is a
little bit more what's the word
interactivity I'd like to say [laughter]
for letting you cuz let's be honest
dazzling aurora is public enemy number
one here gear haters everywhere but we
are going to see mine spplitter charging
into the aspirants climb
>> and what do we make this here two three
yep seven versus two I should say
>> it's three
>> and I think rune breaker is going to win
this or we are going to see
the death grip coming in.
>> Draw card.
>> Oh, death grip using the BF sword
attached weapon mastered unit that was
played after the big pushes here.
>> So now we're a tie.
>> Okay.
>> And yeah.
>> Oh no, no, we're not even at a tie.
We're tying with the sand soldier. And
that hidden blade really did a lot of
work. Or the grip.
>> Wow. The death grip there coming in
clutch. And you have to feel, you know,
when you're runer charging these big
units and you're getting traded with
tokens, it has to feel rough. We are
going to see the civ coming back though
from the champion zone.
>> Yes,
>> that is very very useful for Roombreaker
to have here because he can just charge
it into the seat of power. Take that
battlefield and then of course at the
end of the turn use desor to play a
Elder Dragon or another mind whatever
you're finding for him. I think it's
hopefully an elder dragon.
>> Yeah.
>> Push it also into the seat of power
which is going to cause some problems in
the turn afterwards perhaps
>> because then you are threatening a hold
on the aspirants climb on the side of
Squirtle.
But we are going to go for another
treasure trove. Pack of wonders
combination gets you one more rune again
and draws you a card. And that is so
much ramp, so much consistency in the
hand. But none of these cards really do
anything right now. I was about to say
not really the cards you want, but not
really bad cards nonetheless. A ton of
draw power, but as you say, don't really
need that. Here we're going to see the
dazzling Aurora though. Will it be mind
splitter? Will it be an Elder Dragon?
>> It's going to be the Elder Dragon.
>> I think we've seen some incredible tech
there from Runeer.
>> Yeah. Any stubborn in hand. That is not
a card that you necessarily want to find
off of the dazzling aurora, but this
card on play a spell from your trash to
your hand. the sort of area.
>> Yeah, fantastic little addition that
we've seen a lot more actually come into
this letting you reuse those spells as
you do say, you know, letting you use
your Gust perhaps Sky Blue Moblast.
Flurry of Blades of course is an easy
one
>> and a heatless resurrection from the
side deck possibly.
>> Yep, it was.
>> We are putting that elder onto that
battlefield with our silver mercenary.
So, we are trying to not lose in the
next turn. And now Squirtle can push of
course one recruit token into the
aspirin clam. Go up to eight which is
not a game shot yet.
>> No,
>> he has a plethora of equipments there.
That is that is not very little but
>> there's a lot of extra might there on
the board.
>> He ran out of units.
>> He has. Exactly. Yeah. Oh, we see the
Squirtle crab come down though. That is
going to give Squirtle some No, well
that's not handet when he gets on the
death new. I apologize but yeah, you're
right. no units to play with. It's like
the reverse of where we were earlier.
So, yeah, you can easily get to eight,
but and then this is where you normally
see the Azir Sovereign come down to
clear out, but that is a lot of might on
the other side of the board there. I
don't think we're going to see that this
turn.
>> Big question is if Runreer has more
cards in his deck that are not Elder
Dragon, can he prevent the one recruit
hold? Can he prevent a two recruit hold?
because that would fix the Elder Dragon
problem immediately if Squirtle just
pushes these two recruits into the
Aspirans climb. There has to be a way to
clear that. And I think any
>> another BF sword that is an absolutely
ridiculous amount of might on the board
there. Well, uh what's the word?
Potential might I should say.
>> I think the the any stubborn is going to
be a key piece for the next turn for
rune breaker.
>> Okay.
>> Because he just picks up the flurry of
blades from the trash. Oh, Squirtle
actually wants to wait for a bigger push
and doesn't push anything into the
battlefield knowing the eighth point
doesn't help him too much. He's very
unlikely to hold there. That is very
very interesting.
>> That was Rune Breaker's first hold so
far, right? I believe maybe it's his
second. But here we are back over to
Roombreaker now. Has got a flurry of
blades in the hand. But you're right.
I'm a big fan of that Annie card. You
would be sad to see it come into play.
You say you do say why that dazzing a
roar but let you just be so flexible in
a deck that I think dazzing a raw I
think it's safe to say is quite linear
hasn't got many tips and tricks to Annie
coming on the sideboard just lets you
get a little bit more funky with it as
we do see it come down now and let's see
what are we going to take all that
golden here we go
>> it's very typical for a dragon to sit on
a lot of gold
>> yes on brand I like that yeah we are
going to see flow your blades taken off
that Anna I must say though Leo
So I think that's currently two
flurrying blades in a hand as well. So
you can play you can play around any
potential defy
you know try and defy my first one have
a second one.
>> It seems like Squirtle has completely
ran out of steam and runer is definitely
stabilized at this point. I think that
is uh something you can just state here
is equipping
last rights to the any stubborn and for
a hold you could just play something
from the trash like the elder dragon for
its full cost though but now is also
that is something really great about
that card that is the main use of it
basically recycles the units from your
trash when you equip it so that you can
hit them off of dazzling or again and
again and again and again and again
>> and again
>> oh we're going to get the ganking coming
in there from the an extra point on the
board. Now, this is interesting. This is
what Rune Breaker needs.
>> She has ganking.
>> Yeah, she does. Come on. And this is
this is what Roombreaker needs. You
know, has weed the storm. Squirtle was
off the race. We saw that absolute
colossal board state Squirtle had with
BF swords here, recruits their sand
tokens here. Runeer has destroyed all
them for lack of a better term and now
has his big units in play. Here is a
dazzling Aurora again. I believe this
should hit an L dragon. Could it a min
splitter? Of course.
>> I think the minds splitter is under the
deck if we haven't seen all of the other
dragons yet.
>> There it is. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, I think Yeah. Squ hasn't got any
units in play other than the base. So,
I'm assuming the sand soldier will not
be long for this world.
>> Soldier.
>> Sand soldier. Yeah. Don't want to give
up that freehand information on the
scuttle crab. And again, while it has
zero, don't have to really worry about
that one.
>> But yeah, now this is a scary ball state
though looking at Leo. Let's be honest
here. Two elder dragon, the Annie,
another elder dragon. So, two in total,
and then the severe as well. And if
you're Squirtle, all you have is two
recruits and the scuttlebug. We do see a
guards though that can get some sand
soldiers into play, of course. But, oh
wow, what is that five cost card there?
Is that the Is that a VI disruptive?
>> Oh, that's
>> Oh, it's the Ash. Oh, but a bit late for
that one.
>> The Ash would be very, very late.
Something like an Imperial Decree would
be incredibly cool here if he was
running that.
>> Don't think he's running that one though
>> in the side deck perhaps cuz that is a
good Nope.
>> But that would be that would be kind of
crazy with a lot of
>> crazy.
>> Yep.
>> But now we're checking out the B state.
What can Squirtle do to get back into
this game? Because for now it is looking
like one of those games where you have
almost gotten Aurora.
>> Here we go. Is there sovereign coming
down?
>> We see the guards coming down as well.
Leo the board state has exploded.
Equipment getting attached. Sand
soldiers here there literally
everywhere.
>> And we pass.
>> And we pass. We're getting ready for the
big turn. It's going to be next turn
though.
>> Uh five six old. Yes.
players just making sure A, B, C, D is
followed correctly, drawing a card,
ching, channeling the runes. And now I
think it's another turn of Runeer just
sitting on what he has and sabotaging is
also super strong here, taking away that
charm. Surely
>> massive,
absolutely massive turn there for the
sabotage. You know, Squirtle's building
towards trying to get game next turn.
Sabotage removing any potential threats
there. What a turn for that, Leo.
Squirtle
is a champion though. He is not scooping
any games here anytime soon. Even though
there are only 21 more minutes left on
the round. Oh, pack of wanders bouncing
back the Annie Stubborn. That works.
>> Paying some gold here. And you're going
to add back that sabotage. Take out that
Dorance Blade. That is another push.
That gear that can be played to get
another sand soldier to push with Azia
sovereign.
>> Wow. Such high play there from
Roombreaker.
And here we are going to see the
dazzling Aurora come down again. This
one should be a mine spplitter, I
believe. Yep. And now you get even more
hand destruction as well.
>> Let's see what Squirtle can find off the
top. Is there anything like an arise
>> that can get him back into this game?
Let's see what he finds off the top. Is
there a way back
or have we reached a dead end? Oh,
>> hidden blaze.
>> That is a card.
>> It is a card. I mean, it will get you
through one of these absolute titans
that you're staring across the board
from, but need to brutalize her for the
runes.
Okay, four I can do.
>> Squirtle just thinking has to plan this
turn out a lot. This
>> I really like the calculating he's doing
because first things first,
>> most of the time you're throwing in your
scuttle crab.
>> You want to get full information of your
opponent.
>> Then again, you have so many
>> gears you can recycle. You want to try
to trade something off. Let's see.
>> Yeah, there goes a humble scuttle.
>> That's the brave scuttle crab there with
the BF swords
>> that we'll be able to trade into the
Annie. Honey and trigger get one
experience.
>> But now we get the death nil on the
scuttle crab given Squirtle hand
knowledge from rune breaker
>> and yeah there's a lot of options in
that hand. Double flurry of blades is
terrifying
>> to keep it revealed or uh
>> he barely looked. [laughter]
>> That's that champion difference right
there.
>> So how [snorts] I do this?
>> This is such a big turn here folks. I
cannot understate how important this
turn will be. Can Squirtle weather this
storm or will the mind spplitter and the
Elder Dragons
get this game back for Roombreaker? It
was currently one game down here in our
Swiss round two feature match here at
the UT regional qualifier.
>> I wonder
if Squirtle is trying to
hidden blade his own recruit unit.
>> Two draw two. I think that's seems
pretty sensible when you want to well a
one card hand right now
>> because otherwise you could have hidden
bladed a Elder Dragon preemptively.
>> Yeah.
>> And then shoved in the scuttle crab to
see what he drew.
>> Because now if you're hidden blading
your opponent, you're playing versus two
cards that you don't know of. However,
>> here [snorts]
>> it's also fine to do it that way just so
you have more flexibility later on. That
is a big token.
>> It was 10 strength, but I think it's
been immediately
sent to the discard or the trash I
should say.
And yeah, this is struggling again. That
board state did explode last turn, but
it seems to have got back pretty anemic
again. Leo, what are we planning here?
>> Repeat the same uh two green and one
yellow.
We're floating. We're floating.
>> Go here.
>> Is that the biggest
>> sand soldier we've ever seen?
>> I think it is for me. Not going to lie.
>> Go for 10.
>> Currently at 10 that can trade with
elder dragon.
>> A big issue for Squirtle is that double
elder dragon because if you're just
hidden, if there's just one, you're
hidden bladed and flurry of blades does
nothing anymore.
Yeah, you don't really want to be
playing against two older dragon. I can
tell you that is over to run now though.
Priority has been passed. We know has
two fer blades in hand. Don't need to
use those. Oh, there we are. Going to
see that. That means there will be no
trading with that sand soldier will get
sent to the trash.
>> I mean there's
>> and there we go.
>> One more order rune.
>> Uh 78.
I think this is okay. And
>> yeah, we are going to see the concession
and Squirtle did need the big push that
turn and Roombreaker was able to weather
that storm. And you know what that
means, folks? That means we're going to
a game three here and our Swiss round
two feature match. Room breaker versus
Squirtle, the little winner qualifier
champion. Roombreaker evens it up here.
>> And now for the first time, we're
[music] going to see a going first of
the Azia legend in this match. That can
of course also help you score some more
points. However, this is going to be a
monument game. Therefore, scoring extra
points on your
>> Wait, it is up until their third turn,
right?
>> Third turn.
>> Then that shouldn't be the biggest
issue. [laughter]
>> Interesting. See how it all pans out
here in the game three. Now, what if
it's going through Moon Room's head
here, Leo, then? So, game one definitely
wasn't your game, right? Of course.
Shuffle up with game two. Game two, I
think it's safe to say, went rather
well. What do you think is going through
his head now?
>> I think what's going through his head is
thank goodness I had two Aurora.
>> Yes.
>> Because that second one did all the work
while the first one was immediately
salvaged.
>> Y
>> therefore that really helped him execute
the strategy. So I would be a little bit
afraid of all the card that I've seen
before. So you know that your opponent
is siding in ashes and salvages.
>> Yeah, great point.
>> That is some really important knowledge
that you have. You know that there's a
scuttle crab in the deck list. Yeah.
>> of your opponent. So, those are all
little key information pieces that you
can work with.
>> I have a question.
>> Yeah. So, I don't think we got to
consult exactly how much gear removal
Squirtle did side into, but let's assume
it was at least one salvage and one Ash.
If you're going into this game three,
are you saying I need it all? I need the
disarming r. I need two times copy of
Ashley and I need both my salvage. You
ever go all in like this?
Yeah, I think that that's what it there
for. If you are playing Ash, Salvage,
and Disarming Rake, then you are citing
all of this in the metro. And we have
also seen that a charm was put in the
deck of him. Question is, how many how
many answers do you have on the side of
Runeer?
>> Well, we see the times three sabotage.
It's a great start.
Um
guess that Annie can reuse those as
well. Annie is a great card. We saw got
used there to fantastic effect.
>> Annie convinced me in that last game.
>> Yeah, I it's such a versatile card. Is
it been able to reuse spells, you know,
kind of in a similar way to what Fizz
does, right? Obviously, you don't get it
for free, but you get it back. You can
use it next turn. And when you have well
you're sitting on like four gold the all
the runes you can re realistically reuse
all those. One car we haven't seen much
of though uh Leo is those times two of
the back off. Yeah. Do you think they
could be impactful here?
>> I am not sure. Sometimes it's good to
stop an elder drake there but you don't
really see flurry of blitz being played
before elder drake hits the board. So
that could be the consequence of that
then. So I think might be a card that
you side out. Big question. Are we
hitting the one drop? Yes, we are.
>> Okay, so here we go. Game three, our
Swiss round two feature match here at
the Utre regional qualifier squad.
Immediately getting that sand soldier
down. We're going to see a stack deck
coming in there for Roombaker. I tell
you what, in a game three situation
where you go in second stack deck. What
a card to see.
>> Yeah, and I love that the players are
playing so incredibly fast. Stack deck
is hitting three cards again. And we are
going to add ourselves a little breeze,
a little gust.
Here we go. Is over to Squirtle now
though. Let's see what we got. We see a
ton of equipment again. Eye of the
Herald. We're seeing it all here.
>> Yep. So, we can move that now. We will
get a recruit there as well.
>> Two recruit I should say cuz there is
two there of course. And then we get
another sand soldier.
>> This is the beauty of that Azir deck,
right? One token becomes two token
become three token become four token
arise. It honestly gets a little bit
silly.
>> But contemplates whether he wants to put
one because uh if he doesn't put the eye
of the herald onto the in the base he
can push back the other one and then get
two recruits in base which is far more
valuable. There there's
there's the cards in hand on the left
side. Yeah. Okay. So that was the
scriest bloom. was considering why why
did he only have like four car two cards
in hand but that was
>> there is a desura currently in the hand
so that is good and a sabotage to sort
of protect as well
>> treasure trove coming down there
>> that I'm I'm telling you what that would
have been a really really good catalyst
of Aon's turn but we found it too late
if that even was the top deck
>> that is Gust is not really doing too
much here anymore so you will not be
able to play it in the next turn as well
however
can chill a little bit because we're
playing to eight this game. So, it is
not a nine
>> point game.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> And Squirtle is only at two at the
moment, but Squirtle is doing such a
good job
>> at amassing tokens already. You know, it
is his second turn now. It's his third
turn and he already has four units.
>> That is efficient. And now it's six. And
I was about to say it's only going to
get bigger and larger. So he is going to
get more of those down. Oh, we do see
the Ash here. Could this be a turn?
Surely.
>> I think you wait for the ash with
>> you wait one more turn.
>> Yeah, you wait it immediately before the
dazzling aurora can hit the board
>> just to be a maximum irritant. That ash
that ash card folks is Oh, we going for
it now.
>> The thing is you are now exactly at five
runes.
So therefore, if you want to play the
Ash there,
>> you cannot go for a sand soldier this
turn. Oh, and there is going to be a
gust there.
>> Into the death grip so you can at least
draw one off that.
>> Yeah, and but the sand soldier gets
boosted so the gust doesn't resolve. So
we are getting those points.
>> Yes, great point there. Squirrel know to
a end the game against Warex. You need
to get off to the races fast which is
why we saw that chain resolve as it did.
is over to WBE going to sabotage. Okay,
little bit of hand disruption here.
We're going to immediately defy that
though. Squirt saying not today, Rune
Breaker. Not today. Not in a game three.
>> Into the Luna Bloom drawing cards.
>> The boon is happening. Discarding
another boon.
>> So that telegraphs that runer might
already have an Aurora otherwise he
would have needed the other Luna boon
maybe.
>> So is this your Ash turn then?
>> Yeah. And that could be that be
devastating. Ash, in case you don't
know, folks, when you play it, you look
at your opponent's hand, you take one
card you find there, you pop it to the
side, and you say, you know what, Rune
Breaker, until you hold, you're not
getting that card back. That could be
devastating if it targets that dazzling
Aurora, which spoiler alert, I'm
assuming it will if it comes down.
>> Already at five points, this is the turn
to arise.
>> We're going to see the arise instead.
Here we go.
>> Not even going for that. Ash saying,
"Hey, you discarded a Luna Boon with
your Luna Boon. You might even be at two
Auroras. You might have a huge turn next
turn, so I'm going to prepare my base.
I'm not going to win by denying you the
Aurora. I'm going to win by beating
you."
>> Well, folks, you can't see me, but I
have my head in my hands of how many
tokens there are in play. Squirtle has
been so aggressive. There is the
dazzling award for Runeerreaker, but as
you say, could it be a little bit too
late here?
I kind of like the Ash as you're so far
ahead in points as a big push in the
end. First of all, you can see how many
cards your opponent already has in deck.
You have seen two late hit the mind
spplitter there though.
>> But now you might be losing the ash.
>> Now you Yeah.
>> Or the hidden blade.
>> Or the hidden blades both have a lot of
value, but the hidden blade just been
able to bail you out on one of these
monstrous units that runer has. He's
saying no. No easy hidden blade for you.
That will get sent to the trash. Is over
to Squirtle now. So
>> the world is his oyster with these with
this board state.
>> There's there is two ways to go right
now. So you either develop even further
or you play the Ash now the playing the
Ash now of course helps you with
checking out what could happen next
turn. However, you are not going to win
this turn. You're going to go up to
seven and it's going to be all all nice
and chill there.
>> But if you Ash now your opponent gets
one more top deck before you get to
draw. But we don't have to efficient.
>> So we're checking this out. And he was
correct. There is another dazzling
Aurora, but there's nothing too
threatening this.
>> Yeah, there's no sort of insta pick
there. I think there's no immediate game
winner there.
>> I think you take the Aurora even.
>> I mean, the heatless resurrection has no
target in the trash right now.
>> Yep. And looks like that is what he's
going for there.
>> All right. He takes out takes out the
resurrection. So, once his opponent to
go for another big Aurora turn
>> because that doesn't really develop the
game state for him.
>> Yeah. Because the war obviously
concludes at the end of the turn, right?
It's not like it can stop this.
>> Yeah.
>> Bomb Squirtle winning next turn. Bear in
mind has still got champion unit Azir as
well to just start moving around the
boards if needed. Of course, setting up
a hold on both battlefields though.
Squirtle saying, "Right, you're going to
have to push me off both of these." And
you've only got one unit in play this
turn. Good luck, my friend. Here we go.
This could be the the deciding turn here
in our Swiss round two feature match
here. over to Roombreaker. What can he
do?
>> How many might does he have in the
forgotten monument? Because maybe he is
just offering trades to his opponent in
both of those battlefields. Do not
forget about the trifarian war camp
ability to push your units for one more
might. If you have multiple tokens in
there, that's multiple mightes.
>> I want to say now that
>> and it is just going to be the
concession. Room breaker couldn't break
both of those battlefield holds. and
Squirtle will win our Swiss round two
feature match here at the Utre regional
qualifier. [music]
Squirtle taking another W here, saying
he is not respecting the Aurora in hand.
Doesn't even care for it with Ash. And
so many people have said, "Hey, Ash is
such a great card versus Aurora because
you can snipe it off the hand basically
and prevent them from playing." But
Squirt has elevated that play a little
bit. He says, "Hey, you can't have your
dazzling aurora. That is absolutely fine
with me. I will take out your last
interactions. I will take out everything
you have, and I will just win by
overwhelming you with sand soldiers and
[music] outtempoing you."
>> Yeah. And I mean, as we look consulting
some highlights here, you can see just
that is exactly how that game one panned
out. Obviously, Rune Breaker was playing
the dazzling Aurora deck. Wasn't
dazzling anyone. Didn't have any Aurora
in play. So, game one wrapped up rather
[music] quickly. Game two, however, you
know, it did get off to the races a
little bit different.
>> That is a bunch of tokens. I thought
that Squirtle had the
the advantage there, too.
>> Yeah, I think so. It looked like, you
know, when the the war came down,
immediately got salvage. You think,
okay, just has to maneuver in and around
that one elder dragon. Rune breaker
immediately popped the second one down.
Mind splitted away. The good cards from
hand. We saw the Annie come into play as
well and that meant we were shuffling up
for a game three which was the first
time Squirtle was going first. So your
fifth I think he's immediately favored
but Runeer you know did have some cards
to play but in the end you look at a
ball [music] state like this. The
opponent had so much of a point
advantage and bear in mind he's a
previous regional qualifier champion as
well. He's got to have to say his favor.
That's some great play from Squ.
>> Did not have to care about the forgotten
monument. Almost forgot about it in the
moment.
>> [laughter]
>> That was just pure dominance and shows
why some of these aggressive decks like
Azir can handle those situations rather
well because you are just playing your
game plan and then at some point you're
going to have some elder drakes thrown
at you. But it doesn't really matter if
you can control your tokens. Well, you
have multiple turns of pushes that you
can set up and if you chill on spending
might early in the game, which you know
the Auroric doesn't force you to do
that,
>> you can later on have big pushes with
those equipments with those BF swords.
Even though we saw in game two that
sometimes especially inspir games that
is also not enough.
>> Yeah, as you can see there's to coming
with the BF times two a couple recruits
coming in from ID herald that 10 bite
from the elder dragon doesn't look so
mighty after all but we've been doing a
lot of talking. I want to hear from the
winner of our round two feature match
there. So let's kick it down to Barrett
for our interview.
Excellent cast there for I mean I I'm
actually feeling very privileged to sit
in this chair being able to sit next to
you Squirtle our current reigning
regional qualifier champion for Le the
last time we were here in Europe. How
does it feel now being 2 and 0 into this
tournament and you're making a great
performance just like you did that last
regional qualifier which by the way if I
remember didn't drop a single match.
Yeah, I'm technically still undefeated,
right? [laughter]
>> Which is good because I mean people like
Allen's EQ, who we have to of course
talk about in the picture, you know,
went on is currently kind of like on a
very long winning streak over the course
of all the qualifiers, but you can match
that. How does it feel coming into
today?
>> Well, at least the pressure is off, so
I'm just chilling. Want to also have fun
with the tournament. It's also nice that
I'm still playing a like it has improved
since Leil. So, it's nice to to still be
able to play my the deck I that has
given me a win. So, it's nice and I I'm
eager to to face Allan Prisma and those
players that are super super good are
making results consistently. So, it's
nice to to be to try to be in their
leagues, right? [laughter]
>> You're definitely in a league of your
own as well. of course, you know, now we
get to see you play again, you know, on
your way up, hopefully making that
incredible day two performance. Hope to
see you even maybe in another top cuts
here because we came off one of the most
rigorous top cuts I think from Vancouver
and now we have a tough act to follow.
But I am rooting for you like you said
with this Azir deck because I I'm just
such a big fan of calm domain which is
so powerful right now and I think a lot
of people would agree with that and the
order domain having access to a lot of
this extra removal. you're really well
tailored for the format, but I have to
ask you as one of the representatives of
this legend and someone who does well
with it, is there something in the field
that you are kind of afraid of to go in?
>> The last thing I
>> is there like a deck in the format that
you're kind of afraid to run into or
that you don't want to run into?
>> I I'm I'm happy against everything. Of
course, there are worse matchups, but I
think as long as you have like a
strategy against them, like for example,
the the the most player deck that is
Master G right now is not the ideal
matchup. But it it happened the same
with Draven in in Liil. But as long as
you have a plan and try to play
accordingly, it it eases out. It's not
like if I see it, I'm going to lose. So,
I have a plan. I think I can perform
even in the bad matchups. So, I rather
not see them, but if I do, I'm not too
happy.
>> And I can't imagine you're too worried
cuz you're doing a fantastic job and you
have six more rounds to play, but you're
off to a great start. Squirtle, thank
you so much. I wish you luck, but we're
going to send it back.
>> All right, thank you so much for that,
Barrett. It's always great to hear from
regional qualifier champions here in
their thought processes throughout the
round and how it all panned out. What's
going through your head right now, after
watching that one? I want to pick up
some Azir, dude. That deck is [laughter]
really amazing. It's not that often that
you have like token decks that can
actually beat the decks with real big
top end. When you have multiple elder
drakes and you're just throwing the
recruits at them and actually start
trading, that's kind of amazing.
>> Like I said, I think I I adore the
mental image of the big elder dragon. I
just see this one sand soldier, double
BF sword in hand, like I'm gonna have a
bit of this. And he goes charging in
things you love to see. Something else
I'd love to see is though there's been
there's a guest here in this venue has
been causing quite a stir. A lot of
people know them. A well-known content
creator Spoozy. So I think Bandit caught
up with them earlier. Let's see how that
panned out.
With me I have a very special guest all
the way from Sweden. A familiar face to
the league connoisseurs out there. Dad
of the dudes. It is no one else than
Spooky. Spooie. How you doing? That was
good. That's how I want to be introduced
everywhere.
>> It is my pleasure. Now, we are at the RQ
and I'm very curious. What is your
schedule looking like this weekend?
>> So, I went into this event. This is my
first RQ and this is my first TCG, so
I'm a bit of a noob, but I wanted to
have as many fun events as possible. So,
I'm only going to do sides. I'm going to
do a little bit of sealed, maybe try out
draft a bit. There's some creator events
that I can take part in that I'm kind of
excited. There's like it talks of a
draft where you can play like a booster
from each set which seems kind of cool.
So, I'm just going to be doing that and
then roaming around. There's [music] a
lot of things to see here like you know
all the vendors have some cool stuff. Uh
there's some photo booths I want to
check out. There's the wall over there
where you can like uh write your
signature and stuff. [music] So, that's
what I'm going to be uh jumping on.
>> There's plenty to be looking out for.
And any any highlights? I'm really
excited to get involved [music] in
either this one or that one. I mean,
well, first off, highlights for me is
always like meeting people that [music]
has watched my videos back in the day or
are watching them now. That's always
like the best thing to go to any of
these events. But, uh, I think I'm
really looking forward to playing a lot
of the um, uh, games where you open
packs. So, whether it's draft or seal,
uh, or maybe even that box draft thing.
That seems a bit that seems like a lot.
But yeah, like opening cards and then
playing out of what you get seems really
really fun to me. Yeah,
>> I honestly I can't wait. A box is a lot
of cards to be going through it.
>> It's pretty intense.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> However, you have been putting in the
time locally at your local game store
with a streaming setup.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, I haven't encountered like that
anything like [music] it in the wild.
What was your local's reaction to you
introducing that to the store?
>> It was the best. So, like Alphas Stock
where I where I play every week, they're
they've been really supportive. Uh, and
uh, you know, I always wanted to strike
a balance of making sure that everyone
that goes there, cuz not everyone that
goes [music] there might want to be on a
live stream. So, we always make sure
that everyone's comfortable with it and
if you sit down and you get matched by
[music] with me, you don't have to be on
stream. I'll just go to a pause screen.
Uh, but that's only happened once, I
think, since I got there because it
turns out everyone is just so awesome
[music] and loves hanging out and like
everyone is we're all nerds, so we're a
bit introverted, most of us, but we're
also really social at the same time. Uh,
so it's just been a blast. Uh and we've
[music] been steadily growing. So now
we're about like 50 people every week
who just comes down and plays uh plays
Rift Mound. Yeah, it's awesome.
>> It sounds like a real treat. And I mean
as any new project, [music] there are
some obstacles to overcome. What is the
next iteration? What is something like
ah if I can change that or I want to
update to really pull it to the next
level. What what's on the menu here?
>> Okay. Well, let's let me just first say
that if you're doing riftbound content,
the glare, man, the glare [music] is
like the devil that you have to
overcome. No matter what light you put
on a card, it's just going to glare out
the whole car. So, what I do is I come
[music] like two hours earlier before
the event starts and I put like, you
know, paper bags over the lamps and I
like cover everything up and it looks
like a weird grotto cave [music] in
there, man. When I'm done and then, you
know, we get the game in. But yeah, I
think um something that's more
interactable would be cool as an
upgrade. Like maybe that you can hover
over cards while you're watching the
stream, they can pop up and you can
[music] read about them. That'd be cool.
I like that just to get more in with the
viewers themselves. So in your local
scene we you have been seen playing many
a legend. Now just talk me through what
makes you stick by a legend just that
little bit longer. [music]
>> Usually it has to be a legend that not
everybody plays that isn't the meta
[music]
and then I play until I win basically.
So, right before I got here, I
>> That That does explain why why you're so
long on a J.
>> Yes, it is true. But before I got here,
I [music] got 40 on Kha'Zix on my Nexus
night, and that was like the highlight
of my Riftbound career, I tell you. Uh,
so now I might be ready to move on to
something else. I've been playing a lot
of Kha'Zix the past weeks.
>> Any teasers maybe?
>> Oo, I wonder what that could. [laughter]
>> You can figure it out.
You can just go on that.
>> Now, [music] I'm very curious, right?
Because in my experience, you're always
going into new games with friends. Which
CG [music] members have been
accompanying you on this new Ripon
journey, if any? So, none, cuz I [music]
haven't reached out to them about this
because uh it's always been a little bit
hard to schedule because I play games
during work hours and [music] they work
during work hours and then, you know, we
have we've all grown grown up now. So,
it's like a little bit hard to schedule.
[music] But, uh not many of them live in
Stockholm either where I am. So, it's a
bit harder to sort of [music] like get
it going. They live uh basically across
the whole world, but also like different
parts of Sweden. So, but I'm going to
have to do that. I'm going to have to
reach out to them a bit more
>> for the next CG meetup. Is that
>> Yeah, for sure. For sure. Sure. But I I
will say the one thing that is so
phenomenal about CCGs, which I
understand now, I get it now. People
have been doing this for years, is that
you get to go out and meet a bunch of
[music] new friends, which honestly,
like I'm sporting my 40s soon. It's kind
of hard to find new friends. like you
know I don't know what people do. I
guess they have normal [music] jobs and
they meet them there but like I have
going here traveling here. I went here
with 10 new people that I call my new
friends. [music] I and I didn't know
them a couple of months ago which is so
cool. So you know a one of a kind
experience. Now to close it off that
I've I've been the people have been
clamoring
hypothetical situation. Planty is now a
playable legend.
What domains is Plantyia in [music] and
what is the legendability?
>> I mean, it's probably it's green,
obviously. It's probably green, yellow.
Uh, so we're we're probably thinking
some sort of a jungle theme, creating a
lot of sapling tokens, flooding the
board, swinging in for good damage,
something like that.
>> I like it. [music] I like it. Riot, you
listening that. Get on that. Get on
that. Subie, thank you so much for
joining me. [music] Best of luck in all
of these side events and more more to
come. Back to you.
>> Back to us, which is you.
>> You're welcome.
>> Lovely to hear from Spoozy. Ah, it feels
so weird. Uh, I first met him.
Nostalgic.
>> It must be over 10 years ago now when we
did EULCS in Rotterdam. I did a video
with him. He looks a lot younger. I
looked a lot younger at the time. Uh,
very early on early on in in in my
career. We are heading on to round
three, which is still early in this
tournament, but uh we've got plenty to
talk about already. We just had an
Aurora matchup. Uh which unfortunately
an Aurora not finding Aurora is is bad
news. That's everything that you hate in
that setup.
>> Not me.
>> No, you okay? You [laughter] at home, I
know there's many of you in chat that
are like,
>> "That's actually fine with us. That's
okay if we never saw Aurora." I like I
like game too cuz it was a lot closer
and they had me believe it. I'm glad it
went to a game three because even though
you know you can have preferences in
decks, the best games are the ones where
both of them get to do what they want.
>> Yes. And Aurora is a deck that I think
we will see throughout the weekend. Um
the I think everybody always worries
that we're going to see like 20% meta
share for Aurora and most of the time it
doesn't end up panning out. We can
actually take a little bit of a look at
the meta share.
>> You have to mention that you are an
Aurora player.
>> I'm not anymore. I found a new home. I'm
playing Vex instead. But our players
this weekend, wow, we're at 10% share is
our highest share for a in the room is
is pretty
>> that puts a smile on my face.
>> It does. Okay, there's some fun stuff in
here. So, Mi and Diana I think we're
expecting to be up there. Urelia is a
superstar for day one especially.
Leblanc is another one we think will do
well early on in the rounds, but maybe
struggle start to get to Aurora and then
there's 67 Victor players in the room.
>> Honestly, I haven't seen them. Where are
they? Can Can we get them? [laughter]
Here's the thing. I feel like like
Victor has been flying under the radar
for quite a while. Even though I feel
like a lot of the matchups are quite
favorable for Victor. It just now we
just never see him in top eight anymore.
>> I know a lot of people have been kind of
best off hunting with Victor. I I
believe now those of you that aren't
with your finger on the pulse of the
full meta of Riftbound right now may not
know that last weekend we had an
infinite combo played at a competitive
level. Um which is a difficult one and
if we see it we will end up explaining
it to you. But we know that kind of like
the teams and the highle players all
said hang on a second let's theory craft
a little bit try and build things out.
It is in um mind and order. I I believe
thinking about it there should be no
reason that you can't play it in Victor.
So I wonder whether people have kind of
gone away and said is there a way to
refine it build it out there. I don't
think that's what everybody has done for
this but it may explain like an extra
percent an extra couple of percent here
and there on the number of players.
>> It's kind of kind of hard to to to
mention it like with Lux you do really
enjoy the extra card draw here and there
where you could where you are really
looking to get as through as many cards
as you possibly can. Yeah.
>> Um I think person personally Victor
would uh wouldn't ever debase himself to
something
>> actually that would be really in
character for Victor to go infinite.
>> And I will say a little bit of that is
speculation. Uh I know this week has
been a bit of a hidden testing week for
a lot of players. A lot of players
saying like I'm just going to hide my
stuff a little a couple more days and
then I can reveal it at Utre. So we're
excited to see what the meta is going to
do. I think we saw Pike there in the top
of the meta as well. The fact that we're
sub 10% on every single legend, I love
that means we have so much variance
here.
>> The the the diversity is absolutely
undeniable.
When it comes to Pike, are you a Pack of
Wonders believer or are you an aggro
apologist?
>> If I was playing Pike, I would just have
to uh No. You know what? I played
against Pike like week one of Unleash
and I was playing Aurora still when I
was playing it and it was miserable.
like the discard uh setup. So, I
actually would just want to avoid it in
general. We're heading into a round
three match up. We're going to get a
master uh as one of our players. Take a
quick look at the deck list. I ah okay,
there's some tech in here that we have
heard people talking about. It's not
really tech. Uh primal strength. Uh a
pretty good way of saying actually I'm
going to go over the top of you in this
combat. And there's not too too many
things you can do about it unless of
course uh it gets you know counter
divide whichever version of it. That's a
a pretty pretty big turnaround.
>> I I think the interesting parts here um
to mention is we have seen players
gravitate more and more towards triple
runer every single time
>> introducing more challenges as well. The
fact that we're a little light on that
and we're main decking the zonas which
they can be sideboarded out in game two.
We have seen it happen more and more. Is
there a overcorrection you think now
that the the initial fear-mongering
around Aurora is behind us and people
are
lifting their foot of the gas when it
comes to main boarding gear removal?
>> Yeah, I think it's really interesting.
So much of that kind of the minute one
of drop one replace one sometimes just
comes down to like player feeling. the
number of times I'm like, "This card is
useless." And you speak to somebody else
and it's like, "This card is amazing."
[laughter] On the other side of the
table today is going to be a Rengar, who
of course we've seen Rengar put up some
results recently. A lot of that quick
aggro uh style of like I'm just going to
play a ton of units and then move them
around, throw a hunt, lots of stuff,
bounce them back and and ready them
again for the ambush.
>> Here is what I love about the Rengar
list.
>> Sure. A traditional aggro list is
usually very linear.
>> It's kind of on the rails. It's like I
have one game plan. I'm going to stick
to it and if I don't make it, that is a
bit of tough luck. Like we saw with the
team up, right? There's not not a real
backup plan if you can't get onto the
battlefields. With Rengar, you're
introducing a lot more options for
yourself where every unit played is now
a decision for you. Yeah,
>> you can immediately jump onto the
battlefields if you feel the need or you
can develop for a turn. See what comes
out of it. Thrill of the hunt allows you
to regain control of units, dodge
removal if need be.
>> The flexibility of this deck is very
very scary and I think it will partially
explain
>> favorable percentage we saw for the
Rengar. And of course, we have uh a good
amount of favorable battlefields as well
with the Rengar when you get the
Emperor's Dis as well as Starring. Does
that maneuverability leave units behind?
Uh very difficult to to form one
specific line against an irresistible
faolk when you're going second. This is
such a dangerous position for uh your
opponent to play into is Fay Folk moving
into Battlefield into Rengar is
obscenely strong if you're not prepared
to deal with it.
>> And and this is like the lightest
version of it as well. When you're on
Starring and you can pull someone into
your Starring and then ambush and get
your faolk back into your own base is
where things get really out of hand.
That's where I quite like Melvin LM's
decision here of like you can have my
scuttle crab. If you want to do that,
you can have it because I'm going to get
the card back from it. I'm going to get
the information out of hand. I'm not
going to commit past that. Um and gets
the sand soldier as well for themselves.
So again, you kind of this is where you
have to say I just am going to give you
the least valuable option in this
situation. And that's exactly what's
going to happen potentially here. It may
not be the Rengar, could just be any of
the vulnerabilities.
target. Grim target fatal bombs.
>> That is a lovely little bailout for you.
>> And you heard just drown say targeting
fa folk with the apothecary. So when it
does enter it will be able to return it.
>> Always funny when it returns itself.
>> I I I do like that you can do that. the
the the audible response back in in
Vancouver when we saw the the apothecary
on um the the Starring as well where you
launch an attack. Oh, you punch first.
Let me bail out
>> by playing the the the apothecary,
bouncing back your your your initially
attacking unit, letting Grim Apothecary
bounce himself back to hand.
>> Like the Trixiness of a a Rengar deck.
>> Yeah,
>> you got to keep on your toes. the lines
are very similar in amount uh when you
compare it to a Diana where you you can
duck left, duck right, keep up, go down.
>> And one of the other things is the deck
when you're able to pick and choose your
battles quite easily uh does actually
have a surprising amount of card draw.
The Niddi if it wins combat will get a
card draw. We of course know that
there's Kaisers in the deck list that
can easily conquer a battlefield. Yeah,
exactly. More more card draw. So
typically these decks that play a lot of
units tended previously to not refill
their hand quite so well. Now now not
okay, I've just got to make sure I'm
making the right decisions.
>> And it's incredibly usually incredibly
hard to be taking care efficiently of
larger threats where it was all about
the drapens. It was all about the the
Kaisers, right? Where you would be
losing out two, three cards to deal with
one.
When you're in the situation
>> where you are tapping out, you are
vulnerable to all
>> one unit rarely ever stays one unit when
you're playing. Yeah, infern coming
through is a nightmare.
>> And buffing.
So buffing and even put it up to three
>> or just
>> it's an irresistible but
>> deadly fog at this point because of
course we'll get the plus one from the
Rengar legend as well which suddenly
this faith folk is going to be able to
punch pretty hard when it comes in as
well
>> again going to pump up
>> and the longer that this fa folk gets to
stick around the more impossible the
game gets for as long as that fa O gets
to stick around. Ye's legend passive
might as well be wided out.
>> It is. And then again, same thing. It's
Empress every time. It's like cool, I'll
just take that back to hand. Yeah, I'll
take my ambush unit back in
>> always as Inferno played out once again.
And this is the thing is like when a Y
falls behind on units, your replacement
units are either one or two small things
or one big thing. And Rengar actually is
fine with kind of both of those
exchanges because having access to your
chosen champion at reaction speed when
you want to pick it is like great,
you've played one ruin runner. I'm just
going to go over the top of that with
one unit in a Rengar. Of course, Fay
Folk can't pull Ruin Runner. That's a
really important distinction in this. It
it is exactly like you said, right,
where a lot of decks that will deal with
larger threats need to target a rank.
All right, I'm going to play four units
now. [laughter]
>> And you know, um it is not a death
sentence to have an inefficient quote
unquote inefficient trade where you have
to spend three, four cards to deal with
a single ruin runner.
>> If you only have two in your deck, what
are your outsing? And you can already
tell that pressure is mounting on the Ye
and his options are dwindling. The cards
in hand.
>> I believe just round uh moved the sand
soldier back and asked if that can be um
taken back and leave it on the
battlefield.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Looks like the resolution is that
the soldier has moved.
And that that's the scary thing is yes
okay you get a lot of the information
what's bouncing back and forth but you
still have to keep track quite a wide
hand
>> uh of exactly what's happening you can
see like Kaiser from hand
>> whether the original plan would have
been to accelerate the Kaiser and and
conquer the second battlefield um and
then
>> well if if you were to stay on the
emperor's day
>> you get the draw of seed of power right
>> that is the every every little little
card you and get your your kitty paws on
one. You will welcome.
>> But I I guess that would have been the
other thing is you get two draws. If
you're actually you're looking at the
Kaisen and you're like I want to conquer
it and I want to draw for the other
battlefield.
>> I think that that's like the one thing I
like more than drawing one card
>> is drawing two cards.
>> Is drawing two cards.
>> Hey, I can What about drawing three
cards if ever you can? Could Could you
Could you ever
>> What if you have a Nelly
Did he just summon that Nelli?
>> It was already there. I looked up and
saw it on the screen
because that will uh end up being
another card draw if you went committing
the punch first. This could I mean we're
we're tapped out now for for just round.
So you you know that this is a one-way
trip.
These are those efficient trades that we
were talking about that can really put
you far behind,
>> but it's also the bailout that ye really
needed.
>> Absolutely. Because that's what we said
about like either one big unit or like
multiple small ones. Well, now you're
like, well, I have a Mi already on the
battlefield, so if I can play something
else behind it. Actually, just going to
go the the uh Trinity Force route, but
if you can play more behind it, it would
be possible. Doesn't look like there's
another unit in hand. Um, haven't taken
a look at our
>> Ye players hand for a little while
>> and I do believe that was the last card
to go.
>> Yeah.
>> And even though we do have a Kai'Sa in
base, which we're very comfortable with,
let's talk about that Trinity Force.
>> Sure. cuz um you might have heard I am
not as excited to see it as in our match
against Teemo where it was very pivotal
to to mount the pressure up once again.
I feel in this situation it's very
convenient. It makes a lot of sense to
be playing it out.
>> However, it's quite vulnerable on the Gi
and now that um G also has no access to
orange runes anymore to no body runes.
>> You are currently safe from any punch.
It's just the disciplines that you have
to worry about an ong guard here or
there.
>> You're also, if I'm not mistaken, you're
also uh safe from the um
>> trigger buff
>> is primal rage that's in hand.
>> Yes, that is a four and an orange and a
body as well.
>> So, you're also not able to to deal with
that.
>> So, there there is a bit of an open door
right now if they want to capitalize.
The showdown has started.
It's nine is eight.
>> That's 10. She has a buff and plus one
from the sensor.
>> Six. Okay.
>> Yep.
>> Even it up. But if you can get another
pump spell off the top,
>> I'll play.
I
>> give the plus one again. Yes.
Every unit is just extra value with that
Rengar legend.
>> It's a bit of a race of chicken. How
much do you want to invest? End of the
day, it's
>> I have
>> he is valuable.
>> But is it worth the world? Jasa and
>> and it's just surprising amounts of
might come out like an inferno being one
might base but then with assault plus
the Rengar legend you're like actually
this is paying two
>> to add four to the board and that's an
insane trade like people do the math on
like Master Yi's uh legend ability and
it's normally like two for two energy.
>> Two energy for four is a great deal.
That is
>> Aurelia at home levels of value.
>> Okay. And that is going to be scooping
up game one from just saying, "Yep, not
able to come back. Didn't have
replacement units in hand in order to
reestablish control." And that's the
difficulty playing against this Renar.
Rengar has a million units and will just
spam them out. And the tough part there
is they are really getting in front of
the problematic part of the game for for
AE. They never got situated. They never
got comfortable in the game. They were
always grasping at straws as the ye
where if you do allow them to, you know,
entrench themselves on the on the
battlefield, get themselves that
stronghold all set up, then you are
sweating a whole lot more. And the ease
with which the Rango pulled off as well.
The pivotal point in that match is for
how long that FA folk was allowed to
>> yeah to be a terror on the battlefield.
And it's difficult because every time
you commit something to it, you've
always then got to look at what your
opponent has and say, "How badly do I
lose if they have Thrill of the Hunt
here?" Like, like how bad does this go
if I commit a lot to it and suddenly
you're like, "Yeah, I'll just move it.
It's fine. I it it'll get flickered, as
we may or may not call it." Um, but you
know, getting it banished and then
bringing it back. Uh, and just saying,
"Oh, you targeted it with something."
No, no, actually, we're not going to do
that.
>> The
detail to keep in mind here,
>> Sure. is that it was a little closer
than we'd like it to be. Not in score,
but there was no gas left in the tank
for Rengar. That was it.
>> There was not there was not an extra
King Cudo. There was not a way to really
stock up your hand once again. So even
though you can say that was perfectly
timed, there was not a whole lot more
margin for error. If there was one extra
out for the Yi,
>> it's a little more tricky. So even
though convincing game one,
there's not a lot of wiggle room there.
When Yi gets to go first, we might have
an entirely different game on our hands.
>> That is a a fair point. Um I do wonder
how the battlefield selection will
change in game two. We talked about how
like this the Empress Deas is is is a
good one obviously for for Rengar, but
some of the other options are also uh
equally, you know, delightful to play
around. What we like about Emperor Dea's
uh turn one
>> is there's just plenty of options with
the sentries that we play as well. A
quick one drop if you get it early.
Great. We can completely sideboard those
out if we think we're no longer needing
them.
>> That is kind of the flexibility
introduced if you need to introduce more
gear hate more gear hate. So there even
in the sideboarding options that Rengar
has where in plenty of other decks like
I kind of need all of these cards for my
for my deck to run. there are easy swap
outs as the battlefields available to
Rengars become less and less.
>> Yeah, that is a a fair point. I think we
also saw the on the the Y side the
actions came out. Um I saw the thinking
about not so fast as well. Uh these
Rengar type decks don't run spells
particularly much, if at all, outside of
Thrill of the Hunt and Thrill of the
Hunt and Not So Fast Not Interact.
>> Punch first. Like you're like, "Ah, no.
Okay, that that's kind of a useless card
in this matchup." Um, so didn't uh I I
was busy yapping with you when we were
looking at sideboarding for our Rengar
player, so we'll get surprised by
anything that changes on that one. Skull
crab to open makes a whole lot of sense.
And the stars are springing in this
>> Yeah. game plenty.
>> Yeah, if [laughter] you thought we were
bouncing at any point with just the one
battlefield allowing us to to move
things around, Starring
>> as a combined game.
>> Really interesting, isn't it? Grimma
carrying not bouncing himself. That is
um What do you think the the thinking
behind that one is?
>> Uh I think it's as simple as I would
like a unit on the board, please.
[laughter]
>> Deep takes.
>> But you know, that actually does. It
doesn't say too much, but it does also
say that like, hey, my opponent has a an
imperfect unit to open the game may
indicate sideboarding out the one drops.
We kind of talked about it. As I said,
it's not too damning.
>> Yeah, it's information.
>> Yeah, in a if you can utilize the card
to its full extent,
>> you're a happy camper. There can be no
doubt about that.
>> And this is the other thing is it tells
you, okay, there was a buff coming on
the the second way. You wanted a
recipient for that. So again, it's
piecing together like okay, maybe not
perfect at the time. Discipline on top
of that is now is the danger of
attacking into a master Y as that is a
six might only parro
>> and this hurts. Oh, that
>> is this gets the ball rolling for Y cuz
not only is he now establishing himself
pay folk
>> more on that later, but this is this is
that little nudge that the Y needs to
give the kitty a bit of a kick in the
face and make sure that they're not
coming out the gate swinging.
>> Mhm.
>> And I mean essentially that is just two
one and a half cards wasted. Oh, and I I
I would feel like if you're looking at
that hand, you feel pretty good. Uh,
double roomunner. There's a Rengar in
there. You got a charm. You got a back
off and a discipline. This is like a
toolbox at this point. So, you're like,
how do I develop? And then the rest of
my hand if I can deal with this FA folk.
You are we tapped out on are we
exhausted? No. One up is threat for um
for punch first, of course. So you can't
just you can't just charm the FA folk to
pull it in and and say, "Yeah, we're
actually taking this fight right now."
You do have a discipline. So, and I
guess the other problem is if you do
charm the fa folk, it turns off like the
scuttle crab's coming over now as well
>> is the fay folk move will bring it over.
So you turn off the legend ability.
>> Now you're gambling. Your opponent does
not have a a punch first in hand. And
>> if you do want to punch first, right?
You'll get your way all the way up to
six.
>> Yep. I'm not going to kill them.
>> The going to put my damage in here.
>> When?
>> Yeah. I I put one here.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Marking one damage. I think just a
little
>> It's not killing the scuttle crap.
>> Yeah, but it will heal up. Uh so that
that damage won't won't persist. Um just
to do that when you Oh, he was ready,
right? Oh, good. Yeah. So
>> just going through the uh cleanup step
for for the showdown and making sure
everything is straightforward. That's
going to be a year of hand. Now it's a
much better position in this game for
the master. Like you've weathered the
storm taken out two units and and denied
a lot of the uh trickery that the Rengar
was going to do with that fave folk. And
in the same way that we saw the Rengar
keep the Yi at arms length in game
number one,
>> it's being mirrored
>> in our game number two. Sabotage will at
least get some information for a Rengar
to get to get get a better feel for what
he's working with. But the the the most
information you're gathering is that
you're a sad kitty when you're looking
at that.
>> Yeah. You're like, do I take discipline
cuz it's actually two cards cuz I'm
denying you a draw plus a combat trick.
Back off. you can play around a little
bit more and you actually don't care if
you're going to get bounced back to hand
as much. I mean, when you're behind, you
care
>> for [laughter] sure, but uh it's, you
know, kind of the point that Rengar
wants to do anyway,
>> and you're still not all that safe to
start attacking the Y as well. Not only
do you have to power through six might,
>> there's still the threat of another
punch first laying it away.
>> You mean you did just sabotage, so
you'll have that the confirmation at
least. I believe these Darius are coming
in from the sideboard. Um, so we'll get
that as it is the second uh unit of the
turn. Uh, it's plus three as a reminder
because when a unit enders enters with a
Rengar legend, it's going to get an
additional plus one. The Darius gets a
plus two for being the second uh the
second thing played in the turn. So,
we'll end up taking that battlefield
quite handily. That is some extra
strength that is going to be difficult
to deal with. That's kind of like a
tipping point of might for Yi that Yei
doesn't get over with units alone. You
definitely need the cards like
discipline behind it to to be able to
take that fight.
>> Yeah. And we've expended already one of
the charms. So
>> yeah,
>> making it go away is a little tricky.
And if you do try and and you kind of
have to take care of it in this regard
cuz if you let that sit around another
turn,
>> punishing a single exposed unit on
Starring
>> is a lot harder than it seems cuz it's
so easy to just ambush a unit in.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Bounce it out. crabs. Yep.
>> Goes up to five with the conquer. And
this is the thing is this ye from this
position has been a lot quicker to be
able to punish deal as you said the
single units. You just take them out,
move on uh and make sure it's like a one
versus one on on a battlefield and never
really let the Rengar stack up too much
aggression. I mean to play Rengar from
the champion zone at this point is is
basically an entire turn's worth of
resources and and puts you behind. So to
you have to have units out first to then
set up. We'll go for it on the scuttle
crab. You're fine though that you you're
not particularly uh hardressed about
that and having a challenge in hand.
>> Is there a way to actually take
advantage of that?
>> Well, currently you are um sitting on
more might
>> than your your opponent's Rengar because
of the thear and s
>> of course. Yeah, cuz as it enters it
will end up doing. But we're going to
going to start Starring back.
>> But there's not a lot of cards that G
hides away.
>> Yeah, it's Sonia's basically.
>> Yeah, [laughter] we we talked about it
earlier. We're like, oh, if you got like
10 different hidden cards, they got some
mind work to do. any.
And this is that point in the match
where you have to take it slow. In my
opinion, you don't want to give
unnecessary breathing room to your
opponent, but trying to rush to the
finish line right now, trip up, leave an
opening for your opponent to take full
advantage of,
>> that is where the game can come
crumbling down. So, what I want to see
right now from the Y is coolheaded,
>> calm, controlled play.
>> It's It's Rengar that has to make a move
here, not the Y. Yeah. And Ye is
actually going to not do the opposite of
what you were saying, but put to a very
quick seventh point. We've only played
20 minutes in this best of three. We're
closing in on the end of game two. Um,
so that is a double hidden card. I'm
trying to think if there is anything
else or whether that is two zas. I'm
sure I'm sure chat will let us know.
>> Do you even like what's the line here?
It's so tough to to to cuz that is two *
eight might you have to power on.
>> Yeah. Which I think is not
insurmountable but I think from this
situation you have your Rengar which is
buffed. So again you you have to spam
out units that are able to to
>> eight and my bad.
>> Is there is I'm trying to look at what
is in in hand is it so you got the
challenge. Maybe it's possible. There's
a Kai'Sa in hand for accelerating, but
on its own is is, you know, weaker as a
unit and you can't challenge the ruin
runner is the other thing. So, you
already have to clear that out.
>> And and the other part is once you've
challenged, there's damage on your
Rengard like he does he's not very keen
to go into battle.
>> Get the ring up plus one
>> where
>> you have to show down the rune runner
first so that it heals up. Then you
challenge one Rengar to the other
Rengar. Now, then Kai'Sa conquers the
battlefield behind him. I am seven.
>> That is the one way to get yourself out
of that position.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Oh, I
uh
>> and then pray pray that there's no
define.
>> True. Yeah, that does that. And you know
that your opponent's got
>> one up. Oh, surprise on yours.
>> That's one.
>> Yeah. So even though you get it off the
star spring this turn, you still know
the the next turn is likely to be both
of these units still there and you've
expended a lot of your resources in
order to to play. Oh, has the defy.
Yeah, there's the fist pump as you were
saying. That's the one card you needed
to make sure they didn't have and you
made them have it. And that means that
Melvin LM is going to take game two in
this series. Uh [music] very quick from
both players at this point. A quick win
for Rengar, quick win for RC. Um, we'll
see what the game has.
>> Props to to Drown because there there
are a lot of lines for for Rengar,
right? Uh where do you want to stack
your extra might from Rengar that if you
are not seasoned, if you're not
experienced on this can be eating away
at your time and well against the Yei
who also has a limited amount of choices
to to be making really throws down the
gauntlet and says, "All right, can you
beat this? Yes or no?" Right? Is really
asking the tough questions to their
opponent. I like that. So,
>> props to Rengar players that keep a
clean ship, a tidy ship.
>> So, we're just getting some highlights
of games. [music]
>> That was I remember that. That That was
a good time. [laughter]
>> There's uh
>> we'll get back into the action.
for game number three.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you even want to make changes as the
Rengar?
>> Um, do you want to side back in Hello
again. Do you want to side back in your
uh one costs?
I'm I'm just going to double check. We
should be heading to a game number three
as uh that was a concession
um as as uh it was our master play was
on seven points. So yeah. So going back
across the table, um, do you sideboard
back in your one your one drops?
>> So the one drops are getting their most
value from Emperor Deas. However,
Yei has an Emperor versus Deas.
>> He is forced to field right now. So, I
think there's definitely an argument to
be made for them because the value can
get from them and just make it even
harder for the the Mashi to get stuck
onto the battlefields and it's another
unit you can hit on turn one. I I think
it's not at all a bad idea to be having.
>> And this is something that um I think
throughout the entire RQ journey and and
a lot of the things I talk with co-
commentators is like sideboarding is
such a undefined art. Everyone likes to
say, "I've got my sideboard guide. I've
got everything and it's it's hard and
fast and that's it." And that's how you
sideboard. And I'm like, "But when you
play through, sometimes you have to
desideboard for game three." Is like
your your actual early game that you
took out, well, no, you need that back
in for game three, which a lot of newer
players to competitive and best of three
don't necessarily look at is like the
pace of your your series really does
dictate how you play.
I always like to say
>> proper sideboarding really at times
feels more like an art.
>> Uhhuh.
>> You get creative with it. You start
start throwing out all the rules.
>> Such a consistent start though. unit
into Emperor's Dis.
>> Bring it back. Ah, use everything. Get
like that body left behind. Buff it up.
And this is this is kind of a tricky
situation for the Y to be in because uh
it is hard to make efficient trades with
the cards that are in your hand
currently.
It It's hard to to really get that one
for two, that one for three with a a pit
rookie.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> it is.
>> And you don't have a lot of time cuz you
you are running into the arena's
greatest.
>> So, you're on the clock. You got to be
mindful. And
even though you're not too mournful
about losing uh Lonely Parroh,
that is a quick third point though with
that Rengar coming down. Now, it's time
to to adjust around to see exactly what
the exchange can be. There's a niti in
hand if you're looking to go into a
showdown and then end up,
>> but you're just so exposed like that.
Rengar is is kind of a key piece
>> as a bit of a more valuable piece. And
>> introducing an inferna onto the
emperor's deas is so painful.
>> That's what I'm drawing.
>> I'm going to take it a little little
slower. Okay.
>> With the kingo there throughout there.
Get a little bit of extra might going
leave the rangar for what it is right
now.
>> Yep.
>> This it.
>> Yep. Just takes the draw. says, "I'll
just refill and look, I'll I'll
establish board control."
>> And that that should give the
information over to the Y about what is
in hand here because punishing the
Rengar when the Ye is tapped out, if you
had that option, nine out of 10 dentists
recommend taking care of the Rengar.
[laughter]
>> Hey, that bone tooth necklace. Where do
you think he's actually a dentist?
That's where he's getting him. That's
You've ever wondered where those
extractions go?
Now Rengar is going to hop over to the
other battlefield with uh the not quite
ganking
being able to ready and move over. And
as you said, he's kind of the menace at
this moment if like not dealing with it
in the last turn makes it very difficult
now once he is establishing units. You
you're going to have to dig a little
deeper, find bigger units, bigger
threats to to handle this.
>> It is a very large beat stick
>> that Rangar that has to be answered. And
on the defense, it only gets harder.
>> Yeah, there's a couple of tricky cards
in here as well. There's a pike in hand,
which when you can play that from hidden
and and do the you know, all the the
reveal, although there are multiple
pikes, so let me double check. Exactly.
I think
>> you could just like pseudo accelerate
it, a little extra might.
>> Thank you. Yes. Get it out, swing it,
and because it's accelerated, it comes
at four, but you have the Rengar. It's
like three energy for five might on the
board.
>> Yes. which is an absolute delight. He
needs to start coming up with answers
quickly because every turn that this
Rengar is allowed to
>> just be a predator and be pouncing all
all these succulent little
curve units. I think it might be too
late to petition something into Vendetta
about Kha'Zix and Rengar, but it's
there. It's there. Hear me. It's there.
There's something. The quest should be
plus one.
>> There is the uh the pike coming in that
you were were talking about will come in
pretty powerful at this point. So trying
to go over the top of that Rengar. So,
one of the
>> they'll be they'll be coming back in the
set after Radiance uh called I think
that's a couple's therapy uh set. We'll
we'll have Graves and TF and
>> very fair as uh [laughter]
>> that could be an expensive set if you're
paying by the hour on
>> this is a large commitment. This needs
to pay off for the ringer. If if they
get pushed off of this, they might as
well wave the white flag. What is their
answer for?
Oh, just saying nope, can't beat that.
Punch first comes out. This Rengar has
has really been the difference maker.
That one key turn of not being able to
get it off that first battlefield and
now it's sticking around and it it's
only backed up by more units from here.
So, where does it where does Melvin Alam
go here?
>> I I would be interested to see what's in
hand. Uh these aren't exactly the best
cards for
>> There is a lot of writing. There is so
there is a lot writing on this Rengar
>> on this Rengar if if it falls the the
the the unit for unit power that just
drowned has is is more significant
>> but
there's no there's no large enough stick
on board for the Rena right now. They're
working with kindling and they have no
sparks to to turn that into flames.
>> Yeah. And and then the the problem is
when you start using resources but you
aren't able to commit enough. Well, now
you've only got half of your resources
to try and do it the second time.
>> That's another Rengar in hand, isn't it?
>> That's another Rengar that just came off
the the draw from the scuttle crab. So,
it means even if you commit everything
a Rengar now, we just pull it back.
We're at seven points. You don't have to
play riskily. you actually can just keep
it and then look to uh recont control
the board because you know is there any
way that just round is able to first of
all conquer both battlefields and then
hold both it's almost going to be
impossible
>> exactly when you are talking about
Rengar you're talking about attack
attack you have a lot of assault trigger
on the infernace right by
>> in the same manner that a ye would
rather have to be defending a would
rather be
>> attacking
And I think it's very a very conscious
play for the ye
don't see the most opportune moment come
through. I will have my battle when it
suits me.
>> Yeah.
>> Rengar from the chosen champion zone
>> giving the
plus one.
>> Okay.
Yep.
>> Shoring up the second part of this turn
saying, "Okay, well now I don't need to
expend anything to go over the lonely
parro." I'm going to
play
one
>> the draw and Okay.
Okay, I killed a Y. It's okay. And this
you'll draw first. I'll draw one. Yes,
I'll draw. And let's
>> I believe only has like one rune up
though. So,
>> denying a double.
>> Oh, no. Doesn't have any
>> is seemingly impossible.
Yeah, with a Rengar on board and we know
there's a Rengar in hand.
>> I'm pretty sure it's it's just move into
the battlefields and
>> Okay. And a challenge as well.
>> Yeah, that's it. That's going to be it.
You'd imagine it's Rengar on Niti and
then you move into the other
battlefield. Everything taken down. And
that is a two-on-one win uh for Melvin.
And again, it's one of the reasons that
we're seeing so much Yi, the consistency
[music]
that you have answers to most things
already in your main deck. Uh, and even
though some of the decks can give you a
[music] hard time, especially postboard,
you once again are able to shore up a
little about how that game plan plays
out. You can side out the cards that
don't work for you, put in the ones that
that are there as a fix, and suddenly
you don't have to worry. And we do have
to highlight here
>> that the fact that the Ye clawed back
that game three was not an easy feat
whatsoever.
>> Going first has been so important in
this series up to game number three.
>> You are starting on the back foot. Just
that little bit where we saw just a
little bit can ruin your entire game as
we saw in game one. So be finding the
opening, taking the risk where Y is
saying, "All right, I know it's a little
bit risky to be fully committing,
tapping out to get the Rengar out, but
if it manages to stick, I'm in such a
comfortable position."
>> This is what we mean by make them have
it.
>> Yeah, it didn't have it.
>> And it did stick. That Rengar stuck on
the board. I I would love this is one of
these games where I would love to be
able to jump back into the moment where
that Rangar was on board and look at the
hand and just be like, "Okay, let's
figure out is there a way through? Is
was there an alternate play?" At that
point, um it wasn't something that that
I was particularly looking for, but you
know, that's always the fun of this is
you can rewatch it. You can go back,
check out uh your favorite plays or the
plays that you know, you are trying to
learn from the most cuz you can always
learn. There's always more to learn when
you're playing and watching RQ level
games.
>> Something that did stick out to me, I
don't think we've seen a single thrill
of the hunt.
>> No, we didn't.
>> In three games,
>> which is a bit sad. Sorry. Sorry, Rengar
mains.
>> It's it it is really is a shame because
that that flexibility and that
unpredictability that Ranger does bring
to the table, it it gets so much harder.
But I what more is there to say? I I
think we should ask it from the winner
himself. Yeah, let's hear from Barrett
and our winner.
>> Excellent cast there from our wonderful
casters and an excellent game played by
Melvin. Congratulations on that round
three victory on Master Yi.
>> Thank you very much.
>> How are you feeling? I mean, the fact
that you know, you're almost halfway
through the day and you're going on a
pretty good winning streak here.
Master Yi is one of the most represented
decks in the room.
>> Are you confident that you think you can
make day two with it? I I hope I hope I
hope I play master here because I think
it's very easy to wait easy easy to play
this deck and it's a very strong because
uh green and uh and orange has a very
good color. So I agree. I mean I think
calm is very much making a very long
prominence into the format right now.
And in that kind of same boat they
talked about predictability and the
unpredictability that Rengar can really
bring to you. Of course is a very fast
aggressive deck. We just saw Rengar get
second place um you know in in Vancouver
and so I think when it you look at all
the might that can go onto these units.
Master Yi is pretty well tailored to
fight against that because of the legend
ability
>> won't fight so it's okay for me.
>> Is there a particular matchup that
you're trying to avoid?
>> Sorry.
>> Is there a matchup that you're trying to
avoid in the because I think that one
seemed to be pretty good for you.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. There's a good match up
for me. It's uh I think I I like play
against because he my my opponent must
to use one card in one card for um for
the passive op. So it's very good for
me.
>> No, I agree. And I mean the exchange of
those resources I think was another
example here with Rengar because they're
having to play all these units and so
not only are the cards that they're
having to use just to get over your
legend passive ability, you know,
they're also units that they don't have
on the board anymore. Whereas other
decks like Ireelia are playing things
like a discipline just to match your own
legend expert pilot. It was an excellent
match of course but you have so much
more tournament to get back to. I don't
want to keep you for too long.
>> Congratulations. Good luck on the rest
of your rounds and I hope to see you in
day two.
>> We'll send it back.
>> Thank you Barrett. Always lovely to hear
more about the matchups and we we were
hearing about that match up there where
we were like oh is it favored? Do you
think it's not favored? I was quite
surprised by by him going, "Oh, actually
I feel very comfortable in this
matchup."
>> Nice. Good. I'm like, you're the one
that's played it more than me. So,
>> and [laughter] he's winning. So, and is
one obviously.
>> Exactly. Uh we we are going to see
plenty of Yi today. Uh I I think it's
just the the way to put it. um me and
Ye.
>> Yes. Yeah. At a stretch for sure as we
are going to have Yi featured once again
in this matchup, but I think we have a
little bit something spicy again. It's
it's another This is kind of like um
a little bit like Scott Pilgrim at this
point where it's like Ye against the the
suitors like Ye's trying to fight off
all of these different decks we're
playing against. So, it's you against
the world. This time it's Pike. Uh, and
it's uh, awesome. Awesome from
Challenger TCG
>> here.
Just have take it all in just for a
little.
>> I'm looking.
>> What stands out to you?
>> The ultimate Baron Asher.
>> All right. Now, [laughter] I was casting
with with a with with a magpie.
>> Very much so.
>> Here, this is a development that's quite
recent. Introduction of the list.
>> Okay. And why do we see that work so
much? Well, there's already the pack of
wonders treasure trove
>> uh both. Oh, I play one out and I bounce
it to hand uh rinse and repeat value.
>> But when you introduce the list now, you
can bounce that multiple times,
[laughter]
multiple times, get multiple debuff
stacks, okay,
>> in a single turn and take down larger
opponents or keep spamming those falling
stars.
>> Interesting. So even even the Rengars
and the likes, even when you go uh
through all of that, you can still get
units back into falling star range. And
what will help hitting that all the way
back home? Two fizzes. Interesting.
That's a really cool adaptation. I I
love that. When I saw the list, I was
like, "This is really cool. This is such
a good card." And then I read that it
doesn't have like action or reaction on
it, and I'm like, "This card's rubbish.
I don't want this card anymore." This is
a card.
>> The thought of playing it multiple times
per turn. I love that. That's That's
really cool. Um, this is very similar in
a list to the one we previously had.
We're one up on Rune Runner. Uh, let's
take a look if we can quickly spot where
we're one down of. Might be one first,
mate. Ah, it's almost the same list.
Just pick up orange and green cards and
put them in. What the tricky part is uh
for the Pike is before the engine is up
and running, you need to jump through
like four separate hoops.
>> Okay.
>> And if you if you grab the list, but you
don't have the engine going yet of um
the the the pack of wonders, that is
kind of a brick card. the chances of
bricking with the list in your list,
don't get confused now,
is just a lot higher. So, you need to
draw a lot more cards. You need to see a
lot more of your deck to reach that
ultimate potential of your deck. It will
have to be in this game where they prove
the consistency is there.
>> Okay. Uh, good to know. We're going into
game two, by the way, so we'll find out
who won game one. Um I am excited by
this and I'm glad that I have you with
me here to take me through the list in
the list. Um
>> we got lists on lists.
>> Yes. As uh I mean this is one of the the
rare decks in the format right now that
have direct damage spells. Like there
are a few there there are some and of
course a lot of them is trend towards
blue playing like singularity and stuff
like that. But when it comes to like the
spells we know and love like the falling
stars many many of the the decks
>> don't necessarily find places for them.
like the Rengar that we looked at just
then. Not not really a fan at least in
the main board.
>> Exactly. And in this scenario, even
though Yei is running ahead with it,
>> winning the first game,
the direct damage is you're pretty happy
with it into Yeah, cuz you can kind of
play around the legend ability. The only
downside to that,
>> Yay be having a lot of combat tricks.
>> Yeah, that's very true. And actually,
just to note, we're going into the
beginning of game two with 26 minutes on
the clock.
>> So, that was a long game one. That was a
near 30 minute before sideboarding uh
game one of this match. So, let's see
how we go. It's a Ripper's Bay and
Emperor's Des
for our battlefields in this game.
Good.
>> Oh, that is a Well, let's wait till it's
back on their turn. But that is a gut
punch.
>> Yeah, go with nothing for now. As you
said, maybe there's some kind of
because this is where it really gets
awkward.
>> Yeah, I will say I'm I'm a little less
familiar with the in and out of Pike.
So, it's one of those ones where I'm
like, I feel like this is bad, but until
he passes the turn back, I'm like,
>> it's bad, right?
>> It's real bad.
>> Okay. Yeah. Now you've chled and done
nothing on turn one. Yeah, that's bad.
>> Why is the Why is it even worse? You
play the rippers bay when you're going
first. So, you can almost always ensure
>> discard a card
>> that you can get on there first, get
that first piece of engine going. And
even though we the discarding has
started early on into the game, it's
just not that much of a threat
>> because even though it says discard a
card, you can kind of interpret it as
discard the worst card. Yes. Yeah.
However, I would say being somebody who
loves discard mechanics, I am like
rubbing my hands at Emperor's Deis being
the battlefield on the other side
because if I can bewitching Spirit,
bounce it back, play it again, bounce it
back, play it again, bounce it back,
play it again, and just constantly get
rid of cards from your hand. If you have
no cards in hand, I feel great.
>> It's lovely to get a sand soldier for
it, right?
>> Yeah, cuz Spike is pretty content. also
just put kicking it back into your hand.
>> Yeah.
>> Um getting the the sand soldier for it
is great.
>> Is it worth giving up the gold
>> that you' be getting from Pike for it?
That is kind of the the the the toss
that you're you're the decision that
you're weighing.
>> That's a really good point there as
well. As you said, like are you
sacrificing more by taking the getting
the unit than the economy?
And let me tell you, when you're playing
falling star upon falling star
>> and you only have one fury rune, that
gold is going to be significant if you
end up taking that choice. So
>> here we'll start conquering. And uh when
we do start uh putting cards back into
hand from Rippers Bay, we'll be getting
>> more room.
>> Yeah. So there's the answer. It is going
to be just sticking to the plan. I'm not
going to get swayed by my opponent's
choice of battlefield. I'm just going to
take
>> There's a Ye waiting to give him a very
warm warm welcome. A scorching welcome.
>> Yeah. And as we know, only one run up
means Falling Star is going right
through because not enough to pay for
anything like a not so fast. Defy would
not do the job in this situation. So
getting it out of them
>> and stopping the momentum that Y has
built up a little bit is key in the
situation. Right now as the pike, you
kind of want to rush towards seven and
10 energy where you can keep spending
those those gold tokens to get the the
profits to be sharing the booty and
lay the pressure upon the do not allow
them to get onto the battlefields. If
they do get on the battlefields,
>> throw a star at him.
>> Yeah. And and that's I think probably
one of the thinking about this one of
the trickiest parts about this pike deck
is balancing how your recycles affect
like your options in game or what you
can represent as an option and and how
the gold well sabotage will make sure
you're not representing any actions that
you can't do anymore.
>> Sabotage and skull crab out there.
>> Yeah. Like I'm going to have permanent
vision.
>> I I wasn't aware that Ionia was a
surveillance state.
>> I I was going to say [laughter] we we
have cameras on the on the stage for
hand view. Should we just tap that in?
Do you want to just put a little monitor
there uh by the skull scuttle crab and
be like just just play open hand?
>> Unlike Vancouver, uh I don't think this
will be the last turn to leave your hand
open as well. So
>> yeah. Ooh, I am a magpie. And that
[laughter]
is uh got to get that out of hand so you
don't get forced to discard it at this
point. Um, but I mean you're looking at
your opponent's hand, you're like,
"Okay, they have a stack deck. They have
a way of of making me discard." Uh, so
suddenly my read on your hand and your
information and what options are in this
game is now drastically different. Stack
deck. The one card I saw from that was
stack deck. So, so you can chain them.
It always feels uh like good for an
option of like, "Sure, I'll do that."
>> And here is where we start to slowly
enter the comfort zone of a Pike deck.
when we are getting when we're hitting
seven, eight runes
>> and we can keep the chains going. Right
now,
>> we
prefer to get some more units out,
>> but a single discard right now already
hurts a lot more for the
>> Yeah.
>> And with the tools available to them,
the lonely pour and the scuttle crab,
yeah, they will be getting draws. If the
Pike lets it happen,
>> they they can wait for as long as they
want to amp the pressure up on their
hand first, take the hit in the victory
point department, and then let the Yei
draw cards when it suits the Pike.
>> Of course, that interaction that people
may not be as familiar with with the
treasure trove of the pack of wonders
and the way that it bounces it and it's
when it leaves the board, you draw the
cards. So, um, again, another thing that
people are just so used to treasure
trove is like, oh, you channel a rune,
you you put it in the trash. But
actually, the other way around is if it
leaves the board by going back to hand,
you just continue, just get a lots of
cards.
>> And that is why a once a pike deck
reaches that terminal velocity, I'm
going to say, where
>> you have such efficient use for your
energy once you have plenty of it. And
because the engine itself will give you
more runes, once it's going, it's very
hard to stop.
>> Yep.
>> That is.
>> Not quite the infinite
>> soldier.
>> Pike going infinite. No, definitely not.
But uh it it's definitely the kind of
thing that I think this is one of those
decks that you you just have to know
the mechanic loops if that makes sense
of like if I do this this is what I end
up getting like I'm I'm net positive on
and I draw into more and then okay maybe
I do it again do I have another loop
>> because the one part that you are always
a little bit worried about when you
completely tap out
>> Uhhuh. It's like, all right, what's the
absolute worst thing that could happen
right now? Getting onto the
battlefields, even though mounting up
the pressure, getting more bodies out
there. The the fact that Falling Star
can deal with that rather efficiently.
>> Yeah.
>> Up to a certain point, there's
definitely a sweet spot. Once you're
hitting Azir territory,
>> you're way past your comfort zone.
>> And when you're tapped out, you really
hate seeing your opponent charm
>> for the most part. like in this
situation, charm the Vex in, pay the
deflect cost. You're like, "Yep, that's
worth it. I'll uh I'll take that stand."
And yet, you're right, is like there
there may have been some vulnerability
on the next turn to Falling Star, but if
there's no units behind it,
it's difficult to turn the favor back to
Pike in some ways, at least in my
perspective.
>> That is where Pike kicks in because
>> as long as your opponent is not getting
the points, you are doing fine as Pike.
>> Sure. All right.
>> Cuz you can keep your uh opponent in top
deck mode. If you manage to loop uh the
the discard triggers,
>> it's all about not falling too far
behind and not letting your opponent get
too close to the finish line that a
single top deck will win them the game.
>> So eventually your opponent is just
hellbent, no cards in hand, you're
drawing only the one card per turn,
hopefully not getting any usefulness,
and you're like, well, I don't care if
you got to six points or seven points as
long as you don't get to eight. And
>> that is also why um
>> it becomes a lot more clear why round
why game one took 30 minutes. [laughter]
>> That's so true. That's where we're at as
uh
>> cuz the first two stages of of Pike's
game plan is not per say winning but
more so not losing.
>> Okay. So we're it's a grind down your
opponent deck and just you know
>> eroding like the wave smashing into the
stony shore.
There's got to be something there.
Something about build water. Something
about,
>> you know, there's there's something lore
there. That's not my forte, I will say.
>> Sleep on it with the fishes. [laughter]
>> Well, Bewitching Spirit is going to put
another card to the graveyard.
>> Yeah, they have a long way to go before
Ye is in trouble.
>> Yeah, cards in hand. Uh, Lonely Var will
help with that as the scuttle crabs. And
it that's why perhaps it is a war of
attrition at this point cuz it's like
I'll make you discard as you draw two.
>> Punch first hitting the bin. Uh not make
sense here. This is a very costly
solution to answering a falling star at
that point. The
>> h it's action speed. So
>> yeah, it's one of those things that
>> that's the worst kind of answer. The one
I can't
>> the one you can't do. Yeah. He's like
I'll get rid of that. Um,
>> yes,
>> but that's a fair point. I think that's
one of these things where you are deep
in the tank. You're just like, "Okay,
it's plus five and then nope."
>> Again, falling star, it's slightly
>> It's half a step out of the meta, right?
So, you're looking at
>> it was it was third.
>> Uh,
>> I believe cuz I
>> You play treasure.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Keep your opponent accountable, right?
Yeah. Exact responsible for keeping a
clear game state.
>> Yep. Yep. That is uh one of the things
>> that at the uh competitive
level is expected.
>> You don't want to assume that that's
kind of the thing. You don't want to go
oh it's probably that
>> we are slowly mounting a
an army in our base consisting of a bird
and Darius. It's vulnerable cuz once
again we find ourselves tapped out.
There's still plenty of cards in Ye's
hand.
>> This uh I'm trying to think of what game
it is, but I I just have these visions
of we're just opening treasure chests at
this point of like quick open all the
chests. See what's in there. We do
behind what's inside chest number 20. Is
that what you want? Constantly
discarding. It's every It's always
discard.
the the pieces of the puzzle are slowly
getting assembled, but now is the time
that we need to start pushing back on
these whole triggers. The moment you
allow the Yei to get himself in a
position where they can start
threatening the game
>> Uhhuh.
>> quote unquote getting to six victory
points,
>> I will
>> is when the game gets so much more
restrictive for the pipe. They have to
take in. All right. I have to play
around this.
>> These two
targets are falling star.
Using it on the scuttle crab is an
interesting one because it's not on a
battlefield, but what it does say is if
you just discipline it, it's still going
to die because zero might goes to two,
falling star deals three. So how how
many units survive from this is purely
down to how much the red wants to
expend. So the discipline is likely to y
go on to the other unit that will keep
it alive.
>> Mhm.
>> But with three points of damage
reveal most of the cards you've already
seen.
And we do have the list.
>> The list is there. And I was going to
say this is not the scariest of hands,
but this hand represents the ability to
refill your hand with more interesting
options quite well. It's like, okay,
this isn't a problem now, but in a war
of attrition, I don't want you to draw
more. And not only that, with the damage
marked,
>> I'll build water.
>> You can
>> Oh, yeah. Okay.
>> pull him down even more.
And if you then get onto
>> Mercedes gone,
>> kick the bird back to your hand,
>> play it out again. That those are the
types of engines that you're looking to
get scoring.
>> Yeah. Uh awesome. Awesome. Uh tag build.
>> Uh
think
>> you're good.
>> You heard Dor say thinking. Uh the
reason for this is the minus would take
uh the unit down below the threshold to
die with the three points of damage that
have been marked on it already. That is
one key thing in riftbound that if the
unit doesn't heal up via combat or end
of the turn, that damage will kill it if
you drop it down uh below. Discipline
comes up that'll again put it back now
to the equivalent of one health
remaining. It of course does have a
higher might cost than that. And
>> there you have it.
>> Here's what you said.
And that just burnt a lot of resources.
The list gets played after being bounced
back. You name Billwater again, minus
two again.
>> Yeah. The the the only upside here is
that discipline replaces itself.
>> Yes.
>> So, we're not like actively going down
yet, but the moment that battlefield
clears up and we have another way for
our our bird to be replayed again,
>> that is when the pressure starts to
mount. Then four points or three points
away from victory feels like miles.
>> Yeah, that is very true.
>> An element that is very very relevant.
The clock is ticking down ever still.
>> Yeah. So Awesome Awesome does have to
get through this game and then
>> get to a point mine to or might.
>> Sure.
>> Oh, okay. So um so plus six
>> this is falling this is uh
>> list one and then list two. So it should
be minus 7 plus six, right?
>> That is I believe correct. It should be
minus 7 with plus six
>> - 43 damage.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That that's the
correct way of putting it.
>> Oh
okay.
>> It's okay.
cards in.
>> Of course, it was the ong guard believe
that was used there as well. So, that is
what takes it up to the six.
>> That's three cards used. Yes, as you
said, discipline, as as I love to say,
discipline is great cuz it replaces
itself, but still, you always want to
use that in in a better spot. Like, it's
gone. That's now you're you're against a
deck that is forcing
>> five five right now.
>> And look how little energy is invested.
That was [laughter]
>> Yeah, that's actually I guess the thing
as you said when you get to this point
with Pike, you're like, well, my things
all cost really little amounts and I can
do a lot of damage with them.
The the issue you're running into right
now,
there's only one pack of wonders.
>> Yeah, I'm
>> We are done putting it back in our hand.
>> There's a second one.
>> You dig?
>> Hiding.
>> Um there I mean, as you can see, there's
still options for drawing. Yeah, I was
going to say treasure trove with the
treasure trove and just say, "Yeah, I'm
going to do that." Like that might be my
other option. Hope the top of my deck is
is going to give me some kind of good
fortune. Otherwise, you're like, "Well,
I kind of have to start thinking."
>> Oh, probably.
>> You're going to have to commit one of
the units. It's probably going to be the
uh
ah I don't know actually. I was going to
say probably going to be the the the
Lomite.
>> So, here is the dilemma that you're in.
even though your Darius is buffed up.
>> Yeah, you need to start putting that
focus
>> and the fact that yeah, there's damage
on it, but there is still
>> and again this is coming back to players
to represent the board state that is
actually uh you know a pretty strong
>> unit that is there. Even though it's got
points of damage on it and has been
minus, we've still had a lot of pump
spells pushed back into it as it's with
the mastery defender bonus is going up
to seven again.
That's good. Yep. Oh.
>> Oh, and now all of that earlier in the
turn,
>> all that
>> obliterated by the punch first
>> finally stepping into a window where the
action speed is able to to to resolve.
And that
>> suddenly now
>> plus 11
>> uh [laughter]
>> plus 11 - 4 and the damage falls off
because we have had a a heal come
through from the end of that showdown.
>> That that's not your first mate. That is
your first best friend forever.
>> Uh promoted to captain [laughter]
admiral at that point.
>> First admiral first.
But to highlight how gut-wrenching of a
turn that is that even though it cost
the Ye a lot, they had a lot to be
spending.
>> Yeah,
>> they are not poor in any form
whatsoever. The fact that they can
>> they they probably don't want to
retreat, but giving open battlefields
away and giving up your legend,
>> that is not the way you want to be doing
it.
>> You can just flood your own base. You
don't have to worry about Pike ramping
up the pressure. The world is at your
feet. And now the Pike's hands are tied.
They have to They have to cover off
game-winning plays each time again.
>> And that's the thing. We talked about
how Pike wants to have their opponent
have no cards in hand. Look at the game
state we're in. Pike has no cards in
hand and the red's hand is full. Like
this isn't how that's supposed to go.
But, uh, Awesome Rosen was just forced
to play out, you know, the treasure
hunters, uh, the treasure trove,
everything treasure. Uh, not treasuring
this moment in round three is they'll
get the one draw off the top of the at
the beginning of the turn, get the one
draw off the treasure trove, and then
you're you're hoping that your discard
draws are favorable,
but if you can't make it work, there's
no real line to turn this game around.
your the things that you have on board
are not significant enough to stop this
Y.
>> So if we want to look at the other side
of the metal, we know
one thing,
all of those combat tricks, spells
>> that can turn the tide, they're out
there. They're mostly in the trash. Now,
>> if you can find the Darius, once again,
get something accelerated out there.
Keep in mind that uh Pike can also hit
the ground running.
>> Yeah. So they they're not helplessly
lost at sea, but they're getting on that
point where if they're not careful, they
might be sucked away by the tide.
>> Remind me, was was Pike played from the
champion zone in this game? It's a
little above the the screen. I believe
it was played earlier, right? I think
it's in the trash. Uh third. Well, that
would be really unfortunate.
>> That's on me.
>> Or my my
screen is a little far away from me
>> in the in the general sense right now.
Yeah. As the ye
>> Yeah.
>> you have the option to either just flood
your base,
>> take your time with your decisions, and
that is kind of the the other part that
you have to keep in mind as well. If
this does go to to a game three than
overtime,
I'd rather be playing the the legend
that has Accelerate on it. Ah, that was
a shake of the head.
>> Uh, photo red power. Pick this up.
>> Going to pick up the draw.
>> Now the dick continues. And do keep in
mind you can just play it out, pay the
power, and then just get rid of it
yourself. You don't have to bounce it
back to hand.
>> That was a tide turner picked up from
that. So at least has some options for
if you want to be able to
>> use this to crack it. I'll get back
>> the oldfashioned treasure
>> star cross. Does that help? Does that
slow down enough? Now the problem with
slowing down enough is six points to one
point means that the red from this game
state if the time expires
will still take game two being this far
ahead.
>> Um
>> so you do have to close the gap in
enough time.
That's
>> and then you're in the draw bracket
which becomes tricky in its own right.
>> The news is slowly tightening.
>> Yeah. And
>> when you get into choppy waters.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You you need you need good
control out there.
>> Can they write the ship? Because
honestly with the resources out there,
you're not looking good. And a eight
might Rengar.
>> The Rengar to an open battlefield
surprise just trying to uh hold on.
Defied. Oh, that's painful. One of the
only options that Awesome Ross had. And
that's the extent of the hand to say,
"Nope, I can't come back from this
situation." So, the red is going to pick
up game two against a very relieved the
red at that point. Uh, against a deck
that really wanted to just drag drag
Musty into the late game. And we we
talked about it at the very start, the
list variant of this deck. Yes, it has a
lot of flexibility, but it is prone to
bricking there. There are just more dead
cards that don't do anything unless you
have
>> their two friends to go along with it.
And only having a a single pack of
wonders really hurt them there. Not
having a turn one play really hurt them
there. And it was at the very end of the
day a death by a thousand cuts.
>> Yeah, it's a really interesting deck
archetype. I I I do like it and clearly
there's something there. Uh the
challenger TCG team I'm sure have been
testing and playing against matchups. I
would be interested to know how that
matchup goes because it kind of is uh
you know the old adage in movies of
someone doing like a lot of flippy stuff
around and then Mi used to stood there
in the middle like I don't care about
your flips like it doesn't matter
>> and then Rengar comes out and just puts
him in a bag.
>> Exactly. It's kind of just like that
consistency versus like flashiness and
showiness. Uh and in this regard, uh
consistency once again wins. Uh a
surprise. Um I at least the games that
we've cast, Masi has been like the
consistent, straightforward, relatively
dominant deck right now for day one that
we will keep an eye on as we go through
the rest of the day. That means we can
close in on round four when we come
back.
Welcome back and to quick decks here at
the Riftbound RQ in the format where
players have 30 seconds of time to tell
me what their deck does. Next to me is
Nexus. Why did you choose your deck and
what did you choose to play?
>> I chose to play Kha'Zix, the best buck
in the whole game. He's awesome and I
play him because he his play style is
very unique. I love it.
>> All right, very unique play style. We
like to hear that. You have 30 seconds.
Are you ready? Sure.
>> Go. So, first of all, we have our
signature ability. It's basically a
charm that we can use and it's a right
the wind. It's one of the most broken
cards in the whole game. I have only 30
seconds, right? Okay, we got to go fast.
Irresistible faith hog. It's a two drop.
That's basically a charm. It's really,
really good. Uh, you can oppress your
opponent really good with it. And that's
the whole ability with Kha'Zix. And I've
almost forgotten his legend ability. It
makes you uh capable of moving your
unit, your exhausted unit back to the
base and it's also [music] capable of
buffing. So, and we are done. Thank you
so much. So, to summarize this,
everything in your deck charms and
you're taking away the main strategy of
your opponent by just pushing everything
into your battlefields,
>> right? Exactly. Uh 30 seconds were
really quick. [laughter]
>> All right. Thank you so much, Nick. Yep.
That's how Khazix does. It just lurs you
in, gets you singled out, and then wins
the game versus you. Thank you so much.
We're going back to the broadcast with
haste.
[music]
All right, Rift Bounders, we're coming
back at you loud and proud here at the
Utre Regional Qualifier. I'm Shay Burn
joined by the one and only Leo. How was
that explaining those decks in 30
seconds then? You made it they made it
look quite easy.
>> Yeah, I mean they were incredibly
stressed because I also stared at them.
I thought I could yell at them a little
bit more but then that would have taken
away from their 30 seconds of time,
right? But I think all the rift bombers
did a fantastic job and you actually get
a lot explained in 30 seconds sometimes.
>> I mean you say that I think if I was
trying to do that in 30 seconds I would
be so unbelievably tongue tied. I don't
think I would be rather good at it. So,
as we've been getting through this UT
regional qualifier here, Leo, anything
jumped out or surprised you that we've
got managed to get on stream so far?
>> I mean, we've just seen the Pike, two
very, very strong players against each
other. And Pike got dominated by Master
Yi, and usually Master Yi is one of
those decks that is not incredibly
flexible versus a deck that thrives off
of its utility like Pike, right? Pike
has different forms of removal, has
Falling Star, which is one of the best
spells that cannot be defied. So in
theory, you would say, "Hey, this deck
can easily take out Master E's units and
then try to start hand ripping like the
Blood Harbor Ripper does." However, in
game two, you have seen the battlefield
that now all the Master E players are
on. Emperor dies, dies, dies, Emperor
dies,
>> dies. Combine this
>> with the little scuttle crab. You have
almost infinite draw, infinite value.
you can always drop the little crab and
then try to conquer with his hand
soldiers. So, you get so much value out
of this battlefield that it's really
really hard to combat. Then you're just
amassing cards after cars while you're
also holding. So, your opponent will
have to try and get rid of those sand
soldiers. Has to invest something in
there. So, can't always keep up three
energy to play the bewitching spirit and
then you're just running away from it.
And I think this is the beauty of how
battlefields can flip entire matchups on
their heads. Sometimes you have some
some we call them hate battlefields like
Rockfall Path versus the Renga. You
can't ambush into that field. Sometimes
you have some some battlefields that
just proactively help you win some
matchups that are tougher to play and I
love that. Yeah, it really seems to be
like Mia has been doing fantastically
well so far on our stream and I believe
it's actually our most represented deck
here this weekend and it's it was
unfortunate to see the Pike, you know,
not do as well cuz I did pick it as my
cast prediction, but we also picked some
other MVPs from the Unleash. Remember
viewers, this is our first time here in
the EU. We've managed to get our hands
on Unleashed and take it to a regional
qualifier. Leo, what did you pick and
why?
>> Okay, so first of all, Inferno, if
you're listening, I am terribly sorry I
underestimated you so much in the
beginning. I thought smite was kind of a
game changer card for Fury, but Inferna
is such a strong two drop. It should be
illegal to be that versatile when you're
a two drop. So, you can you can just
player on your first turn, get a conquer
point, and then sometimes also with
Emperor's Days, just bounce that card
back. However, this is also a combat
trick, this card is incredible. Plus, VI
Peacekeeper, I think those two together,
they make a good Rexai deck.
>> Yeah, you've sort of picked it to the
ambush ones there, especially Inferna in
used in the Rengar deck. You get the
Pride Stalker buff there as well,
playing it from the hand. Love to see
that. Now viewers, you might look at
mine and you can sort of tell what sort
of decks I like. I like big bad scary
boss monsters. I've gone with Elder
Dragon there and Baron Nasher. You know,
two cards I think when they hit the
field make an immediate effect.
>> I think the way you're smiling there is
every single time when someone drops an
Elder Dragon or an Aurora against me,
this is just the faith that you're
getting from them. That is the
>> That is Yeah, finally got it in play.
Everyone elder dragon and Baron Nash. I
just like those units that come down Leo
and they just immediately affect the
game. Baron Nasha cannot be target given
every one plus two. Absolutely love
that. And who doesn't love being in a
third battlefield adding a whole new
dimension to the game and obviously
Elder Dragon any amount of damage will
kill your opponent's units. I love a bit
of that.
>> Yeah. And I mean the star spring scuttle
crab combination Yeah.
>> from Bandit is also really fantastic,
right? Because this kind of fixes some
matchups for the deck. decks like Aurora
or decks like the Lux Infinite Loop, you
want to score early on. So, if you start
with a Scuttle Crab, you push it into
the Star Spring and then you're playing
your first mate, you immediately get the
double conquer and you could start
running away with points in a deck that
was deemed slow in the beginning from
everyone.
>> You're so right. It's got a crab.
Honestly, one of underrated cards I
think coming into the format and
everyone's quickly realized how good it
is. And then we're looking at there at
the irresistible faith folk there and
the Rengar from James. you know that
irresistible faith focus. It's one of
the best cards there in the Rengar deck
to be honest. If your opponent starts
trying to get clever with it and they
just hide their units at the base, you
can say no, no, no, bring them up over
here where you can meet my inferners, my
Rengars and all that stuff. Speaking of
Rengar, you know, putting on a stellar
performance here at these regional
qualifiers, getting second place already
and now has been put on the map.
Whenever I go to locals, I have to
combat my way for a few Rengars and
quite honestly, it's scary every time I
try. Irresistible Fay Folk is such a
versatile card in multiple decks and it
strongly picks apart some of the meta
decks like Master Yi.
>> Yeah,
>> I was going to say it's it's a nice way
to out a HU from your opponent, but I
don't really necessarily think you
should do that to give him an extra
move. But if you already have a unit in
one of the battlefields, you can push
your irresistible fay folk from your
base into that battlefield and then
you're not getting a surprise defender
opponent. you're putting that unit in,
it doesn't get the boost and then you
can pick apart the board from master as
well. So I think decks that are playing
the body domain with irresistible fay
folk, they are going to have a good time
in this tournament. They're getting
matched up against mastery quite a bit.
>> I believe you are correct. And let us
know viewers at home what your unleashed
picks or what would you have played to
this event if you're going using that #
rqut. We'd love to see and get your
opinions as well. I'm going to put you
on the spot here actually.
>> Oh, okay. If you were playing this
event, let's say you wasn't here casting
with me, I'd be very sad, of course. But
what would you be playing and why?
>> Yeah, it's tough. So, I have basically,
of course, also inspired by Ellen Zaku,
who started playing Diana a lot. But
Diana is a deck that is so incredibly
hard to pilot. Basically, in every
single matchup I played at local
tournaments, I have encountered new
mechanics that I have to know just to
play that matchup correctly. Like
>> for example, playing versus Master Yi,
the way you utilize your Vex is
completely different. It is really,
really hard. I think I might have still
gone for Diana, get a few more reps in,
but maybe in the end. Also, Rexi could
have been my call. Okay. Well, it looks
like Leo 175 players agree with you here
in our Eregional qualifier here,
occupying 10% of the meta share. But
again, as we sort of opened up this
round here, we said that it's sort of
been master event. We've seen it do
rather well here this weekend on stream
where we saw it do rather well there in
China as well taking one home but then
as we look at the rest of this um graph
here Leo any other surprises Ireelia is
dethroned
>> yes
>> the queen of riftbound is now down to
third place that is rather interesting
to me what I find very very exciting is
that Master Yi is top dog right now
because yeah
>> yes people said okay Master Yi with
especially Renga trophy hunter is going
to be so good in unleashed But people
have slowly but surely realized, okay,
the way people approach the master heat
deck,
>> it is a bit too slow.
>> Yeah.
>> And it doesn't give the player who runs
it the mo the biggest agenda over the
game, right? So you don't have too much
card draw. You're a little bit reliant
in some matchups on finding certain
cards like Defy versus Diana because if
you get Moonfold constantly, you're not
going to win that.
>> Yep. But people have found out that to
play the deck way more aggro and that is
so cool with Starring and the earlier
mentioned first mate combination with a
two drop where you can get those early
points assert a lot of pressure. People
run arena's greatest now in that deck
and that changes the this deck
completely because you're not giving
your opponent time anymore to find the
good cards to outplay you a little bit.
No, you're just rushing them down. Then
you also have surprise defender in the
end.
>> Yeah. And I think one thing I want to
absolutely really draw your attention to
here, viewers, before we get on to our
most played battlefields here in that
mastery. I'm a big fan of that ruin
runner. Quite honestly, it's one of my
favorite cards in the game right now,
and I cannot wait to build some more
decks around it. But Leo, we have our
most used battlefields here. Arena's
greatest, as you just mentioned. I
imagine a lot of those 30% will be in
the Master Y deck. Any surprises here,
>> Shay? Are we in an aggro meta?
>> I mean, you look at this and I think
it's safe to say we kind of are, right?
But I guess you do have the 21% and the
aspirants climb which is it's almost
like uh we're drawing battle with the
battle lines have been drawn here as it
were when you've got the 30% of the
arena's greatest. You've got the
Targon's peak and the star. These are
sort of battlefields that you want to
try and you know reuse units and slow
increase the game speed. when you do
have the aspirants clan base you're
saying hold on I see what you're trying
to do here and let's just make the game
one point longer.
>> Yeah I I think it's really nice to see
how they are complementing each other
because
>> there are so many games where one player
chooses arena's greatest and the other
player chooses the aspirin type and then
they basically nullify each other that's
like the only way you're actually
playing without proper battlefield
effects in a game if you remember the
arena's greatest.
>> Yes, this is true.
>> But also sunken temple on 13%. Sun
Temple is a battlefield which I figured
when I saw it for the first time in
Spirit Forge was going to be in so many
different decks because there are so few
battlefields that let you draw cards.
There was like the dreaming tree and I'm
saying there was because we're no longer
allowed to run it which gave players so
many draws in one game but sunken temple
can kind of do the same if you
consistently get those big units out. It
seems like maybe it's the one energy
cost that you have to pay because uh
people really like to use all of their
energy right now. It's it's a very very
tempo heavy game then just uh trying to
conquer somewhere is already always not
that easy and then also investing stuff
plus the one energy extra can sometimes
come back to bite you.
>> It really can. How many times have we
seen already on stream and I'm sure if
you guys play along at home, you've
already, you know, when you go to your
local, you go to events, how often that
one rune difference can, you know, make
or break a game. They haven't got enough
to defy or anything like this. So, you
know, if you do win a big long showdown
chain, have you got enough runes at the
end to draw a card of that so temple?
Sometimes not. But Leo, we have looked
at most played decks. We've looked at
most played battlefields.
>> Yeah,
>> let's have a look at most played units
and see what these players have been
cooking with here. And you know what,
right, Leo, give me a second to speak
now. Vex Apathetic. This card is
obscenely strong, right? We know this.
It slows the game down for your opponent
massively. It's got that deflect, but I
tell you what, viewers, quite honestly,
I despise this car. It is so [laughter]
good. Golly, I'm not surprised to see it
here at 37%. Leo, the floor visuals,
what else jumps out to you?
>> I'm not only going to say that Vex slows
the game down, it speeds it up for
yourself as well. If you actually get to
clear the entire board of your opponent
and drop a Vex, you're guaranteed a
double pointer. So, that one is really
strong. Of course, scuttle crab as well.
Cut immediately replaces itself in the
early game. you're going to get some
some some draws and some points with it
as well. But also just in the end game
to just throw your scuttle crab in, get
full information, and then knowing what
you want to play around is amazing.
Disarming rake at 30%
>> is very interesting.
>> Very high.
>> Yep. That Aurora counter number one.
>> Yeah, I mean interesting if we was to
take the disarmment rake there at 30%,
right? And then we look at Ash there at
90. I know Ash targets a lot more than
just um Dazzling Aurora of course, but I
think a lot of players are playing it
for that. We're looking at what is that
there? 49% just off those two. And if
you add action in the mix as well, who
again, you know, can you know maneuver
around more gear that's not just named
dazzling a war, but I can tell you now
that's what it's there for.
>> The players here do not like dazzling
Aurora.
>> There is I mean the if you could
separate the side decks from the main
deck, I'm sure we would have other
numbers as well. Akshan, a really really
nice unit for the main deck as well
because you can just play it out as a
vanilla. Of course, that is not ideal,
but having a consistent for drop that
doesn't necessarily cost you power
>> is kind of cool. What I want to turn my
attention to is the tight turn.
>> Yeah, I see what you did there.
[laughter]
>> It was also kind of obvious that of a
tight turner at 29%.
This card really didn't see too much
play in Origins and now it just got the
flexibility that it brings with
exchanging places, moving other units
also being hidden. That is just so much
value you get out of cards like Hui
or maybe a Stella Hera, right? Those
cards.
>> So this this card is absolutely insane.
You can also sometimes in Diana you have
your your units like Vex or like a
Ravenloom student but you know okay this
turn I'm going to have to invest a lot
of energy into my unit to overcome the
opponent and then you want to save it
for the next turn. So you play a tie
turner you're not going to get an extra
draw out of pushing your Diana back but
you know that maybe in the next turn if
your opponent takes your tie turner you
can go into the other battlefield and
then you can start predicting again save
that Diana get more value out of it. So,
Titf is such an incredibly versatile
card that can help you build up more
advantage, but also can help you build
up momentum.
>> Do you think real quick before we get to
look at our most used spells, you said
that Titoner wasn't played a lot in
previous formats, do you think with the
addition of ambush into the game, being
able to just quickly preserve something,
does has that had an effect on why Titan
see such an uptick in play?
>> Definitely. I mean, you have to have it
hidden somewhere to respond to an
ambush. That does come up sometimes. So
yeah, you have an away on the one
battlefield and then your opponent
decides to throw down a ring and you're
like, I don't want my way to die there,
so I'm just going to send the tie turn
and that definitely helps there. But I
think that the
>> fact that it is a two drop that you can
play to not lose tempo in the early game
and then get some more value out of it
or preserve cards on in the long run
predicting opponent's moves
>> is a little bit more of a factor there.
>> Okay, well sounds good to me. Now I
mentioned it and teased it a little bit.
Now, let's look at our most used spells
here. And to be honest, I don't think
there's many surprises here. Gustify
discipline. Star crossed at 38%
as well. Leo, talk to me. What's What's
jumping out at you here?
>> Gust
is so incredibly good. It's found its
way into so many decks. That's kind of
crazy actually. It's a huge counter to
Leblanc. Leblanc has kind of slowly
dwindled down in usage, but people stick
to their gust. So, it also has some
other ways like if you're playing Diana,
you have a lot of might modification to
push down your opponent. You can bounce
cards back then if they are not.
>> I mean, this is a great answer to a
punch first, right? So, that's that's
already where you win the game. What
else do we have here? We have Defy, of
course, it is the best counter spell
card in the game for sure
>> by landslide. Discipline is one of the
best combo tricks because you know you
just get a free draw. Stack deck has
declined even though it is an incredible
consistency card. Then I mean there's a
lot of combo tricks there. But the
uprise and sabotage is also really
interesting because the hand knowledge
is just key and decks like Master Yi,
they're like six cards to look into your
hand.
>> Yeah, sabotage one of my favorite cards
to play with honestly at Locals. Being
able to, as you say, get that free hand
knowledge and just before you start a
showdown, just rip away the answers is
things I like to see. stat deck as well.
Obviously, you said one of the best, if
not the best spell card in the game in
my opinion, for just letting you filter
through your deck in combination with
Fizz. Just using it over and over and
over again. So, yeah, that was our most
used spells. Let us know using that #
RQ. What's your favorite spells
Battlefield deck or unit? Just just tell
us all really. I can't wait to see what
you say.
>> Yeah. And what is your favorite unit? I
love the unit Renga pouncing for
example. There was a moment at the
Atlanta RQ, I believe it was, where
Prismaticism used it in the end game and
that was an absolutely wonderful moment,
perfect precision in that gameplay. And
why don't we learn a little bit more
about that?
This is a story about a big meta upset,
a story about technical precision. This
is the story about how a Reangar changed
the tides. Riftbound Regional [music]
Qualifier Atlanta, the last regional
qualifier before Unleashed release.
We're finding ourselves [music] in the
League of Draven. Chaos and Fury are the
domains to beat. A whopping 211 of the
1832 players brought Draven Glorious
Executioner to their tournament with the
hopes and dreams to win it all. Equipped
with Ferris Ferrunner, the undisputed
best unit in Spirit Forged [music] and
Rebuke as the best answer to it, the
mid-range deck proved as the most
dominant force in the tournament.
Winning combats with sticky units and
utility cards to [music] profit off the
passive card draw engine of your legend.
A snowball that once it starts running
cannot be stopped. The perfect strategy,
not for prismaticism. He [music] found a
way to play Draven's game, but more
aggressively. What the Draven legend
brings in value any doubles in tempo.
The meta centers around powerful units
and most importantly two energy cost
chaos spells flash hard [snorts] bargain
rebuke [music] and ride the wind. All of
those cards provide utility on your turn
and on your opponents. You can dodge
combat force points or protect [music]
your units with all of these cards.
While these cards provide similar amount
of utility, [music] they work in
completely different ways, which makes
it hard for the opponents to play around
all of them. Any the dark child readies
two of your runes at the end of your
turn, which allows you to always be able
to completely exhaust your runes in
order to play your biggest units and
maximize energy usage while still
keeping your opponents on their toes
with two runes up at least. But one card
in particular sets any apart from the
Draven decks. Rengar Pounce. The OG
Ambusher is an incredible offensive
threat, coming in hot with five might on
[music] attack for only three energy
straight from hand. While the offensive
possibilities that Renga as a champion
historically has are quite obvious,
prismaticism finds more death in the
cart, which brings us to the moment he
won his first regional qualifier title.
We are finding ourselves in game three
of the Atlanta Finals. The winner
immortalizes themselves in Riftbond
history. Prismaticis Moni versus
Challenger TCG's Koko Lopez on Draven. A
dramatic aspirin climb game in which
both players reach eight points.
>> Both players literally one point away
from being the regional qualifier
Atlanta champion. The tension [music] is
pulpable and the resources are few.
Prismat finds himself with five runes
ready. Looking at a Ferris forrunner
previously established in Koko's base.
Both battlefields are empty and
prismaticism only has a long sword on
his side of the board. The situation
look dire. The options in his hand
looked mediocre. A traveling merchant
for two and a pass immediately readying
his runes again. After thoroughly
thinking through all [music] the
possibilities and checking both players
treasures, he decides to only play a two
drop with no immediate impact on the
board state. It feels almost like a
concession. GG's were spammed in chat
already. Koko Lopez starts his turn by
trying to conquer the arena's greatest
to set up for a [music] winning hold
next turn. That was the moment in which
Prismat with haste slammed down the
right the wind pushing the traveling
merchant onto the other battlefield. No
answer from Koko. First the move [music]
trigger of the merchant happens
discarding the ferris forrunner to draw
another card. Then both players conquer
in their respective battlefields and
[music] draw a card since they cannot
get the victory point just yet. All of a
sudden the pressure is on Koko Lopez. He
needs to deny the holding point or
prismaticism will be crowned the Atlanta
champion. His out is just in his hand. A
falling star that he kept in hand to get
rid of the traveling merchant. But
again, lightning fast prismaticism picks
up his cards and throws [music] down a
defensive Renga pouncing onto the
battlefield.
>> And does Koko have the rebuke in this
instance? No. Prismaticism.
>> Immediately followed by a quick
concession of his opponent who fought so
hard to become a finalist. instead of
developing the merchant and another unit
who then later on try and deal with the
ferris 4runner. Prismaticism in this
tournament displayed how a risky play
style, playing the odds, and bravery can
catch your opponent off guard and
[music] win you a regional qualifier.
Well, what can I say? First of all, the
first thing I want to say is bravo Leo.
What a script that was. Almost if I was
there myself. I'm Sha B joined by Leo
and we're going to get ready for our
next Swiss round here at the Utre
regional qualifier. And Leo, we have a
pretty allstar match up coming up,
right?
>> Yep. You would have guessed it if you've
watched the video closely. There is a
good chance that Prismaticism is sitting
in the chair right now preparing for the
next round of the Riftbound RQ here in
How are you feeling, Shane?
>> I'm feeling very excited cuz there are
two other decks that I think are at the
tippy top of the metag game. I think
it's safe to say that I can't wait to
see how they get panned out. One of my
favorite uh combination of domains as
well, which we will get into more
details soon. But Leo, how are you
feeling as well? Fury and Chaos right
now is in an odd spot. You know, you
have these top players saying, "Hey,
Annie is one of the best decks in the
room, but nobody except for Prismaticism
really performs like crazy with the deck
anymore." So maybe this is a player
versus car situation.
No, that that analogy doesn't make any
kind of sense. Wait, I will I will get
back to this. But [laughter]
>> he is a phenomenal pilot, right? He is
the best player with this legend. As you
can see the swag wearing a best of any
around his neck.
>> Yeah, that's not a statement. All right,
just as you sit down for your photo
thinking, yep, I one of these aren't
many of them actually. And is obviously
a previous regional qualifier as well.
Well, and I think, you know, and he it's
actually it's a deck I would love to
pick up. You know, it's one of the it's
coming from the starter sort of set as
it were, the proving grounds. Um, with
that really strong legend ability that
comes up almost all the time and it just
means you're never really safe,
>> which means we are going to have a very
two and fro game. And one thing I said
why this is one of my favorite two
domain combinations. Even though you do
say not a lot of players outside of
Prisma are actually doing well with it
is because it's got the combination of
draw power. It's got the combination of
denial and removal and it's just got
some of the best spells in the game.
>> Yeah, there is some different sorts of
counter spells. There's star cross to
play around something like actually
starcross plays around almost everything
but really stops an elder drake there.
still on that triple Renga pouncing
which is interesting because you do not
see this in basically any other list not
even in a Rengar deck.
>> Yeah, have of course the Inferna and
other cards from Unleashed. Next to the
abandon is Grim Apothecary and Vex
Apathetic. Those cards are really really
interesting. Funnily enough, he is not
running the Starring which is a cool
card to combine with Grim Apothecary.
>> Yeah, that's literally just what I was
looking out for there but doesn't play
that. But this is where, you know, it
just look at all these options. You even
got Noxus Hopeful coming in for that
nice Legion. You got Clear for the big
swings stat deck. We saw it in our most
played spells just letting you search
through your deck. Well, not search for
your deck, you know what I mean? Look at
the top three, grab one, and you've got
Flash for some big defensive plays as
well.
>> The deck looks so incredibly basic,
right? You have some good units that
bring you some momentum as well. Ferris
Forrunner feels like a card with
basically every deck playing Star Frost
that shouldn't have that much impact
anymore, but it somehow of course does.
You're playing cards like long sword
just for for good stats because
manipulating your own runes is so
incredibly powerful and gives you so
much momentum. And then we have his
opponent Mercia running consult the past
which is an interesting tech that we
have also seen before. And Frigid Jewel.
Frit jewel is a card that we have last
seen in Vancouver from Dwali in the top
four match versus Allen's EQ. And this
card of course really helps you in
certain matchups. Like if you get to
draw multiple cards, you of course trade
much better into other cards. You have a
ruin runner on your opponent's side, not
that big of a deal anymore. However,
if you're playing Dana Minro matches,
then you're going to have some issues
there because acceptable losses and turn
to dust all of a sudden have targets to
hit. So FR jewel comes at a risk because
in some matchups the main deck gear
removal is just completely useless. It
>> really is. So here we are going to get
started at our Swiss round four feature
match here at the Utre regional
qualifier. There is our fist bump
mulligans have been concluded and it
looks like Mia is kicking us off here
with the big the bad the scary Diana
deck. It's just going to be two now for
that traveling merchant and it is over
to Prismaticism. Let's see what he can
cook up. Triple Fury rune into that stat
deck. Not a bad card you want to see at
the start of the game. Now you look at
top three, put one in your hand, recycle
the rest.
>> Yeah, going second. It's so hard to miss
the two drop just because you have stack
deck as well.
>> And how many are we running? We're
running traveling merchant. If you have
the stack deck too, you have the Noxus
hopeful of course, but you also have
inferna and overzealous fan. So those
are all cards that you can definitely
hit on your first turn. If you're
starting the game with only two runes,
that is a little bit much more of an
issue.
>> Just wanted to say for merger, they're
only playing one copy of the traveling
merchant. Done pretty well to get that
into play. We are going to see that
stack deck concluded. And in case you
don't know, Andy's legend ability, the
main reason the deck is played is cuz at
the end of your turn, as we are going to
see a noxious hopeful come down thanks
to that Legion, is that you actually get
to ready two of your runes, making it
one of the best, if not the best
defensive deck in the game, letting you
fire off responses on your opponent's
turn. It's over to Mera. Now, four runes
open to play with. playing that Diana
giving you an extra energy to use in
showdowns making it very scary in
combination with her way letting you
move her way around get to a ridiculous
amount of might and just ask your
opponent questions. Leo, what do you
think of iron up here? Looks like
traveling merchants move.
>> Yep, trigger's good.
>> Traveling definitely not the worst card
in the deck. The question is what you
want to develop next. If you're just
dropping the Vex now into the base,
right? Way we're not quite there yet
when it comes to the runes. If you're
just dropping the Vex into the
battlefield, you are giving up your
>> Oh, merchant, right? Because then you
can only use Diana ability and then
stupify it and that is going to bring
the Noxus Hope down to three. So,
>> it's interesting. Are we going to see a
saved traveling merchant with something
like a flash, which is still a card that
is quite costly, or is it just
immediately a positive trade? It looks
like Nas hope for has come in and sent
that traveling merchant traveling all
the way to the trash as it were.
Prismaticism still got five runes open.
All fury runes. Keep an eye on that one.
Don't know if that actually matters too
much here. It's like inferno's being
eyed up here. Play to base and then a
three. The grim apostrophe as well. All
into the base, meaning that if merger
decides to develop that champion unit
into a battlefield, it can get rolled
upon really fast.
The Grim Beth doesn't really necessarily
want to be played in base, but the the
battlefield we're playing on right now
is the Rockall path, so can't be there
anyways.
>> Oh, there's that fridge jewel that you
mentioned.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, ST deck is being found immediately
and that is triggering the frigid rule.
So, we are already at five might.
>> Wow.
>> Long sword. Long sword coming down
there. The activation as well.
Immediately the ambush equipment. Back
over to Mia now on the priority. Still
got four runes open. There's a lot to
play for here. Stat deck. Can we find an
answer?
I mean, stupify is a good one.
>> Stupify helps us trade. At least it
doesn't really solve the entire
situation yet.
>> It doesn't. You'd rather not try and
lose your Diana here. letting you filter
cards throughout the game with that
predict letting you churn through your
deck. I was thinking it safe say Diana
is a bit of a combo deck so it needs to
see cards to have its responses. You'd
love to get more use from this Diana.
What is Mo going to take
>> in this matchup? I love the frrigid
jewel.
>> Yes, just trading for momentum and
you're going to get some advantages
every turn basically. And this is such a
good ride. The wind unanswered from
prismaticism.
>> Wow. Okay, they show them that is
basically saying, "Okay, rockfall path.
Nothing's going to happen there." But I
can push my Diana ready into the seat of
power. Get a point there and then push
her back into base as well.
>> That is a really good
>> How many cards in your hands?
>> Escape.
>> And let's not make it. She did take the
moonfall, I believe, from the predict as
well. Keep an eye on that one. That
signature spell that manipulates mit in
a maze way is over to Prismat now,
though.
>> Here we go. But what can he cook up? We
have a star cross, cleave, grim aposphy.
Not the most craziest of cards here.
Star cross, one of the most impactful
cards there from that unleashed set. It
looks like
>> Inferno moving in for the conquer.
>> Seed of power is going to give you
another draw. Now the question is, is
are we pushing back the Noxus hopeful
from the rockfall path? Absolutely we
do. and is
>> play another grim pick up inferno.
>> Play a grim and gets the inferno back to
hand for some more followup. The
question is are we developing that one
too? Yes, we are going wide against
Diana. Always a good idea. That's a
frigid jewel. That's a threat to your
trade. So, you better leave those
battlefields open with a little bit of a
point advantage.
So, you can already see where the game
is going if Prismat can still dominate.
So it is over to merger now. Let's see
what she can do. Has to have a quite
look at this hand.
>> Is that perhaps a good turn to develop a
way?
>> I think that seems like a good idea to
me. We are just going to see the conquer
first. Going to see some extra cards by
that predict on that ability.
>> If we're going to use even, we can use
the
>> legend ability.
>> Yes.
Moonfall is currently in the hand. Don't
forget. Looks like this is going to be
the Haye. It's looking like
>> Yeah, we are at a critical point when it
comes to runes here. If you use the
Diana predictability,
>> then you are going to be down to two
runes on the opposing turn without your
Diana ability.
>> You are very correct. [laughter]
>> Whatever happens, you cannot star cross.
And I think that is one of the best
interactions that you are having if you
want to save your own units as well.
So, we have developed a way which is
looking like it might stick for a while
unless
the star cross of prismaticism find its
way into this way.
>> Attack.
>> Love what you did there. Nox hopeful
charging in to that Diana there. We are
going to see something being played
there. It's going to be the
>> Oh,
>> the smoke screen I should say.
>> No, I won't put it through.
>> Wow. That could be the perfect timing
for a star cross bounce way to b to
hand.
>> Let's see if that's what Prismat chooses
to do. Party has been pathed back. That
smoke screen. Is it minus four? I
believe. Yep. Minus four. An incredible
two drop in my opinion.
>> Yeah, cost the power. So it does hurt
your grind game a little bit.
>> Does cost the power.
>> Play medicine.
>> Oh, but we are going to get the response
cleave which will pop cuz it is the that
is the attacker. An extra three now. And
it looks like yep we are going to
conclude there with Diana getting sent
to the trash. Prismac getting a big
conquer.
>> Prisman at this point is just really
overpowering his opponent. Going to
almost certainly take that fifth point
as well. Draw a card of seed of power as
well. Really making the most of this
battlefield. The Rockfall path not
there's the star cross just as you
mentioned going to remove that way which
is one of the Diana's biggest weapons
currently been reset back to the hand.
go away back to hand seat of power and
that is such a great play having that
cleave used on the noises hopeful
because then again you are not going to
hold on that seat of power and he lacks
some card draw sometimes if you can draw
multiple cards in the next turn that
would be the
>> third draw off of seat of power that
would be absolutely incredibly
>> useful here okay inferna and a traveling
merchant as well you mentioned card draw
traveling merchant obviously get you
there as Well, Prismat with four units
currently in the base, two runes open.
Back over to merger with a bit of an
anemic board, it's safe to say right
now, but has got a lot of runes to play
with. I think that was a Vex apathetic
in the hand. Could could have lost its
usefulness now though. What can Mia do?
>> We're also only at seven runes. So, that
means that Quay and Fizz into Write the
Wind is not even a possibility. That is
also something that you really really
need when you want to catch up on
points, catch up on trades, take some
units out of the side of Prismaticism
because Prismaticism
is just chilling there. Has four units
developed in base. The tempo is all on
his side. Of course, he has fewer cards
on hand, but what does that matter?
Every single trade that he can make is
going to be almost favorable for him.
And he has cleared out the entire B
state of his opponent. just I know Vex
apathetic going to come down now.
Obviously really really strong when it's
in a battlefield slowing your opponents
down, stunning them and not letting them
move. But you're right, the key to this
match up is going to be getting that
weigh in play and moving it around cuz
it's ability triggers whenever you move.
Not only letting you filter through your
deck, but depending on what card you
discard from its ability, you can either
draw an extra one ready two runes or get
an extra three might letting you just
quite honestly bound through
battlefields and score points, which I
think is going to be the key to victory
now as Merger falls behind. Here comes
the Fizz. Oh, and Fizz, if I heard that
correctly, wants to go for tactics. So,
digging for cards while completely being
tapped out. How much is that going to
consult the past? Could be hidden. So,
that would be something. But Stupify can
also work with the Diana
>> legend ability.
>> And it is just going to be the pass. Leo
back over to Prismat going to hold for
six as well. This is getting scary.
There is value in tempo. You have
bounced back the Huay earlier and that
of course does not feel as good as just
permanently removing it.
>> Is Merch ever going to have time to play
it again?
>> I'm not sure. I said I think you know as
we said I think Vex apathetics
usefulness might be closing but I think
you're right when you're currently
what's that four points down as it were.
That way is going to have to be moving
you know all around the place to be able
to try and get merger back into this
game. And we know that Annie love can be
very defensive as well if needed. Here
we are going to see four runes and a
recycle.
>> Wow. There's for the Annie going to let
you grab back a spell. Did you see what
it was?
>> Was it the star? Of course it would be.
And a nexus hopeful coming down as well,
Leo. Oh no,
>> the offensive
>> and still has five open. Sorry, Leo.
>> That is so incredibly well played.
Asserting pressure the entire time on
seven runes. And it feels like even
though there are at times not many cards
and then feels like you're playing
against all of the possible options but
because of this any legend ability
always readying those two runes at the
end of the turn is so strong. Another
frigid jewel but how is might going to
help you at this point
it's going to be very very very mighty.
The problem is not only is there double
battlefields develop but let's count
them up folks. 1 2 3 4 five units in the
base. We are going to see Vex apathetic
attempting a conquer here. Will that go
through?
>> Yeah,
>> we are. Oh, sorry. We haven't seen
priority pass yet. Stupify.
>> That's going to reduce the might down by
one on the nexus hopeful and draw one of
course.
>> And then we have the double frigid dual
trigger.
>> Triggers.
>> Yep. Triggers.
>> And there we go. That's going to be just
enough to hop this Vex up here in this
showdown.
>> All right. So there is a chance that
prismeticism utilizes the long sword
that he has picked up earlier and plays
another one.
>> Oh, there you go. Right on Q that
assault
react.
>> Yes.
>> Equipment an extra plus two.
>> I'm at seven now. Six to five. Six
against seven.
>> Six against seven.
>> And you can just see how important this
decision is as our players are really
going through it here.
any response. This could be game
defining
>> things as we know that there's star
cross in hand for prismat. Now if merch
needs to lets this go vex just dies
combat lost if mista has to play another
card you can still starrust later on and
you can still interact and save this
card.
>> Okay, so we are going to see a moon. So,
it's looking like
>> that is playing around the star cross at
least a little bit because yes, you're
pushing inferna, but she's at zero.
>> So, here we are back at the showdown.
I'll play flash.
>> And there is a flash just securing all
of those units. Not even the inferno,
but saying, "Okay, you're going to have
a favorable trade in the other
battlefield as well. I would rather give
up Inferno than the Grim Apothecary.
And I think he gets out of this combat
relatively safe. Merch gets a point,
denies acceleration in the next turn or
ambushing.
>> But there are so many units in base
already.
>> Yeah, that's the thing. I think Prisma
did rather well there. Identifying out
wasn't going to get out of that
showdown. So instead using that flash
defensively to preserve those units for
a massive big late game push. Merger Mzo
I should say. What else can she do here?
>> There is of course it's Oh, are we
hiding a card? That can potentially be
huge. That is a unknown factor for
Prismat to play around. However, there's
double frigid jewel still on board for
me. So every stupify can make a five
might difference or at least once,
right? It also works on the opposing
turn, right?
>> Thank you.
>> Oh, it's a second card, right? And you
draw your second card each turn. So you
would have to use two stupifies if that
is somehow possible.
>> Well, let's see if it is over to Prismat
now on that seventh point. So in order
to win this turn would need to conquer
both. Can he do I mean looking at this
looking at this board state? I mean it's
not outside the possibility but let's
take our time. Let's work this out.
We have the stack nexus hopeful. We have
another nexus hopeful. We have the Annie
Grim Apostrophe times two.
Look at this absolute unit of a Noxus
hopeful.
>> Yeah, I know. Double uh long sword
again. Imagine the mental image of that
Nexus hopeful. He's charging in for
glory.
>> What do we have in our hand there? I see
a start. Okay, here we go.
>> Will we see a response?
Tie Turner
>> and no switch.
>> No effect.
>> No effect. So it's going to be two on
what is it now? Two on No, no. Four on
five, I should say.
>> Yeah.
>> Cleave.
>> And the cleave comes through for the big
assault free. Prismac clears off for
that showdown. And it looks like Is that
a concession?
Is that a concession? Yeah, it must be
>> very much.
>> Yeah, that must be a concession there as
Prismat will take game one. It's looking
like MA unable to win that game one.
Prismat going up game one going into
game two here.
>> Oh, and would you look at that still
saying, hey, I want to look at your
trash one more time. Take some notes
knowing which cards you kind of played
[music]
>> and then saying, okay, there we can
>> go. Prismat taking game one versus Merc.
Some of these players make it look so
easy, man. The any deck is so incredibly
hard to pilot. It looked like it was a
bunch of
not too hard decisions, but the
precision behind that is incredible.
Just
knowing when to go aggressive, knowing
when to force out cards of your opponent
is incredibly tough. Just the sheer
knowledge that you can pressure a lot
with the long swords from your hand
while you still have cards to retract
your units in those situations with the
Noxus Hopefuls. Every time Mercer was
pushing in, he presented long swords,
which you know, even if you lose the
combat, they will still hold value.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you're forcing out cards from your
opponent, and then when those cards are
expended, energy is expended. Flash,
star cross, push those units back, keep
the might added bonus from the long
swords in your base, still have them in
play while your opponent will lose the
might, will lose the extra
>> O that was added to the units.
>> Perfect. It really is a fantastic
masterclass there in Fizz Max. As we
look at this graphic, I want to draw
attention to something here. We have the
legend favor 45% versus 55%. Nashes if
you was to take overall matchup data.
All right. So, looking at that, Dana
should be slightly favored. However,
when we go down to our win prediction,
which takes into account more than just
raw matchup data, legend matchup
performance and player current recent
form as well, the overall strength of
Prismat with this anid deck pushing that
to a 61%
win prediction,
>> but Mercia of course having to play
against such a strong hand as well. And
this is
>> good point. Good point.
>> I think put up a really good fight so
far. So, I'm quite curious to see how
this goes after sighting. I don't know
how prepared players are going to be in
their side decks versus the any decks
because I I can imagine that something
like an extra moonfall if you're only
running two is a good idea.
>> Yeah, it looks like it's interesting
one. I don't think anyone is going to
side deck particularly or specifically
for Annie. I think you're right. Um, if
you're Prismat though, we saw the frigid
jewel times two that can get a little
bit intimidating. Do you think you if
Prismat wasn't to play any gear hate in
his main deck, are you potentially
starting any in or no?
>> It depends on the gear hate. I mean,
we're playing Chaos Fury, the gear hate
in those domains.
>> I mean, there's thermmo beam, which is a
great card, but against two frigid
jewels, I mean, you're losing runes on
that, and your opponent will have
already utilized it. You're you're also
paying five energy, so that is more than
your opponent has ever paid if you take
out two.
>> Yeah, good point.
>> And your factory recall as well. I I
don't even know how many other removals
are there. I just know that chaos decks
tend to play other acceptable losses is
also something that you could run. I
don't know if we're doing that, but that
that is a card that I can see
working
in that matchup.
>> And here we are going through the side
building phases, side boarding phase, I
should say. So integral in a game of
rift riftbound. you know, it can make
it's almost like if you win game one
with your sort of main deck, the
strength that you have to sideboard for
game two and three, meaning that, you
know, if I'm now going second, but I
have my answers can quite honestly
really flip a match up. So, I think if
you're Prismat now, you must be
thinking, okay, I'm feeling quite good
going into this now. Yeah, going back to
the sideing process of of gear hate,
even a card like acceptable losses would
feel very much reactionary against a
deck like Diana just saying, "Okay, I'm
a bit afraid of your trades with Frigid
Jewel."
>> And I don't think that is how the deck
wants to necessarily play. I think you
want to push your own agenda and relying
on your opponent to draw the Frigid
Jewel and not discarding it with
something like the Huay to get some
extra runes up at the end of the turn
does not feel like in any play. So I
don't think we're going to see that
necessarily.
>> I think you're right. I mean looking at
that game one prismat really wasn't on
the oh no I'm scared of those frigid
jewels, right? It just said here's my
times two nexus hopeful one of which
holding two long swords and you know the
rest of my army as it were charging at
you seem to work rather well. But yeah
this any deck whenever I see Prismat
play honestly Leo I'm just so impressed.
It makes me really want to build this
deck and try it out myself. I don't
think I'm as clever as Prismat though.
He may make it look easy folks but trust
me it's not.
Yeah, I'm a big fan. Two of my favorite
domains as well.
>> Yeah, also I still want to play Annie.
Still looking for a third Kaiser,
>> but I haven't quite had the bravery yet
to bring that to a tournament just
because I know it is a deck. It feels
like it has low ceiling
or rather high ceiling, low floor.
>> Yes, I agree.
>> And you would have to play it to such
precision.
>> Mhm. It's like one of those decks you
can put a 100 hours into and then you're
still not half as good as
>> which is what I think we saw in our
graphic where it said the overall legend
match up with Anna was favor. I think
you know as you say super low floor if
things aren't going right with Annie
you're twiddling your thumbs as it were
but when it is in the hands of a player
like Prisma it can be scary but let's
talk a little bit about Mer then you
know obviously game one didn't quite go
her way what do you think is going
through her head right now
>> I think Mer needs to find some outs to
units in base something like a
singularity that has risen in popularity
in Diana side decks recently just
because it's so good in the mirror match
take out away
>> can also help here because Prismat has
won this game by just saving units has
won this game by going with apethecary
and especially also something like a
flash to preserve these units from
combat. If you can stop him from going
wide in the base, I think that's the way
to do it. So starting with a tie turner,
which is okay. That's uh every time I
see a tie turn, I'm opening hand. I'm
like, well, I at least I didn't whiff
turn one, right? You still have it, but
you would have rather seen a or the
>> Raven Bloom student. And this is
something I want to draw attention to as
we are going to see the nexus hopeful
come down with the stat deck and it back
over to merger. Merg has chosen the
battlefield of that um Tyro Argon's peak
I should say. Now that readies up two of
your runes when you conquer at the end
of your turn.
>> Really going to have to try and keep
Prisma off that cuz that's going to
really play into his [laughter] into his
battle plans as well. Essentially
letting you get up to four runes ready
at the end of your turn. But here we are
going to see the nexus hopeful charging
into that tie turner after the Diana
champion unit coming down for merger.
Let's see what she can do.
>> The Tagon's peak makes it so much easier
to defend that battlefield. So it's it's
like a snowball effect immediately when
you have it. So you're starting your
play with a two drop. You push into it.
You get to develop your Diana and then
you still have three runes up for energy
together with the Diana legend ability.
So therefore, you can very well prevent
your opponent from getting into this
battlefield. However,
Prismaticism had the golden start of
stack deck plus Noxus hopeful again,
which is a incredible two drop with
Formite. So that is getting harder and
harder. Another stupify is another card
invested. I mean, it replaces itself,
but still it cost you a little bit of
energy. [sighs]
>> So now we're looking at a what a two two
right after two stupify. Now we see that
Prismat does have a long sword so can
use that to boost up the noxus hopeful
if he desires of course.
>> I do see inferno as well. We see is that
two long sword actually
>> I think that's a flash and
>> yeah flash and the inferno. Yeah.
>> So
maybe he's thinking to just give up that
Noxus hopeful say okay you've passed the
priority.
Oh no the super fire still has not
resolved. So that's also something you
need to think about. But maybe you're
saying, "Hey, I'm going to trade evenly
here and develop a Kai'Sa or a Vex in
base."
>> Sure, that resolves.
>> And that's exactly what it looks like
happening. That is going to resolve.
We're currently at a
>> Yep.
>> Yep. A two two which is going to be the
trade.
>> There's so many cards that could even
punish him for the long sword play. If
you're then encountering something like
a smoke screen or an Eclipse, no,
actually just smoke screen. Eclipse is
not available anymore. At that point,
you're going to have some problems.
Develops the Vex even instead of the
Kaiser just perhaps to play around
Moonfall a little here because of the
deflectability.
>> Yeah, that Vex apathetic, our most
played unit here at the UK regional
qualifier.
>> Activate.
>> We are going to see Dakum charging in.
Can use your champion ability there of
course to predict
>> the legend ability as well.
>> Yep. If you want to forge the future,
you got to consult the past.
>> Wow.
>> Don't even know if that makes sense
semantically.
>> You love that from you. That was
>> Raven Bloom student coming down. That
card can get out of hand.
So can two.
Anything else?
>> That is a big investment after we have
pushed our Diana into the Tagon's Peak.
But I think with four runes open, you
kind of can afford that. Oh, plays a
traveling merchant as well. Opens up two
runes.
>> So, we might see prismeticism here,
forcing a bigger trade this time around
with a potential long sword if there is
a reaction from Mercia.
>> Being only at two runes also opens up
hard bargain plays.
>> We are going to see the showdown now.
Then, Leo priority has been passed.
Currently at four versus three. I'm sure
Mojo would love to keep her champion
Dino around. Let's see if she has a
response. Oh, I can see
>> be smoke screen.
>> Smoke screen coming down. That's a minus
four. One mind run and one chaos for the
deflect.
>> Pretty costly card. Basically the cost
of a rebuke almost.
The question is what does Prismatism do
against that? I like the aggression in
this play of Mercia.
>> I really do. You're one game back. You
can't be letting Prismatism have his
way.
Looking at that hand, I only see a long
sword as a response or the flash it's
looking like, right? Or the inferno, I
guess, as well. But you'd love to keep
the vex apathetic up.
>> I think so. I think that Oh, wait.
Completely tapped out. Could be inferno.
Long sword plus flash.
>> Okay,
>> this one resolves if you're going for
>> Oh, yeah. Of course, the Diana is only
at three might and we're trading versus
the still a conquer from prismmeticism.
And it looks like we are going to see
Kisa coming down there as well. That
fury staple
>> and we'll open up an additional two
runes
>> from that Annie ability of course is
over to Mia
who has a whole treasure trove of units
to play with here. Raven Bloom student
times two and a traveling merchant.
Let's see what she can do here. Only one
game back
>> here in our Swiss round for feature
match.
>> I'm quite confused actually that the
inferna is still there because Vex was
at zero might. No. And Diana was facing
versus a
>> Yep.
>> Inferna that has
>> three might. So I I I guess you cannot
overkill there. I think you have to
assign one damage to the zero might vex
to kill it and then you can only assign
two more.
>> Yeah.
>> Trigger.
>> Yep.
>> So we are going to see traveling
merchant going in.
>> Yep.
>> Draw one. Discard one.
There's that frigid jewel again.
Frigid jewel times two.
Now the thermmo beam doesn't sound as
bad.
>> I told you, didn't I? That thermo beam
would be quite And we see a hidden card
as well. Okay,
>> I think
>> this is getting interesting. This is
getting interesting here, folks. Over to
Prismaticism.
>> It looks like the defensive wombo combo
for Mercia with the frigid jewel and
consult the pass which will in fact on
the opposing turn trigger the frigid
jewel for for mightite point. So that's
kind of neat. flashing the Kaiser and
the Inferna back to base.
Now, are you pushing both of these into
the Traveling Merchant starts with just
the Kaiser
>> Consult the Past as an resolves and then
we're going to see some jewels that are
very, very frigid.
>> Oh, wow. What a nice interaction that
is. The hidden consult the past giving
you plus four.
>> Long sword is going to match that. So,
we're both at six and we're trading. No.
Okay. Okay, okay, okay.
>> Long sword times two. Here we go.
>> Now we're at 9 to6. It's looking like
>> should be 8 to six.
>> I say it should be eight. Yeah, I just
want to say it.
>> So the is
>> I'm not the I'm not the best at math, so
these always take a little bit of time
for me.
>> Neither am I. Leah, I can tell you that
for free. But it looks like Yeah, that
is going to go through there. Traveling
merchants sent to the trash. And then we
get the draw one from the zone ruins as
well.
>> Zone war.
>> Star.
>> Gets rid of the star cross.
>> Finds another card. First draw was from
the Kaiser conquer actually.
>> Yep.
>> ST deck. Looking at the top cards again
after this big investment of two long
swords in one turn.
>> Mhm.
>> We're going to possibly unless we're
dropping this Noxful, which it kind of
looks like.
>> I think it Yeah, you have to. As you
say, you use so many resources now just
to be able to get a four might unit down
seems quite nice to me.
>> Okay.
>> And at least you can ready up two of
your runes as well. Strong turn there
for Prismaticism.
>> The battle of the board continues. Is
over to Mia.
>> Prismaticism might have gone up to three
with this. Yeah, but now Mia is already
having a big turn here. Double Raven
Bloom Student with double frigid jewel
and a stacked deck is immediately going
to pump one up to seven if you want to
push it with both of those jewels. So
this eight might Kaiser which in a
tempoheavy game with only two two drops
on the board should be incredibly
impactful doesn't look like it's going
to necessarily cut it. There is there is
ways to get these Raven Bloom students
up to way more might. Honestly, whenever
I see these Raven Blue students just go
from like what their two base up to like
as you say 810 and beyond, it's honestly
terrifying. And it's not, as you say,
with the Frigid Jewel, with all the
cards you're playing, it's not actually
that hard to do coming in with one of
the most premier two drops in our game
right now.
>> It's terrifying, Leo. Honestly,
>> yeah,
>> I love this match up because it feels
some kind of fundamental.
Yes, we are going to see coming down
there now as well. Going to use stupify.
That's going to be some more ammunition
there for the Raven Bloom students of
course
>> and you get to draw one as well.
>> Now we get the frigid triggers.
>> That's ridiculously
>> kind of especially with the stupify.
That is a clean trade if there is no
interaction in hand. Sometimes you need
to play to your outs. If there's only
one card in hand of prismaticism, yes,
there are two runes open. That doesn't
mean that there is an interaction. Gets
an incredibly favored trade here to go
up more points. Also taking over that
Targon speak.
>> This right here is a massive turn there
from Mia. Clearing away that Kaiser with
a double long sword, conquering both
battlefields and starting to get ahead
here, which is what you need to do in a
game two. And we haven't used the Z
warrants yet. We're of course still
going to just do that in this turn, of
course. Finds a new card. Interestingly
enough, keeps hard bargain in hand,
which is a card on low card amount of
your opponent with very many runes
>> is that is really hard to utilize. Now,
of course, we're using that is just
immediately going to basically kill the
Noxus hopeful there in base. Of course,
it has moved to the Zorn's Warren and
then has been killed in combat, but that
is not too important right now. I just
love the flash. Having the flash,
>> it's going to make
>> prismaticism's life really hard. Also,
all of those long swords that want to be
equipped at some point.
>> I can see the hard bargain clutching
things out in the end.
Only two cards in the hand. Yeah, just
the Kaiser and the hard bargain. Not
really. I mean Ka's obviously very
strong right now. You can try and
develop your double long sword Kaiser or
just a long sword Kaiser but
>> it's going to have to be Kaiser against
the world. It feels like here
>> we are going to see the showdown now
into the Raven Bloom student. There's
the flash as you said going to preserve.
Oh, there's the hard bargain coming in
though.
>> That is absolutely huge. Isa conquering
over that Raven Bloom student, getting
the first draw, getting another point,
and then Inferno is going to have a nice
time eoing there. The biggest question
you have to ask yourself now as
prismaticism is do you want to invest
the long sword before in case there is
something like a stupify because one
rune is still up. Equips the long sword
hits for five. That's a huge inferna and
then is going to trigger that z's
warrants responding to that with the
inferna playing into the battlefield so
you don't have to discard and you can
draw for free now. Targon's peak and any
trigger four runes up prismaticism out
of nowhere is absolutely back in this
game. This game has been a battle of
back and forth. Mer clearing both
battlefields last turn of prismatism
said hold up wait a minute let me
challenge you back there as well. over
to merger now does have the hue in hand.
I think if Mer is going to be able to
close this game out currently is tied
will need to start getting that way
moving around the board.
>> Very good for Mercer that prismaticism
is only
>> at five points. Can afford to let him
double hold there.
>> There was an argument to be made to push
the Fizz into the inferno battlefield
that there isn't going to be an easy
hold there,
>> but decides to keep that unit around for
a potential double conquer in the next
turn. I think that is one of those play
to your win condition moments and
prismmeticism is asking eight
>> reun you at five.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> You're just making sure. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. Then perhaps we are going to
see a full-on retreat to threaten game
next turn. Although seven is always very
tempting to try and hold.
So the legend unit could be being
debated.
Moving back to base.
No, we're not. He's teasing me.
[laughter] Teasing us, I should say.
It's not just me viewers as well. Come
on.
>> Messing around with all all of us.
>> They the signature prismaticism move.
>> Head in the hands.
>> Here we go. Okay, so we are going to
retreat back to base. Are we going to
see the Annie coming down? It looks
like.
>> Looks like we are going to let you
return the spell. Target was the star
cross.
Who needs fizz if you have any? Am I
right? Because then you don't even ever
have to recycle the card.
>> Drops another traveling merchant for a
potential power push next turn. Can find
more cards. Has the star frost available
to him because of any the dark child.
>> All right, so here we go. Prismaticism
is you know threatening game next turn.
It is on to Merge now to try and stop
him from doing that. currently has four
runes open as Bismac going to start us
off there with a showdown
>> into the into the battlefield there.
Draw one cuz of Oh, does get a ride the
wind. Leo, that right there is a bit
naughty.
>> Considers to
drop the Vex.
I think at that point trying to find
more defensive cards by discarding
something like the hard bargain could be
a very viable option. I think it's
>> these decisions that can make or break
games. Quite honestly, it really can.
Looks like our bargain has been
discarded. Gets to draw another one.
>> Oh, and that moonfall.
>> Absolutely huge. So, this could be
pushed into zone warren. So, you're
going up to six. And then you have how
many runes? Eight, I think.
>> Yeah, we're going to dig for another
card then with the zones warren goes up
to seven. because the score merge also
very very close to winning this game.
Something like a Vex apathetic would hit
really hard, would deny so many top
decks.
>> Oh, it looks like the the Vex is getting
discarded though, Leo.
>> I can see that as well because you want
to find more spells. You want to have
more flexibility. Keep in mind that
there was a star cross and we have
another Vex anyways.
>> Oh, we have a second. Okay, Vex Athea
slowing down Prisma. No fancy
shenanigans next turn. moving units into
the active. They will get stunned into
active into the battlefield. They will
be stunned and not unable to move.
>> On Merc side, I'm a little bit worried
about the amount of might that is
already on the side of prismaticism.
Yeah,
>> there is a inferno with a long sword.
>> Mhm.
>> That is five offensive might, six from
the Kaiser, three from the Annie,
>> two from the traveling merchant, and
another three from Infern. I'm sure you
calculated all of this. Give me the
total.
I [laughter] was just thinking he's
going to charge them all in there
really, aren't you? But yeah, you're
right. It's a lot being developed.
>> Martha's for defenders.
>> What's that?
>> Martha's for defenders. Just
>> Yeah.
>> But I have to say, M's done a fantastic
job here of, you know, making life as
hard as you can for Prismat.
Very curious to see five runes open for
Mercia, which means
that you can only moonfall plus ride the
wind, not all of those together with a
stupify. And but the stupify can be
crucial. If you write the wind over the
way, draw a card and then discard the
stupify, you will get to draw another
card, trigger the frigid jewel. M.
>> So what I imagine prismmeticism needs to
hold the star cross for
>> is the way as a response to a right the
win scenario. Does he see that?
>> That star cross pick up from the will be
huge.
>> Both our players really debating on what
to do here.
Make or break decisions.
>> God, this game is so much fun.
>> It really, really is. It's so much more
for and I just have to talk about it and
not make these decisions myself. I can
tell you that for free.
Remember this merger needs to win this
game to try and advance to that 4 and0
record. Bismat currently one game up.
>> Okay.
>> Sorry.
>> Oh yeah, we have the target on speak.
That was just the end step. So we have a
lot more possibilities.
>> Okay,
here we go. Leo one point to take for
Prismat
will have to conquer both battlefields
of course has a ton of might on his
board. Has the star cost available. Does
have the grim aposphy as well for what
it's worth.
But remember there is the Vex apathetic
down for merger as well. Keep an eye on
that one.
But for now, power play Prismat. What
can you do?
Perhaps
a good way to approach this would be to
try and force a trade with the Vex
>> Sun Kaiser here.
>> Okay, we're not going to do that.
First thing that is going to happen is
the stupify onto that Kai'Sa to level
this up. But I could imagine, yeah,
prismaticism passes immediately.
You're in a recycle.
>> Oh, that is a Moonfall. That is
dangerous territory. Moonfall trying to
push in.
>> What's the text on Moon with the long
sword?
>> It resolves even if they no longer have
a unit there.
>> Oh,
>> I hope so. That's a [laughter]
>> prismmeticism.
He's getting some clarification on
exactly how this moonfall will resolve.
>> I think that's uh I mean we everyone
here knows that he has the star crossed
in hand from Annie returned in the
previous turn.
>> So
I understand the question to the judge.
>> Mhm.
>> Also saying I hope this still resolves
even if the unit is no longer there.
[laughter]
And I really understand why because if
you bounce that way and you still push
the inferno, then that is so much might
that you are off, right? The long sword
is stuck under this inferna. It is stuck
under that
>> kaiser. No matter what, if the the unit
is no longer there
or does it need to be a battlefield
where they have units in order to
resolve?
>> Valid question. A very valid. I'm there
waiting to hear the answer myself if I'm
being honest. I need to know the answer
myself.
>> But as you say, you don't
>> this inferno.
>> Yes. Okay.
>> Yeah. You really don't want to have to,
as you say, waste that might from the
inferno plus long sword combination,
especially while it will have the the
assault trigger as well.
>> And these are the decisions. These are
the players, you know, that separate the
good from the great players and the
great players from the worldass players.
Okay,
>> still currently maybe waiting for a
judge ruling. Oh no, I think we are just
uh starting to resolve star cross.
>> I think we Yeah, I think we're getting
back in the mix.
>> Is [sighs] it even worth it now?
So this will be
three and three.
>> I think just no matter what happens,
star crossing the way is going to solve
a lot of problems because then Mercia is
not really likely to trigger that
trigger jewel.
>> Yeah, I can resolve.
>> Okay. Okay,
>> all these dice are weird.
>> Moon does resolve
>> two.
>> Kai'Sa is now
>> six against your five
>> three
>> and inferna also still is making this
quite awkward because she is also
attached with a long sword. So
overpowering that way
and that would have to be followed up
with a right the wind. No, I don't
really see a way in which you can come
out of this here. No, but Merch reaches
over saying I can't get out of this one.
The moonfall
>> really didn't put up enough.
>> Yeah, the ride the wind might it put the
might down.
>> Yeah,
>> but not enough. It was still six to five
where he couldn't get out of this.
>> Wow. and Frismat getting a quick game to
win. They're advancing in this round
four match going 2. They go to that
perfect 4 and0 record
as it was to be expected by one of the
best players in the world. There are so
many rift bounders that claim that he is
the best of the best. in fact the best
player in the world and he has shown
that once again a long long thoughtout
decision in this scenario about the
resolution of the moonfall saying hey do
I even want that do I want to go for
some starcross shenanigans then in fact
saying hey just going to get the conquer
this way and then if I get the conquer I
can use the star cross on something on
the other battlefield I can take out the
the vex and then we're cooking
>> yeah and that's what you think as we see
the sort of replay every turn was so
meticulous you know the Noxus hopeful
coming in there again with the cle that
was a big turn there for him to sort of
win this game one emergency said that
was enough now we saw the you know the
frigid jewels come up quite a lot in
game one and two but you know
pismaticism just saying okay I can just
dance around them don't worry about it
this was a back and forth going game
though merger put up a valiant effort I
think it's safe to say really made life
hard and made Prismat think as you say
with that signature hand in head in
hands I should say but again just been
able to weather the storm reload in
those runes thanks to Annie's ability
and was just able to eventually clutch
this game out.
>> Agreed. I think you are really putting
up a good fight if you get prismaticism
to put his head in his head. I think
that's that's the sign of a really
really good game of Rift Bone that he is
sitting there and he really has to think
the turn through. But in the end, just
the developing of units in the base
versus these vexheavy decks like Diana
as well with combos, it really helped
and also it did help him quite a bit
that the way was drawn this late in the
game like a a way that is developed
early and cannot really be stopped. It
is tough to handle also for an any deck.
>> Yeah, when that way just starts moving
around, you know, going from base to
battlefield to base to battlefield,
stacking that might and drawing you a
ton of cards at the same time can go out
of hand. Again, if it does turn up late
though and your opponent just has a lot
of units in base and says you can dance
your way around your way around it, it's
fine. When it sticks to the back, it's
my turn. I'm charging in my Noxus
Hopeful with my double sword and we're
going to have a valiant effort. Yep. And
someone who charged in some Noxus
hopefuls in those games. Game one, game
two, stack deck into Noxus Hopeful.
Fantastic performance by Prismaticism.
Let's hear it from the man himself over
to Barrett and Prismatic.
Thanks so much y'all on that wonderful
cast. And of course, I have the
privilege to be joined here with the
Prismaticism regional qualifier
champion, of course, the Annie man
himself. You're officially halfway
through with the day. You're 4-0. I feel
like I have talked with you a billion
times. So, I got to ask you across the
day as a whole matchup wise, how are you
feeling? Because I feel like if I ask
you about Diana specifically, how many
times have you actually practiced
against Diana?
>> That's pretty much all of my practice,
honestly. But yeah, other matchups I
played against Azir and I played against
an Aurelia and both of those went pretty
well overall. Um I think there were
games where it was it was pretty close.
My opponent probably did make me miss
some mistakes which let me back in the
game. Um but I capitalized on those and
then got the wins. Love it. I mean like
I said halfway through the day, you
know, I feel like a lot of your tougher
opponents are of course, you know, once
the bracket gets a little more closer
into each other, all the undefeateds,
there are still some heavy hitters in
this room. You said his ear. We know
that Pedro or, you know, Squirtle is
still roaming around. You know, another
regional qualifier champion. There's
still plenty of you in the room. But I
have to then ask a follow-up question.
That was a great performance. I think I
think your your match the ad adaptations
and the long swords like extra of them
now in the deck I I think is a really
strong choice and you really showed it
off even in that game where we were kind
of talking about how you know we thought
it was going to be a detriment of
spending that power so early but the
fact now that your units are so much
larger now to combat against these other
decks. Do you think that's maybe a shift
even for like the master y that are
going to be mainly in this room?
>> Yeah, it makes a big difference in a lot
of matchups. Like in the endame
situations I get the six points, my
opponent's defending, I get to cascade
the weapon. It's a ton of value. It
helps me protect my battlefields against
Rengar. I don't need to flash out. I can
just fight him with the long sword. It
was just a card that I should have
noticed or realized sooner. I was happy
every time I drew it. Who cares about
the runes? Like my units are too big.
And even in that that second game, I was
thinking, "Oh, I'm I'm really far behind
on cards. This is not looking great, but
I have these long swords in play.
They're actually extra cards in play
that are a lot of value."
>> It's not one card. It is as many uses
you get to attach and equip it, of
course. So, my last question before we
hand you back to the rest of your day is
um I got to ask, have you done any
push-ups today?
>> Not yet. I did one like quick arm
wrestle. I I lost yesterday and then uh
well, I knew I would lose. I went
against Grappler. That guy's massive,
but it woke me up. So, good. Good. Well,
again, fantastic. Always great chatting
with you and getting a little bit more
into the the the hair in behind the
brain or the brain behind the hair, I
should say. But thank you so much,
Presentism. Good luck for the rest half
of your day and I hope to see you in day
two. But we'll send it back. Thanks.
>> Thank you so much for that, Barrett.
Yeah, we had a lot of hair in that
winner's interview actually there.
Barrett has luscious locks himself and
we love hearing from Prisma as you do
say a lot. Can
>> you tell us about those from?
>> Yeah, I haven't quite got the locks
myself, but I do get this close-up shot.
Thank you Production. Yeah, not quite as
luscious as Barrett and Prismat there.
So, it doesn't look I don't look as
majestic when I have my head in my hands
and I'm thinking hard like that. But, as
you say, it's really great to hear from
Prisma. in many people's opinions, the
world's well the best uh riftbound
player here. So, it's great to hear from
him.
>> But we of course have another feature
match that we can bring to you every
time the first feature of Magic is over
rather quickly. We have a backup match
and this time around we're in the League
of Rogue again because this if I am not
mistaken should be a Victor versus Ka'ix
match game three.
>> Okay, now this is an interesting one.
you know, two decks that, you know, not
surprised to see, but, you know, not at
the tippy top of the meta game. Um, it's
safe to say, you know, that Victor being
able to quite honestly make a cornucopia
of tokens, whether it's recruits or the
birds as well from the car dredger
there. So, this is going to be really
fun as well. It has a lot of good
interesting things with, you know,
hidden blade, cold the week, thousand
watcher, singularity, rages of pain,
bellow's breath combination. Honestly,
can get out of hand rather quick. There
is one card that you didn't mention that
for me tip the
>> Oh, what's that?
>> Back into the next level. That is the
safety inspector.
>> Oh, of course. Yeah, you're so right.
Actually,
>> five energy, one power has the cull the
weak effect unless you can spend three
XP, which is never going to be the case
in that deck unless your opponent gives
you XP for free. I don't know if that
somehow works. However, this card cannot
be defied. Yeah.
>> Therefore, this is a blowout versus
decks like Urelia, like cuts like Ruin
Runner, decks that sit on it for too
long. you can just
safety inspector get rid of the camel
and then you win the game.
>> Yeah, quite honestly that card is
terrifying. But speaking of terrifying
cards, that legend of that caric worth
noting that caric champion has been
seeing a massive uptick in play recently
and here we get to use it for our
fullest effect. And again, this is a
very tricky deck as well. I'm looking at
Rengar. I'm looking at Irresistible
Fairfolk. I'm looking at Star Quest,
Vex, Lucian, Axan, and of course,
everybody's favorite, Punch First in
those showdowns. I am the biggest Lucian
Merciless fan. I I like the alt art a
little bit more, the High Noon Lucian.
That is an absolutely gorgeous card, but
the ability of this card to just score a
point and then immediately dip out again
to open up that battlefield is just
unmatched. kind of sad that we don't get
to see way more of this card in Unleash,
but I think the best deck that utilizes
the body domain is Master Yi. And in
Master Y, you don't necessarily want to
leave your battlefield open, right? You
want to come through the the stats that
you're getting passively from your
legend. But I like it that it is used in
Kha'Zix because Lucian can actually it
can do so much. You can dip into
battlefields, then you can go into
another battlefield with another unit.
there. You use the Kha'Zix. You push
both back and every single turn you pick
apart more units from your opponent
until they can't match squads with you
anymore.
>> Yeah, it sounds like it's going to be a
really fun match up as we do get into
our game three. Who is it going to be?
Is it going to be the Lucian and the
Kazix just dancing around the
battlefield? Or will Victor's recruit
army be enough to weather the storm and
inspect the safety and make life as hard
as we can for Ace? We are in our
mulligan phase here. Of course he kept
illusion my guy. [laughter]
>> He would keep an eye on illusion there.
He loves a bit of Lucian.
>> Okay, it looks like we are going to kick
us off there. I think that is Arena's
greatest. It's looking like immediately
getting on the board. We're not missing
that one. I can't quite make out of a
battlefield Leo. What is that one?
>> That is the forbidding waste. If you
hold there alone
are or if you're defending there alone,
you're getting minus two.
>> We begin the game.
>> I see. And that's going to work really
well with that champion unit caric where
if it attacks or defends an enemy unit
as a lone you get a plus two as well.
>> Three
shot one
>> and we are starting on the side of
Kazix. Not immediately using the legend
ability to buff
our unit.
>> So there we go. Victor's going to get
that recruit in play. pass.
>> And then
>> some people might have already seen this
play.
>> I can't quite make it out what that one
is.
>> It's the honest broker.
>> Honest broker, I should say. I
apologize.
>> Now is back over to Ace. Oh, we're going
to see a sabotage.
Interesting.
>> That's very, very early, but I suppose
versus Victor, that's actually not that
bad. Wait, that is horrendous.
>> No hit. That is wild versus today.
>> No sabotage being done there.
>> But we do get hand knowledge.
>> Yeah, see safety. But trading hand
knowledge for not only one energy but
also for a power is rough.
>> See another upside of the safety
inspector.
>> Um
>> can't get sabotaged. That's that's just
how easy it goes. It's just still
sitting there. So all of a sudden Victor
has the board presence because of that
extra token. The two draw plus a token
on turn two is strong. But we have the
Lucian as an answer.
>> Chinese
>> Lucian just going into the forbidden
waste and then dipping out of it is
really really strong. I I really like
how the deck plays. At which point are
we going to see a buff on the
>> diplomat awaken?
>> Never.
>> Not yet. So we are going to get back
over to our now
>> our victor player. Let's see. Was that
singularity off the top? was
>> that is a huge card versus Kha'Zix,
especially when their rune economy is
already in shambles because if you go
for a
>> turn to sabotage
>> that DMs you early, you have to
capitalize on it. That is not a card
that you can just throw around
willy-nilly.
>> Complicated.
>> It is. If you play this card, first of
all, you want to do this at a point
where your opponent has a lot of cards
or where you go for important pushes for
the game. But if you just start
developing and you sabotage, you know
what's coming in the future turns. You
cannot play around everything because
they're going to before you go into deep
combats. They're going to draw three
more cards.
>> I was thinking, who do I sacrifice?
>> And then you're also going to be at a
massive rune deficit. Look at this.
>> Sometimes in war, they sacrifice
>> exhaust five to two points.
>> We are going to see a push there from
the traveling merchant. We are going to
see the legend ability. You'd love to
far that singularity now, but currently
we haven't got enough runes for that,
but you are right. Keep an eye on that
singularity. There's no what's the word
restriction on where it can target. Do
six to two of your opponent's units.
That is wild. Here comes the Cameron
Dredger.
>> Love that card. It's a very good card.
It's like a It's like a baby Oh, what's
it called? The Met guy. What's it called
again?
>> Let's crank.
>> Yes. Like a baby. One of them letting
you get some bird token when the carryon
dreger.
>> I don't understand how that works
lawwise that you get a bird out of this.
>> I think I think is isn't he like a bird
keeper? It looks like in the artwork or
something. It's a little bit of a bird
keeper perhaps. That would make a lot of
sense.
>> Let us know using the hashtag RQ if you
think that is the case. But it is over
to Ace now starting off with a stack
deck.
>> Yellow will get
>> so even I mean stack deck is always a
good card to plan your future turns.
However, you are giving up quite a bit
of tempo if you start your four rune
turn with this. Look at this. There is a
Renga trophy hunter in hand that cannot
be played this turn anymore
>> because of that sabotage. the double
faith fo plus fist combination not
something you necessarily want to see
especially
>> because if you don't want the card at
that moment but maybe at a later moment
you are recycling two of those fay folks
so you're basically almost never going
to see them at all
>> oh we're going to nice play picks up his
cards checks if he wants to respond with
something like a stupifier or bellow's
breath because one card was not known
for ace was a singularity I'm sure that
knew that he couldn't do anything but
he's bluffing a response
>> then
there you go there's your Lucian going
in and out of the battlefield as it were
traveling merchant also
>> going to conquer
>> and then I ace diplomat
>> dip I apologize
>> push him out
>> you're good
>> and there's the legend activation I'm
going to move it back love that play
there
>> and for four
>> we still got our runes to play with what
we see
>> developing our horror yep that one goes
to Ace and that one might feel the
punishment if you are at seven runes and
your opponent has spent all of those
runes to develop units in base.
>> Could this be the singularity turn? Oh,
we got call the week as well.
>> Oh, that I think that could be way worse
than a singularity turn. It could be a
singularity plus recruit token turn.
>> I think so. That big bad scary
singularity doing six to two of your
opponent's units. We're going to see
Carol and Dreger charging in. We are
going to see the recruit charging in.
Is this going to be singularity? I would
love to see that right now. One. Yeah.
>> Oh no. No. It's the recruit. Oh, that's
fine.
>> He's teasing us. He's teasing us.
>> That's six.
>> Here we go.
>> That's three.
>> That's three more.
>> There it is. Oh, and he's got the gold
token as well from the honest broker.
So, that is not even super costly. Takes
out the Kha'Zix mutating horror that
wasn't even played to a battlefield.
Takes out the Lucian for flexibility.
>> And he's still up in runes.
>> Wow. Leo, quite honestly, could that be
the gamedefying turn right there? That
was so much value. Two points plus an
essential board as it were. Just a
diplomat.
>> Okay.
>> Against Ireku and the world.
>> Unless you cheated.
[laughter]
>> I would never.
>> So bad.
>> That would be funny. That would be
funny.
>> At least Ace is in good spirits as he
stares down this horrifying board state.
>> Yeah. I think Diplomat will trade with
the treasure. Yep. Going to leave a bird
token behind and then Arena's greatest
could be a possible Rengar target.
However, we know what's in hand. Ace
knows what's in hand that has such easy
counterplay. Will you even go for the
Renga here or will you give away a whole
point? Because if you throw in the
reengar into the arena's greatest
because of the forbidden waste, diplomat
will just be traded away for a recruit
or a bur token and then the safety
inspector just trades off the rena for
free by tributing a token. So
>> yeah, and you know the safety inspector
is in hand from that sabotage all the
way again, right? So
>> some players will get punished at some
point, but it's even harder to make them
when you know they're going to get hard
punished.
But sometimes, especially when you have
hand knowledge, you know, there's no
really good space.
>> Mhm.
>> Yes. I'm one XP through the combat, but
it's a tough situation for a hunt. You
really on the back foot here. Still
hasn't start all the rooms open for this
turn. No. So far,
>> what else should you have in hand? Does
he have perhaps a Lucian? That would be
a card that could help. But anything he
develops
>> can be just immediately taken out by
just removing one of those tokens.
>> That is
I find it very wild how we're constantly
switching up the runes we want to
exhaust. I find that very cool.
[laughter]
>> Nice hand movements with the cards.
>> Just debating. God really making a tough
decision here. So that's going to be
>> just oh three three in a cycle. It's
looking like
>> are we developing another Lucian or are
we playing the Fizz that we have perhaps
picked up from the stack deck earlier
next to the double irresistible fault?
But Fizz only finds a stat deck, I
believe, at this time, right? Which
>> or another sabotage.
>> Or another sabotage. Yes, that is true.
I mean, that would be really risky,
though.
>> None of this seems particularly great.
>> No, I think you're right. It's not like
those Fizz are picking up any game, you
know, swinging cards as it were.
We are really thinking about this
though, aren't we? I mean, this is tough
when you're on the back foot in a game
three. Every decision really does
matter, folks. Especially when you're on
stream stage, lights, cameras pointing
at you. It's very different than playing
at your local. I can tell you that for
free. But we are going to see three
enemy cycle
>> and it is going to be the fizz to the
battlefield.
>> And I will attempt to cast sabotage for
one.
>> It's going to be a sabotage.
>> And it's actually going to hit.
>> Yes, the caler. I have to target the
caler week.
>> Just call the weak is the only target
there.
>> My safety and calig. So I I I hit the
calder of course. Bottom two.
>> Bottom then. Exactly.
So now I have to spend this experience
to buff
this one.
>> Yes,
there's the buff finally. I've been
waiting for this.
>> You've been waiting for that buff.
You've talked about that.
>> And you have your vi.
And I just love being able to hear the
players talk out these impactful turns.
Ace know he's on the back foot, but he
knows he needs to really sequence this
stuff. And that's exactly what he's
doing.
>> Now the question is yes, you have two
units in the forbidding waste. So there
is no might deficit from that
battlefield. However, you also want to
develop something is you don't want to
give recruit tokus too many holes.
>> No, exactly. You don't really want to be
letting them play a resistance if and I
just pass.
>> Oh, folk is interesting. The thing is,
you also know that there is a VIP
peacekeeper right on the side of that's
just pushing one of the tokens in there
and then throwing the VI peacekeeper in.
Then you're going to have six to six
might and you can take both units out if
you want.
>> Hold on a second. We have the Imperial
Decree combination. Is that the math
right now?
>> When a unit takes damage this turn, kill
it. It's essentially elder dragon. So
you could charge in well both your
tokens into the Fizz and the Imperial.
>> You had four points. You had five.
>> Thank you really. Oh, we're going to
play the Zen Xiao first.
>> Then we can still hit him with the five
energy cost cards. Y Imperial Decree.
Oh, safety inspector. Everything that is
very well on curve from Kenzo just at
the right time.
>> Yeah, he has hit everything. It feels
like at the right times
has a lot to play with here. What's
this? Three, no, two recruits and a bird
token yet to move.
>> I have never seen a Victor player this
far ahead in runes in my entire life.
>> No
charges in first. Head first.
>> Not even
>> trying to. Maybe we are going to see a
VIP keeper soon.
>> Just to keep both of those units. I
would love that play just to be
>> I kill you.
>> Nice.
Okay.
>> Okay. So, that's going to conclude.
>> Fizz going to be hitting the trash.
>> But now you can trade with a token
because of the waste.
>> Yes, you can because of the waste. Move
reducing the might by two.
>> Yes, I do.
>> Crew can just charge in as you say. Open
battlefields.
>> Oh, here.
>> Yes.
>> Goes up to six. The question is, do you
I think you just develop the inspector.
No,
>> they won
>> at this point.
>> Or you make another token. Could also
consider Victor leader.
>> Yep. Goes wide in base. I love that. Not
caring about the irresistible fa. What's
it going to pull in anyways? We do know
that Ace does have a Rengar in hand, so
could get sneaky with that.
>> But I like this play for my record
there. just go and wide, build up the
might and say next turn I'm going to
snatch this game free away from you
>> versus Renga. That could have been a
really really cool line by developing
the safety inspector, taking away one
unit from the battlefield and not
allowing your opponent to play something
into battlefields and then rather having
him to react with the rea so that
whenever you push a token into one of
these empty battlefields at six points
and they use a reanga, you can imperial
decree and then conquer with two others.
So that would have been a a cool way
perhaps. I don't know if it if it would
have fully worked out with the amount of
tokens that you have because you would
have had two.
>> Yeah, cuz Yeah, you are right. That
would have been absolutely amazing
though. The Imperial decree onto
Orangar,
but Ace,
you can tell, is really having to think
this out now.
>> Honestly, I think this line is way safer
>> for sure. Oh, 100% 100%. That is why is
currently, you know, at this 3 and 0
record. He knows his way around his
Victor deck.
Here we go. What has Ace got?
>> Oh, we're going to buff the
[laughter]
>> strong start.
>> I move here. I take a recruit
one.
>> I get that's an easy trade.
>> I conquer to five.
>> Gets the XP back.
Yes,
>> everyone knows Kha'Zix is way better in
the early game.
>> Yeah, the longer the game goes on, the
more the Kha'Zix decks grasp on the game
>> definitely lowers. Oh, okay. Yeah, with
all those runes open, I think it's safe
to say can fear there must be a Rengar
knocking about. We all know that against
body players with that many runes open,
get ready for that Rengar ambush. Can
our Reku
clear off the fair? And now that is
still an incredible Imperial decree turn
or VI peacekeeper if you want. Also
>> ACS only at five points so that is very
very chill.
>> Yeah
>> or he can go for a push with the VI
peacekeeper which is very very low risk.
>> And even if there is plus the Rena
another one energy card in hand that
puts the oranga in unconquerable range
for VIP peacekeeper plus a token.
You just recall all of your units and
then you try again next turn when your
opponent is at seven.
>> So many options just the most important
turn.
>> Oh, right. It's fine.
We will finish the game even if we go
into time. So, uh it's okay.
>> Both players realizing, hey, the game is
so close to the end. Even if we're going
to time out,
>> the game will get the game will conclude
no matter what. Yeah,
>> but I think Yeah, you say so many
options. You have the VI, Imperial
Decree,
Safety Inspector, all of which are valid
at this moment in time right now.
>> Sometimes it's easier if you only have
one push.
>> Yeah, exactly. I agree.
>> You don't have to care that much about
which line is the most perfect one
because most of them honestly at this
position if that's only Oranga will get
you there.
>> Yeah, that is true.
But we don't blame our players for
really thinking out each and every
decision.
Looks like Imperial decree is being eyed
up here. I love this card.
>> Play decree.
>> Here we go.
>> Pushing in one token. Trading with the
faithful. Pushing in another token.
Expecting the ring. Trading with it. And
then going with Victor leader for game
might be the plan. But there might be a
response from ace
>> and the safety v and nixen is gone. How
much? Two more.
>> Imperial decree.
>> I don't know. Okay. Means when any unit
takes damage this turn, it will be it
will be killed.
>> Have to uh
>> we see a response. Oh, is that a hard
bargain?
>> Wow.
>> Wait a second. Wait a sec. If the last
card in hand that we don't know, I mean
doesn't have to be a last card. There is
a rebuke in hand. I don't think this is
over. But of course, Imperial Decree has
one loose condition and that is getting
counter spell.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So that hard bargain I reckon
decided not to pay the extra. So that
Imperial decree will fail.
>> Make a guy.
>> We are going to get another recruit
coming down
>> and that has really changed the temper
of this turn.
>> Another two being eyed up here.
>> Yep.
>> See? Oh, he's passing.U is playing it
safe. I like the sound of that.
>> With an incredible repeated hard bargain
saves himself another turn. holds up to
five to six and in the next turn.
>> Maybe conquer in the waste. I'm not even
too sure about that
>> because how how are you getting there?
You can't render a trophy hunter in
there because no unit is being played
there.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. I don't mind that for my record
being okay. I was going to make my push.
You made it a bit harder. Let's take our
time. I've still got the point lead.
Let's not get too ahead of ourselves.
And the pressure, make no mistake about
it, even after that great hard bargain
is still on Ace here to respond, you
know.
>> Yeah, it still looks incredibly
difficult for him. Oh, that that hand
motion looks like a pass.
>> It is a pass.
>> It was a pass. Okay. Okay. Over to Areku
now
>> on seven points.
We'll need to take both of these if he
wants to win exactly this turn.
>> That's the card.
>> What was the card? I didn't see it. That
was hidden blade. And that is an
incredible card in a situation like this
where your opponent tries to grab the
last straw to sit on one unit
>> and hope that it's enough, but then you
can take it away. Give them two draws.
Who cares about that anyways? Gets a
conquer point, a conquer draw, not a
conquer point because we are always
>> you can't win off a conquer. You got to
conquer both battlefields. But with
hidden blade currently in hand, that
could be, you know, not a ridiculously
hard thing to pull off here.
Four what? Uh, three recruits.
>> Wow. I recruit is considered.
>> Oh, there's a safety inspector.
>> Does that just not
>> Oh, yeah.
>> possibly remove the fairy folk and he
charging in theory. Rengar could come
out. Of course.
>> Okay. Which one?
>> Takes off the token. Yeah, but now he's
only left at three runes. Has the hidden
blade if comes down into that
battlefield.
>> True.
>> But maybe there could be another counter
if there's another hard bargain in hand.
Oh, he's going to
>> Okay, so we're trying our we're trying
our luck here, Leo. Oh, there we go.
>> So, this has to be the Rengar response,
right? We've seen this in hand already
>> to play Rengar.
>> There's the Rengar.
>> Now, more runes will have to be expended
>> for the hidden blade. Take out that
Rengar trophy. What could be
>> That's enough. could still draw too
often too often. Hidden blade might keep
accepting the game.
>> Um,
>> he keeps repeating that's enough. That's
enough.
>> Unfortunate draw. Really? Yeah. You have
it. You have it. GG.
>> And there we are going to see Victor
taking [music] a round for feature match
B. Our winner will be Aku.
I reckon he played that pretty well,
huh? That was a really, really strong
performance there with the hidden blade
in the end.
I would have loved to see, you know, my
prediction there was the VI peacekeeper.
I would have loved to see a vice
peacekeeper play as well there, but he
just played it so calmly. Had this big
hot bargain where some players would
have been like, "Oh my goodness, no. Did
I play into that?" No, he just kept calm
and said, "Okay, you know what?
>> You will hang on this round. I will not
overcommit. I will not try to forcefully
win this turn. Yeah,
>> I will just push more units into base.
Carry on dredger. Another recruit token.
Push my other recruit token back to
base. And next turn we will try to push
again. Won the game of that. Really love
that for him. Well played.
>> Yeah, fantastic play. You know, as you
did say was going to start pushing with
that Imperial decree. As soon as that
got counter, players might start
panicking and be like, "Oh, let's see if
we can reduce this board state." He
said, "Okay, you well done. You've had
your counter. Congratulations. I'm going
to take a turn off. You You've had your
fun now. Next turn that'll be my turn."
And he walks away with that game three
victory, advancing to that 4 and0
record. Also, shout outs to Ace for
really nice sportsmanship. Very very
very polite communication of the
players. They're always in good spirits
saying, "Yep, that's good. That's that's
enough. You got this." And no matter
what happens, we're going to play this
game out. Really love that. They seem to
have an incredible time just like we
have right here at the RQ and we are
having an incredible time here watching
those games together with y'all. And uh
in Germany, we say giving our Zenfatsu.
So, we're giving our mustard to the
situation. I realize now that this
translates horribly into English.
[laughter]
>> I was waiting you to translate that and
you say mustard. That wasn't quite what
I was expecting to hear. But yeah, we're
having a great time here at our UK
regional qualifier. Let us know your
thoughts and what you want to see and
what your highlights have been using our
# RQ.
But I think we are getting ready for an
interview now. I believe let's hear
let's hear it.
Thanks so much for that excellent cast
here with our second feature match for
round four with Ereku taking it down
with that Victor legend all the way from
Origins. And I've got to ask you, we've
learned that Victor is actually like the
sixth most represented legend in the
room and you're doing really well with
it and proving maybe why. Why is the
deck good right now? What has changed?
>> I think it went from like Btier to A
tier because of Squouch Fountain. That
card is insane. It gives for two runes,
six might accelerated. And of course, I
think Arena's greatest is like a
automatic win for you for Victor because
they go so fast. You can play two units
on a second turn. And I think nobody can
do that that well except maybe Rengar.
>> No, that makes a lot of sense because I
feel like in my brain when I think about
how Victor was being played in the early
days, it wasn't necessarily as
aggressive as it is now. and these arena
greenness being added in for the
battlefields. The sprite fountain makes
an excellent decision on having that
accelerated unit to get onto these
battlefields. And you played that match
so well against another deck that I
didn't necessarily think was going to be
doing so well, but this Kha'Zix and
there's quite a few of them out in the
field. Is there something that you're
looking to avoid in the matchups for
Victor? I'm I hear that, you know, I
play Azir and I think I have a pretty
good matchup into that deck and there
are quite a few good players out there.
So, are you trying to dodge a lot of
these sort of calm decks? I would love
to dodge the Azir, but all the sideboard
is made for Azir. So, I think I'm
prepared for him also. I would love to
play a good Azir actually because it's a
fun experience. Even if I lose, I just
want the experience.
>> But you're not losing yet. You're 4-0,
halfway through the day now. Only a
couple more rounds to go and you can
lock in a day two. And I hear this is
only your second regional qualifier now.
So, you're really starting to make a
name for yourself. How does it feel that
you're this close to moving into day
two? It actually feels so good because
in my first regionals in Liil I didn't
do so well but I didn't get discouraged.
I brought Victor again. I actually
thought about bringing Leblanc. Same
colors but other champion unit but still
I thought no like maybe not Leblanc.
It's too hard for me to pilot. I take
Victor go fast try to win more games
than the previous qualifier and have a
good time. And I don't know how it goes.
and I can't think of a better way to
have a good time than going 4-0 in the
first half of the day. So,
congratulations, Aku. I wish you luck
for the rest of your day and maybe we
might see some more Victor Nation later
on today. But for now, we'll send it
back.
>> All right, then. You know what? I love
that interview hearing about, you know
what, I don't want to play a
communicator. That's like the block. I
want to go past. I want to hit hard and
win games. It's going well for him.
Currently, 4-0 at his second ever RQ.
Things you love to see. But there's also
some other stuff that I love to see that
is more rift bound competitive action. I
tell you what, don't go anywhere. We're
going to have a quick little video and
then we're coming at you for our Swiss
round five.
>> [music]
[bell]
[music]
>> Dream.
Dream.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
[music]